Okay, the State Board will convene and we'll begin with the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America, and to the Republic for which it stands, one nation, under God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Okay, we'll begin today with the report of the superintendent.
Thank you President Kurtz.
Thank you members.
Good day.
It's a good California day, right?
And I'm looking forward to today as we get another look at our ESSA plan and I just want to say at this point in the day, thank you to the great work of our teams, the California Department of Education team, the State Board of Education team,
who have worked so diligently, so cooperatively and creatively, so hard to get the ESSA plan to where it is today.
So we get another chance to discuss ESSA.
Other updates from our last good meeting?
One is an initiative I launched.
We call it Global California 2030.
We're still celebrating the amazing passage of Prop 58.
73% of Californians agreed on something.
They agreed that the antiquated barriers to bilingual education should be removed.
They said yes to dual language capacity, and yes in realizing that we are in a fiercely competitive global economy, that the globe is continually shrinking.
The interest and demand for dual immersion in language programs has skyrocketed.
In May, I visited Coanga Elementary School in Los Angeles, and to a great example of a dual language school.
This is a Korean immersion school.
Again, looking how can we expand our language capacity in all of our schools in California in the way that Coanga School is doing currently.
This is a wonderful example of where I believe all California schools should be going, expanding the teaching and learning of world languages.
Our goal is to dramatically increase the number of students proficient in more than one language by 2030.
I want to thank everyone who attended, including Monica Garcia, the chairwoman of the Los Angeles Unified School District, and Superintendent Austin Buechner, who endorsed Global California and committed to making LAUSD a strong partner in implementing the goals.
Specifically, we want to have by 2030 half of all K-12 students participate in programs leading to proficiency in two or more languages.
At least quadruple, we want to at least quadruple the number of students who receive the state seal of bioliteracy on their high school diplomas.
demonstrating proficiency in more than one language, going from nearly 50,000, as it is today, to over 200,000.
Our goal is to quadruple the number of dual immersion programs that teach languages besides English.
And so, again, a lot of great work has been done.
I want to thank
Elena Fajardo and Veronica Aguilar and Tom Adams.
I don't know if anybody any of them are here.
Tom Adams is here It's his division who spearheaded this details of this plan and this initiative and I thank all of them and I want to thank the EL roadmap committee because they paved the way so to speak they paved the way for this initiative and for further public focus on the needs mostly
Very much good news in the state budget.
Legislature approved the budget with more than $78 million of Prop 98 funds.
In the eight years of Governor Brown's administration, Proposition 98 has risen by $30 billion, and it's been driven, thankfully, by a recovering economy and voter-approved taxes and a keen focus on balancing the budget.
Prop 98 per-pupil spending will reach about 11,600, up more than 4,600 from just eight years back.
Then it was only 7,000 per-pupil, now it's 11,600.
This is hugely significant progress.
However, California still ranks 43rd in the nation in per-pupil spending, so we have some distance to go.
The budget also makes nearly $83 million in investments in the state's new accountability system and capacity building within the statewide system of support.
Thanks to all the advocacy here from President Kirst and your team and our team working together and working with the governor.
This is a recognized need, the state system-wide support.
Other education highlights include extending the career technical education incentive grants.
creating partnerships between local businesses and schools to train students for high demand jobs.
The budget also includes $300 million to help districts develop strategies to raise achievement for low-performing students.
Another $125 million will go for teacher recruitment and training with a focus on special education, STEM, and bilingual teachers.
There's also
An area that I hold close as a very good priority is the classified school employees are amazing partners in schools day in and day out.
This initiative, however, allows those who want to move forward to get a teaching credential.
There's 45 million set aside so our classified employees can become teachers in the schools where they've worked.
A budgetary that still needs working on, in my opinion, much work on over the rest of this session is funding for mental health, for intervention, counseling, professional development, to identify students with needs.
Everywhere I travel up and down the state of California, speaking with teachers, speaking with students, speaking with administrators, speaking with parents, I hear increasing concerns surrounding the level of help available in counseling and professional development
and the increasing concern about the number of students with depression struggling with the idea of suicide and homicidal anger.
I hear this concern from teachers again around the state and three weeks ago I spoke in Washington, D.C.
at the American Foundation of Suicide Prevention
And we went over the horrific statistics of California that the federal CDC just came out with.
45,000 deaths a year, Americans, mostly young Americans taking their lives.
They reported a shocking 25% increase in the last two decades.
So my staff has prepared, and I'll hand this out, a fact sheet on the mental health statistics and the challenges we face.
And I urge us all to work together and invite any of you who want to help
I formed a working group to bring all the agencies involved with mental health and suicide prevention together.
Finally, a good report is an update on the Labor Management Institute.
Another 30 school districts joined in the last couple of weeks.
Over 270 people participated.
It's been the goal to improve labor management relationships.
A large number of schools have been involved over the course of the last five years.
It's having a major positive impact on relations between labor and management.
Finally, we're very proud of the special workshops and forums coordinated by our incredible employees here at CDC, creating real action in the spirit of inclusion to hold Black History Month, Latino Heritage Month, our first ever Asian Pacific Islander Heritage Month, Disability Awareness Month, as well as our most recent, Pride Month.
Stay tuned for the upcoming American Indian Heritage Week, commencing in the final week of September.
And we have really meaningful workshops that take place and professional development for all of our staff and all of our guests.
With that, I look forward to a good board meeting, Mr. President.
Thank you for that comprehensive report.
I have some announcements as is typical at the opening of the board meeting.
First, I'd like to announce we have two University of California Center interns working at the state board office this summer.
They're both here, and when I read through their bios, I'd like them to stand up.
First is Ong Nguyen, who is supporting the work of the California Early Math Project through August 21st.
He is completing his Bachelor of Arts degree in Political Science and International Relations at the University of California, San Diego, and he is an international student from Myanmar.
Second is Julie Ann Mather is an incoming senior at UCLA where she is majoring in English.
She is working with our communications director, Janet Weeks, to increase the state board's digital media presence through Facebook, Twitter, and our blog.
And so she is also trying to raise the awareness of the California statewide system of support for schools and districts.
She's from Lakeport, California, and they will both be with us into August.
So both of them, you're here, stand up.
There they are, okay.
Finally, I'd like to say in preliminary remarks that this is our last board meeting with our student board member, Jaden Gray.
And we appreciate his dedication and insights over the past year.
And he is going to attend the University of Pennsylvania in Philadelphia and study politics, philosophy, and economics.
That's a very good combination.
Would you please come up and I want to present you with something that we give to the outgoing student member.
First a card, then we give you a certificate of appreciation and accommodation for your work in public service on the California State Board of Education.
Okay, there is one addendum to our agenda today for item 14 related to charter school numbering.
There are seven public school charter hearings on our agenda either today or tomorrow.
Those are items 16 through 22.
We have the regular consent items on our agenda and those regular consent items are 5 through 15 and the waiver items of W1 through W22.
So, board members, any board members wishing to remove items from these proposed consent calendars should advise our executive director, Karen Staff-Walters, by 12 o'clock noon today, Wednesday.
We also wanted to say to the board members that you got your electronic red folder with all the letters and communications to them.
We'll be talking about that.
today.
And speakers, please sign up at the table just outside the room.
Binders are on the table with separate pages for each number.
And sign up on the page for each number that you want to speak on.
There's a general public comment item, item 24, for items not specifically listed on the board's agenda.
Individual speakers will be limited to one minute each for public comment for all items today on Wednesday.
For item two only today, a group of five speakers may sign up together and designate one speaker who will be allocated a total of three minutes for the total group.
If you wish to submit materials, please provide at least 25 copies.
to Amy Bovico who's down there sitting in front at the desk there.
Please introduce yourself if you are a speaker and identify what organization or whether you're introducing yourself to prepare and to represent before the board.
And we have TV monitors for the meeting in room 1103.
if we cannot accommodate the group at our board meeting.
So those are my preliminary announcements.
And so with no further ado, I think we're ready for item one.
And we'll have first the presentation by CDE, by Cindy Kazanis.
And then we'll have technical questions on each
for each board member.
And I think we'll have the technical questions on each of the items are different.
And so at the end of each of the three items, we have the growth model, the safety net methodology and the English learner progress indicator.
We'll have individual chances for technical questions.
And after we're done with that, we'll, of course, have public testimony and then deliberate on where we want to go next.
So
Thank you, and open up the presentation.
Great.
Thank you very much, President Kirst and Superintendent Harlaxton, members of the board.
My name is Cindy Kazanas, the director of the Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division.
Just like you were able to introduce some of your interns, I wanted to introduce the intern we have for the summer from Stanford University, Noemi Davila.
If she could just stand for a moment.
Welcome.
And she is helping, this is, I think, our third year of the Stanford internship.
And we've always had great luck with your students, remember Kirst and others.
So she's helping us with building out this accountability system.
So it's always nice to see a fresh face and maybe a future state employee.
Who knows?
Welcome.
So as President Chris mentioned, this is a meaty item and as a result, similar to past practice, we will take a break after each one or pause rather for technical questions.
So we do have three parts of our recommendation today that require action from you.
We're requesting action from you rather.
And then the last two attachments will be a brief update on the ongoing development of the California School Dashboard and our commitment to doing stakeholder outreach.
Today you are going to see pieces of what we have put forward back in an April memo to you for our work plan.
I'm happy to report that we are on track for meeting our deadlines for not only September but November and the release of the dashboard in December.
Even with the hiccups in ESSA, we have been able to stay on focus with the state accountability system.
But it has been quite a bit of excitement over the last 60 days.
So you're going to hear a little bit about what we've been doing to get to this point and how we develop these recommendations.
So with that, I'm going to turn it over to Jenny Singh.
I did want to mention that for this section of the item for the growth model, Educational Testing Services does have a technical expert here, so you can feel free to ask those kinds of questions if you have them as Jenny goes through the presentation.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Kurz, Superintendent Torlakson, and board members.
Again, my name is Jenny Singh, and I'm here to present Attachment 1, incorporating a growth model into the dashboard.
You may recall at the last meeting in May, we brought three growth models to you and asked you to select one growth model for us to study further, and you asked us to further explore the residual gain growth model.
You also requested that the Educational Testing Services, or ETS, conduct some further analysis of the RG model.
You may recall when they did their first analysis, we did not have the results from the 2017 Smarter Balance, so we wanted to go ahead and look at the 2017 data to make sure that the model performed consistently over time.
And then you also requested the CDE staff to obtain additional feedback from stakeholders on incorporating the growth model into the dashboard.
So I believe that we have done some extensive feedback from the field and from stakeholders.
And then you also said that you had some questions, actually three questions that you wanted us to respond to at this meeting.
So we're gonna go ahead and start with those three questions.
So, you wanted to know what does the residual gain model tell us?
You know, we're developing an accountability system and we think it's important that when we put in additional indicators that it provides us with the information that is going to be helpful to not only us, but to schools and districts.
So, as you know, the residual gain provides growth for each student and student group with current and prior test scores.
So, it only is for grades four through eight because grade three, of course, they don't have prior test scores.
So, we're looking at a cohort of students from one year to the next and how they've grown.
So, it tells us whether or not a student or a student group met the predicted test scores.
And when I say student, I'm saying that as we're actually performing the analysis, because student group scores would not be going out.
We would only produce school and student group scores to be posted on the web.
So we can tell if they met their predicted test score.
We can tell how far the students or student groups are below their predicted score or how far above their predicted score, right?
And then we can tell whether a school or student group had high or low residual gain growth from the prior year to the current year.
And that's subjective.
You'd have to look at the growth statewide and make a determination on what you consider high and low growth.
So what doesn't it tell us?
Well, it doesn't tell us how far students or student groups who met their predicted targets are from level three.
So many students can meet the predicted target and be below level three.
Students can also meet their target and be above level three.
But this residual gain model doesn't give us that information.
doesn't tell us if the achievement gaps are closing.
And it's my understanding that's an important component that we would like to see in our growth model.
And it doesn't tell us whether meeting or exceeding the predicted targets indicates if a student is on track to proficiency.
And you wanted to know, what does distance from level three change tell us?
So we are using this methodology, and it does tell us, on average, the needed improvement for a school or student group to bring the average student to level three, or to the extent to which the student groups or school exceed level three.
Now this change reflects the difference in how students in the current year performed on the Smarter Balanced assessment compared to the students in the prior year.
So we're not looking at a cohort.
Many of the students are the same, but some students are different.
And that's really important to understand.
So you get two different answers
The growth model provides one set of information and the change provides another.
Also important to understand that there are many growth models.
They're all, and we're gonna use the same data set when we're producing growth model or change.
And depending on the growth model that is selected, you will get a slightly different answer, right?
It's telling you something different.
So we wanted to look at change versus growth.
I've actually, we've limited how much data we can put on the screen here, but I actually provided the full, all the data for all the student groups in ELA and math for you.
You can look at that at your leisure.
I'm sure you'll be thrilled.
So what we wanted to do here is we wanted to really know the difference between change and growth and how it's gonna work in our model.
Because we have a model that's already established.
So, you can see here, important to note that when we're looking at the percent that's meeting the predicted target, really about 50% of all students
and all student groups are meeting the predicted target.
Now we know that would be true for the all student group because that's the way the residual gain model is designed.
50% will meet it, 50% won't.
We were a little surprised that that actually occurred for all student groups as well.
The foster group is the one group that is a little bit low at 46.2%.
Also wanted to point out that sometimes you can have a negative change in the DF3 and a positive change on the residual gain.
You can see that with the white student group.
And the reverse is also true.
You can see that with the foster group.
They had a positive distance from level three and a negative residual gain score.
So we provided a memo in June that included the ETS updated analysis of the residual gain growth model.
And they replicated many of the analysis that was provided in the April model.
ETS used the statewide student level data to compare the 2015 and 16 RG results to the 2016-17 RG results.
So some of the analysis conducted was the relationship with student demographic variables, important analysis, the correlation between the RG model and the relationship with grade configurations, the precision and or reliability of the RG model.
And to no surprise to us, the findings were generally the same, statistically the same.
This model has been around for a long time.
We did not anticipate that it would be that different.
They also compared the year-to-year growth outcomes and found low stability between years.
So we were a little bit surprised with this finding.
So for example, schools with high growth one year are likely to have low growth the following year and vice versa.
So of course when they were presenting this to us, my first question was, do we pick the wrong model?
And they said, well, we actually did this work for the change in distance to met and the conditional percentile rank of gain and found the same results.
I'm not sure that made me feel better, but that's what they found.
And they indicated that such high volatility can make it a little bit difficult for LEAs to use growth for driving decisions, as decisions made one year might be contradicted with the next year's growth data.
And they also indicated that they did look at some data from another state.
Because one of the questions I asked was, is this an issue with our scale scores?
Is this causing it?
And they said they actually had data from a large district in another state that wasn't Smarter Balanced data.
And they got the same results using that data.
And then there have been a couple of studies, and one study that they pointed out was one that was conducted on Nevada's growth model, and it also showed the same volatility in growth from year to year.
So we had all this information, we wanted to take it out to stakeholders.
So we presented, we had five different stakeholder sessions, and we actually conducted a webinar.
In the webinar we had polling questions that people responded to.
We had good attendance in the webinar, a little over 700 people.
So there's a lot of interest and growth model out there.
So all in all, we had presentations where we had about 1,000 individuals participating.
We got feedback that was mixed.
Some presentations we went to, the stakeholders indicated that distance from level three provided them with actionable information that they needed, and they really didn't see a need for a growth model.
Other stakeholders said a growth model could provide additional and useful information.
But they weren't sure that the RG model was going to provide them with the information they wanted.
Because what they really want is they want to know if a student is scoring at a certain has a certain score, how much
can they expect that student to grow from one year to the next?
And of course our residual gain model does not do that.
So that was a little surprising for us also.
So we got a lot of great feedback and very useful information.
So even though the residual gain has some volatility, it still can be useful in some ways, right?
We could use the model to identify outliers for a case study if we so desire to do.
So for example, we could identify schools that are in the fifth quintile in both 2016 and 17, which is approximately 7% of the schools, and we could do a study on that.
So, I mean,
Even though there is some volatility and growth, it still would be useful to identify outliers.
So the recommendation, of course, from the department is to approve further study of the RG growth model using additional years of assessment data as it becomes available.
Additionally, we are recommending not producing the RG results and posting it on the website because we think that there's a likelihood of causing quite a bit of confusion for schools and for districts.
We do know that there are other states that are using growth models and they are using them for their accountability system.
But we also know that other states, when they're using these growth models, they're actually, they're taking all of their indicators and they're combining them together for an overall score.
So the impact of that growth model is much less on schools than the impact of the growth model when we put it in the dashboard because it would be a standalone, possibly could be a standalone component and it would have a much larger impact on the identification of schools and districts.
Other considerations that we need to think about, it is possible that we may need to explore other growth models in order to provide schools and LEAs with the information that they have requested.
I'm not sure there are models out there that would meet their request, but we certainly would want to further explore that.
And in addition, it's important to know that ETS has completed their contracted scope of work related to growth models.
So what are some next steps?
So we definitely we want to continue to provide LEAs and school support on how to analyze their annual assessment results for the LCAP goals.
I think the assessment office has done a great job in this area.
They have, if you go to the CAPS website and you're looking at the data, there is a tab that you can do click on that shows change over time.
So if you want to know about fourth graders, you can click on fourth graders and you can see how fourth graders performed in 2017 and how they performed as third graders in 2016.
So that's very helpful.
They're going to be, of course, adding another year of data so they have a three year trend that people can look at.
That's available online.
So it's available to stakeholders, to schools and LEAs.
And they also developed a really nice report that complements that information.
So what they've produced is they have an average change in scale score.
by subject, grade, and scale score range.
So for example, in math, if you have a student that scored between 2189 to 2200, you can see that the statewide average growth for students in those categories was a growth of like 99.9 points.
So then you can tell if your school performed better or worse or about the same.
So that's a nice addition that you can use with the report that's online.
Also recall that we do have student score reports.
And those are the score reports that go to parents and districts have this information as well.
And those score reports do provide this current score and the prior score.
So you can see the change over time.
And that is really in essence a simple gain growth model.
So we have that information.
So there's a lot of things that have already been done.
And I think that we can continue to provide support to the field in this area.
We would also like to convene a series of meetings with growth model experts, LEA program experts, and stakeholders to obtain further public input on the purpose of the growth model in the accountability system.
So we need to really determine what do we want from the growth model, and then how do we best incorporate that into the dashboard, and which model will meet that purpose.
So with that, I will be happy to answer any questions.
I just wanted to add a couple of context before we conclude.
As Jenny mentioned a couple of times, we would not be able to have done all this work without the support of Michelle Senner and her staff of the assessment division, and of course the ETS contract that was invaluable over the last 18 to 24 months.
And in fact, some of the analysis that they did with our data is something that I don't think that some of the letters that we saw understand
the extent of that, and they don't have access to that data, right?
This is a statewide data set that is unique, obviously, to California, and so we've been very fortunate to have that, be able to utilize that contract.
We also have a very thoughtful process in California when we look at new items, and I wanted to just emphasize, I think Jenny sometimes underestimates what she does versus other states.
When I went to Chicago a couple of months ago, they were telling us how to create a technical design group,
That's really strange.
We've had one for over like a decade or two decades So so there are other states out there that are really behind the ball and we have been fortunate in California to have a lot of expertise over the years going back to Bill Padilla and I'm sure others that I can't even remember and
that have set us towards this path.
And so that when we take something to you, we are confident that it is not only technically sound, but it's fair to schools and the districts.
We don't want to bring something out that is confusing.
In fact, on our technical design group, we have a couple of local educational agency representatives, and they are quick to tell us when something doesn't quite work for the field.
So, in addition to that, one of the things I wanted to acknowledge was Michelle did provide us an opportunity to talk to the assessment technical group, the technical advisory group, and they were really helpful in talking about, you know, looking at assessments and how growth models work.
And I think that there's an urgency out there from others to put something in place.
And we want to, what we're saying today is we want to be thoughtful about it.
We're committed to continuing to look at it.
We have talked to national experts, but we are willing to, again, convene a series of meetings to get us
across the finish line.
It may take us a couple more years.
What we have is working in California.
That's what we heard from our local educational agencies.
You saw that we talked to over a thousand people.
We were astounded that we had on one webinar almost 800 LEA representatives at the end of May.
So they were interested in what we had to provide and they gave us plenty of feedback on what we had to present.
With that, I also wanted to acknowledge Jenny and Kimberly Mudhank, who did present last time, is on vacation or you would have seen her today.
And their leadership has been terrific.
And so just with that, we can open up technical questions.
And again, like we said earlier, ETS is here to respond to those as well, if you have something for them.
Okay, so we're going to have some technical questions now that we can
then have public comment and move into more deliberations.
Do you have information?
One thing we get is all these other states have growth models.
And if you do what I would like if we have it now or you could get it as to why they have them.
Because the growth models are implemented in my recollection of history
for teacher evaluation.
And they were also used to secure federal waivers for under NCLB.
And we're not talking here about teacher evaluation.
By the way, a lot of the teacher evaluation things found the same things, volatility balance scores bouncing around.
So, you know, there's an implication among the letters that we're behind
But maybe we're not behind on this with other states because 40 states did it, but they, you know, they all had another reason for it.
And it's not clear to me that it was the use for teacher evaluation was a resounding success.
It appears to have been pretty much not very effective.
So do you have knowledge on why the other states did this and what they're using them for?
Well, I have knowledge on a few states from some meetings that we've been to, but not on all the states.
So we would have to actually do a little more research on that and bring it back.
The few states that I talked to, you're absolutely right.
They had growth models in place that they received for teacher, that they built for teacher evaluation.
And they just decided that they were going to transition those growth models into the new accountability system under ESSA.
Like I said, that was only, you know, three or four states that I spoke with and I don't have information on the other states.
Yeah, maybe we could look a little bit more broadly because
We should do it because most other states have it, but they were doing it for something else.
I think that would inform it because the allegation is we're really far behind and all of that sort of thing.
And then the other question on your series of meetings, one question is not just for accountability in the dashboard, we want to understand this,
But what's been raised is what decisions by what actors would a growth model inform?
And that's more than accountability.
And some of these growth models seem to be useful for local district information, but they would not be used in a
perhaps in an accountability model.
So I would think that, you know, the meetings you're talking about convening seem a little narrow to me in terms of that kind of a scope and just focusing on accountability and the dashboard.
So is that what you, how did you think about the nature of the subjects for these meetings?
I'm going to be honest, I haven't had a lot of time to think about them at this point.
We have a lot of work to do between now and November, so I know that we won't be doing much until after the first of the year, but maybe Michelle can help us out.
Michelle Center, Director of the Assessment Division.
Of course, we're always happy to collaborate with our Accountability Division.
I think that you've heard how we do that so well.
I think that we're happy to engage in that conversation.
I think that what is a little different in terms of
looking at the assessment information for improving teaching and learning is that we've already for quite some time started that work.
We've already started those workshops.
We've started that training.
We started that messaging.
So we're in a very different spot than we are in terms of talking about growth for accountability.
It would be interesting to engage in the conversation with individuals and also make sure that we are
not creating confusion.
by adding another way of looking at change.
For those of you, for example, we just did a workshop called the data are in now what, right?
Which is exactly that, looking at your data over time.
What is that telling you?
What questions might you have?
And what actions might you want to take?
And that's the kind of information that we support, which is really looking at multiple data points and not necessarily just looking at a growth model.
but always happy to collaborate.
Okay.
Other board members?
Board member Burr.
So are we just asking technical questions?
Yeah.
Because I'd like to make a lot of policy statements here.
But I appreciate, though, Michelle coming up because I think one thing that was really illuminating, Jenny, and I wanted you to kind of go over it again, and maybe this is at a later presentation, is what information is currently available to LEAs
to teachers, to the members of the public about progress on test scores because that seems to be a little bit of a mystery.
I would say I certainly wasn't aware of all of that because I don't get in there and look at all those different tabs.
So I think just for purposes of communication, because to board member, to President Kerr's comment, I think what we're in a little bit of a conundrum here about who needs what information when to make the best decisions on behalf of students.
and what level of information is gonna be helpful to make those kinds of decisions.
So I would just ask that we have maybe a real joint presentation or a walkthrough again of what information is available, what kinds of training, that training that you just mentioned, Michelle, I think is fantastic that, again, putting that information in the hands of principals and teachers is the most important thing to me, and parents, of course.
so that they can be making judgments about their students' success.
What we do in terms of sending signals at the state level about what our expectations are, especially around equity and student growth of subgroups, is a different conversation, I think.
And I think we're conflating the two here in a very technical way that makes us all go,
Oh my God, what are we talking about here?
So I think helping to understand that, again, in a way that's important to the people who are making the decisions would be helpful.
Remember, Bre, I think that's a great idea, particularly the timing that we have with an upcoming release around fall-ish, where we can come back to you and talk to you about all the different data and information that we have out there.
One thing that I'll mention as part of our training, we have this slide, and it really gets you thinking about what is a student trajectory look like.
And for those of us that are parents or those of us who are teachers, you don't really expect that that progress in terms of learning
is necessarily that straight line, do you?
And you kind of expect that, and you recognize that.
And that's OK when we have, from an assessment division, conversations with locals about expectations for students and about how you might inform teaching and learning.
But that's a very different conversation when then you start putting accountability on that and expectations.
So that volatility isn't necessarily something that is
negative or unexpected or a portrayal that something is wrong in the assessment.
But maybe it is something that we should have expected.
Students grow.
They have plateaus.
Those are the normal things that happen in learning.
And I think that we can have that conversation much easier when we're talking about improvements in teaching and learning than you can when you're talking about an accountability system.
And if I could just add one other thing, because this is what scares me a little bit about this conversation.
For the last four or five years, we have made a concerted effort to move away from making decisions based solely on test scores.
And I feel the sucking motion pulling us back in that direction
So I just want to, I also think the conversation, if it can be broadened to talk about a multiple measure system and does it make sense to have one model for a specific piece of that multiple measure system when we don't have it for the rest of those measures.
So I just want to make sure we're always putting this into context because right now all we're talking about is a test score.
And I think that's why it makes me nervous.
I think it makes a lot of our experts on the technical design group nervous.
And I think if you look at the research that President Kirst mentioned about some of the decisions that were being made based on these models, it didn't pan out.
And so I don't want us to put all of our eggs in one basket.
Board Member Strauss.
So I have a several part question and really for clarification as we all grapple with I know we initially talked about wanting a growth model and that there were many states that were using it.
But I know we're finding some challenges and I I read the letters and felt like we needed some more clarification because there's some different.
conclusions, depending on who's writing to us.
So, my first question, I have like three, so just timing.
There were letters from stakeholders regarding CORE's growth model, and CORE's been talking to us for a long time about that, and I just wonder if you could talk, I think you've evaluated that, about the technical aspects of how they're doing that, so I'm
kind of interested in any information that you have, particularly to that approach, because I think there's a question about how we approach it.
And I'm very concerned about the volatility and what it will actually do for us.
So could you just, that's the first part of my question.
Do you have any information?
Have you evaluated that at all?
Yes, we have looked at the core model, and in fact, we had a meeting with some of the core staff around mid-June.
Rick Miller, Noah Bookman, and Julie White attended, and they provided us with some detailed information about their model.
We had a lot of information about it ahead of time, but they provided us with even more information, and it was very helpful to have that conversation with them.
I think it did reinforce our desire to slow down a little bit and do a little more work in this area because the core model has different assumptions about a growth model than we do, right?
So because they have different assumptions, clearly we're looking at it from two different aspects.
And so I think it just reinforces the fact that we need to do a little more exploration on the growth models.
Well, so I agree that we need to take our time.
I really appreciated the input from the technical design group about unintended consequences.
And I am particularly concerned about the volatility.
But I don't want to put more numbers in without understanding why we're putting them in and for what purpose they serve.
And I also think that we need to kind of build on what Member Burr was saying about how we explain it.
Does it help inform teaching and learning?
How do we explain it to our constituencies?
And is the residual gain model, is that the best model?
Or is there a better one?
And so I guess I just wanna support that we need to take our time and I just support the TGE's recommendation that don't throw it away, but take some time and really further evaluate it.
So I think those are my general comments.
Board member Rucker.
First of all, I want to thank you all for this work.
This is very tough and very, very technical and difficult work.
And in layman's terms, there are assumptions about what the data should be telling us or, better yet, how the data should be interpreted to tell us the things we want the data to be telling us.
And that second point is where this discussion about the growth models fall in because people have used the growth model.
The core model is not the only growth model that we've seen in this state.
The other one that we've actually seen published was also published by the Los Angeles Times in their teacher evaluation model and we know that that blew up.
And so my questions go to how these, particularly with the residual gains model, you pointed out that there are differences in assumptions about what the model does or differences in assumptions about how the model would operate.
So my question is about those assumptions.
In looking at, without asking you to tell me what the actual assumptions are,
Because, you know, after the second sentence, frankly, my eyes will glaze over.
But in looking at those assumptions and the differences, doesn't that also mean it changes the calculus on how the elements of the factors in the growth model are actually used?
Is that one of the reasons why understanding the differences in those assumptions are important?
That is correct.
Okay, then my second, so I do understand this.
All right, so then my second question is in looking at, without taking away these local models, both from the LA Times and from CORE, but looking at other states, and I'm gonna separate the question, looking at other Smarter Balanced states that have a growth model, and other states that have a growth model that are not using Smarter Balanced.
There are Smarter Balanced states that also have an RG model.
Is there a difference?
And I understand that there were problems.
The same problems that you discovered in the work that we did in this modeling in California became apparent in other states.
My question is, in those other Smarter Balanced states, are there similarities or differences in the assumptions they had in developing or implementing their RG model that you're aware of?
I do not have that information.
Okay.
And then for the state that you looked at that you said that was a non-smarter balance state that also had the RG model, was there a difference in the assumptions that their model had?
So, ETS had the data from another state.
And what they did is they took that same data and ran
our RRG model with that data.
Okay.
And so then my last question is, as it relates to the issue of the volatility, I'm going to tell you now this question is not correct.
I've been trying to figure out a way to ask this question and I still haven't figured out the correct way to ask it.
So you may have to tell me I don't know and that probably is going to be the correct answer.
For this issue of volatility, I know that right now when we look at the way our academic indicator has been developed,
The issue of the distance from level three doesn't have that same fluctuation or volatility in it from grade to grade.
That's a very stable report because of the way you've calculated it.
Is there some way to control, and I'm using the word control on purpose,
to control the way the volatility and the fluctuation volatility works either from year to year or grade to grade as you're following to try to figure out how to do the comparison of this year with last year.
Are there ways that you can do the calculus to control that volatility?
I'm sure there are.
That's what we want to further explore.
But if you want more technical information, we do have someone from ETS who could maybe respond to that.
Maybe not today, but maybe for a future meeting, because that is something I'm very interested in, having read the memo, the information memo that you put out.
My eyes really did fall on and study and study again the explanation about the volatility.
So I am very interested in trying to understand that not as a comparison on how other RG models work, but as a way of understanding whether ultimately a decision is made to use any kind of growth model because I agree with my colleagues.
that the data we're getting right now based on the chart that you gave us, it's not really, it doesn't have any value added for the kind of reporting we're looking for.
But the perception is still there that if California doesn't have a growth model, there's something missing.
in the discussion of our accountability picture because there is still this great expectation about what numbers are supposed to tell us.
And the fact is those numbers don't do that even if we want to have that conversation.
That's a conversation for a different day.
But on the technical side, I really want to make sure we have exhausted the type of technical analysis to determine whether or not we're truly getting any
valuable information that is distinct or distinguishable from what we are currently getting in the dashboard data that's currently being reported.
So I agree with board member Super in saying that we should probably have another update or at least another review about what's actually being reported in the dashboard so we can understand whether or not a growth model has anything else that it can add to the data we're already getting.
Thank you.
Board Member Sun.
So I have very brief technical questions and then probably a little bit more policy-ish statement around this.
So first of all, I do appreciate all the work that you guys have done on this.
The promise of a growth model has been around even prior to LCFF, right?
It was part of PSAA and I get that it has become this holy grail of accountability that we've looked up to and then we're always searching for it and going after it.
So I get that, and I think that it's kind of become something that we just continue to search for, but not really step back and ask the questions, well, why are we actually looking for this?
So I was super disappointed, as you know.
that we have a failure to launch on this particular model that you've done so much work on.
However, I think that stepping two steps back is a good idea, convening the stakeholder group to really discuss why we want this, what information we actually do want.
But I don't want to give up on it.
And so I do appreciate the recommendation with very specific next steps that is about continuing to research and continuing to move forward with it.
You had asked, Jenny, you had stated several things that the current data or the model does not tell us.
Is that because we don't have enough data?
Or is it that even as much data as we can collect, it still won't tell us
It won't, it will never tell us that information.
Okay, it will never tell us that information.
So that says that we really do need to take two giant steps back and really look and ask those questions of why we're doing it.
The other piece is, while I also appreciate that we are not looking at test scores as the only, as a measure and trying to super emphasize test scores, I do think that with all of the
the time and the development of the tests that we have and that it does measure standards, that I would like to see something that looks at the test score results in a different way than what we currently have with the status and growth model that we have.
So whether it gets emphasized or not, I do think that we need to look at that kind of data through different lenses.
That's my thing.
Okay, Board Member Valdez.
First of all, thank you.
I know this has been a journey and we're so proud to have all of you leading our journey, so we appreciate that.
We know it's not a linear journey.
The road is like up and down, right?
And so again, from my lens, being within a district and living this day-to-day, meeting with 80 administrators next week and really thinking about all of this, how do we roll it out?
What are the conversations?
And so my question really centers around, first of all, I wanna say that having clarity is so important and so to not cause confusion, it's so wise to hold off to make sure that when we do have a growth model, because I think we want a growth model.
I don't think anyone would say we don't need a growth model, but we want it to be clear and we want it to work because the growth model should be integrated into this system.
and it should work.
So my question is, as we think about teaching and learning and all of the assessment and accountability, how does this help in the leading and lagging indicator questions that districts have in terms of moving forward, if that makes sense?
So as you're looking at it, we know that it's lagging data, if you will, when it comes to us, but is there an opportunity to begin to think about in that multiple measures concept
that the leading, we can help in that leading indicator data along the route, if that makes sense.
So it's an open-ended question, but it's just something to think about, because from a consumer level, that's really what's gonna make the difference, because yesterday's over, the test is done, that was last year, but as we move forward, and we think about leading indicators, or could we use some of this data to be leading, I guess, is one of the questions I'm asking in a open-ended way.
I think it would be very difficult to use a growth model in that way.
But, of course, our assessment office, I don't know if Michelle wants to address the fact that there are data elements that can be used on an ongoing basis.
I guess I got confused because I wasn't sure if you were suggesting that the growth model be used as that way or recognizing that it can't be used in that way.
So we do, of course, have many resources that are available that can be used as leading indicators.
Many of those are resources that we provide for formative assessment purposes and trainings that we do so that people will know prior to even giving the test, let alone getting the results back, how students are performing relative to our state standards.
So that's the type of information we have.
I'm not sure that that completely meets your need if what you're suggesting is you have that information on a real systematic school-wide type of approach.
If so, we do know of some schools and districts that really are trying to utilize our interim assessments in that way to varying levels of success.
But that's another way of getting that leading information.
So those are the models that we're looking for.
So how are other and I know that this is all so it's tying everything together.
It's the interim.
It's the growth model.
It's distance from that all of that.
How does that really come together in a comprehensive way.
That's just the messaging that would be really really helpful.
Thank you.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I apologize for missing the presentation, but I had a flight delay.
And my question is not technical, but it's very policy.
You know, I know that board member Sanchez mentioned or referenced how long this conversation has taken place and it definitely predates me.
But my world in Sacramento started in 2015.
And this conversation started with the idea that we were adopting the Alberta model.
for the accountability system, which was based on averages.
And averages could lose a lot of information as it relates to performance of subgroups.
And in particular, students whose information may seem like they're doing better than they actually are or lower than they actually are.
And so I remember President Kurz mentioned, we really ought to measure, find a methodology that helps us measure, are we making gains towards narrowing achievement gaps?
And that's how this conversation got started.
So that's a conversation that I wanna have because when I saw the meeting from May that I missed, I believe that board member Sun was really the only one that focused on, are we narrowing achievement gaps?
What does this mean for equity?
What does it mean for subgroups?
And so I understand why at this point we need to take a pause and really revisit what we have.
But I also think that not putting a timeline for when we will actually come back with something that could be incorporated into the dashboard makes it seem like someday, one day.
someday doesn't exist on our calendars, right?
I want to see something more concrete.
I know that there's many states that are doing this.
It may be different, but I think that we need to start opening up, and I'm excited to see that we have here something about future meetings with growth model experts.
Even if CORE is not what we're looking for because of the agreements that we have, maybe we need to change the agreements of our assumptions.
But I think that we need to bring some of those experts.
USC, Harvard, we received a letter from academics and researchers that are happy to help.
We should be tapping into them.
Children now send a letter.
They seem very knowledgeable.
There's a lot of people that have the technical expertise that we may not have, and maybe we don't agree with what they're presenting.
It may not be the model that we're looking for.
But I think that having an open-ended timeline that doesn't really tell us when is this coming back to the board, when is it 2019 that we hope to have it in the dashboard, 2020, even though that seems like a faraway timeline for most of us that have been waiting for this, at least it's a timeline.
So I'm a little uncomfortable with the fact that we don't have set dates, that we don't have a sense of when this will actually be incorporated.
Yeah, go ahead.
Do you want to respond?
Yeah.
I just would say that you're going to hear something similar with, I think, the English Learner Progress Indicator.
And so we will regroup and figure out if we can bring you something back, either in a memo between the meetings about sort of a three-year plan for accountability, because we haven't been able to take a breath.
And we probably need to just take a pause and figure out the next couple of 24 months, 36 months, what does it look like?
We had given you a six-month timeline or an eight-month timeline back in April, and obviously you're now, you're thinking much further ahead, so.
Can you scroll back, board member Ortiz-Lacombe wasn't here, back to what it can't tell you.
You had something.
Yeah, if achievement gaps are closing, right there.
Yeah.
So I mean, I came into this thinking it might help us with this.
So I think that's very, very interesting.
And you confirmed that none of them really do that.
So yeah, I just wanted to make sure you were aware of that.
I read the memo, and I read the item.
And so maybe we're not looking at the right model, but I do think that that's why we need to see what other models are working there.
Texas has the narrowing achievement gap domain.
typically not one to reference Texas for things, but in this case, you know, they are looking at something similar.
And so let's see what's out there, but maybe diversify the group of folks that are advising us so that we could get there a little faster.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Could you comment on, you know, what was really prominent in the EdSource article yesterday, that the way we're doing it now
where we're using student groups and there's people moving in and out of these student groups has significant technical problems.
So that are, you know, what is implied there by some experts, end quote, is that the way we're doing it now is really under the change model has real limitations and then the implication is there
the growth model might fill in for some of those problems.
So... So regardless of what model you use, whether it's the change model or the growth model, there are implications on both of them.
Neither one of them are perfect, as we can see.
You may recall that last November, November 2017, we had to come back to the board to revise our 5x5 grid.
And we had to revise that five by five grid because we noticed that there was some there was volatility and we wanted to control for that volatility.
And so we made sure we had about 15 percent of the schools who would have gone down to at least two performance levels if we did nothing.
So.
We were well aware that there was some volatility in our change model.
We took, I think, the appropriate steps to control for that.
And I think the field is very happy with our academic indicator.
They seem to think it provides them with useful information.
They're using it on a regular basis.
It did take them a little bit of time to adjust.
To to our five by fives and to the you know, the way we were calculating the academic indicator, but I think it I I think that the tdg has provided us with very good guidance and I I think that our academic indicator provides the information that schools and leas can use
Well, but the criticism was that students migrate in and out of schools and move around.
As I understand it, I may not have this right.
And therefore, the way we're doing it has technical errors.
And it wasn't volatility, as I understood this criticism.
That is true.
Students do move in and out of schools.
That's the difference between the change versus the growth.
The growth, you're looking at students who had a score from the prior year.
Recall that we do not put anyone in our model unless they've been at the school for a complete academic year, from fall census day to the first day of testing.
Yes, students go in and out of schools.
When you're looking at a K-8 school, you're going to have new third graders every year, and your eighth graders are going to leave.
But a lot of the students are the same.
So there are some differences, but there's a lot of students that are the same.
So yes, there are issues with that, but I think our technical design group has addressed them the best that we can with the model that we have.
With the residual growth model.
Okay.
Board Member Berg.
So I think it would be helpful, again, as we're going forward, to talk about the value of a cohort model for what purposes.
Again, does it make sense at the state level to send signals versus an individual student growth model, which you need at the LEA level in order to make judgments about every student that you're trying to serve, every subgroup you're trying to serve.
Because I'll say to go along with board member Sung's comments, I've been around a long time on this issue since 1992.
And when the API was created, our technical design group said a cohort model works at the state level.
Because when you aggregate all these students, the transiency, it's kind of noise in the system.
And for purposes of sending signals at the state level, it's okay.
So I think it is important to distinguish between the cohort model versus individual student growth model.
And at what level you need that information, again, in order to make decisions.
Because I agree with Member Kirsten, I'm a little bit...
Concerned about people saying well, it's flawed because you're not using individual student growth when in fact There are purposes for a cohort model that may make sense on a policy basis So I think we need to again as we're moving forward.
I would appreciate if we could sort of sort through some of those issues To make a reasoned decision.
Thanks
I think the same letter that President Chris referenced also had a statement that I wanted to make sure that folks saw that said that growth to proficiency actually conveys very similar information to the state's status measure, distance from level three, which is not desirable for measuring the effectiveness of schools.
There's a lot of confusion.
There's a lot of controversy and in fact one of the people who signed the letter from the researchers co-authored the study in which one of our Researchers who authored our study the original study together that we talked about that's from like four or five years ago that all the states were using and so even even in academia they have disagreements Okay board member Rucker
Okay, so I want to thank you for going back to what the board did last fall to make adjustments on the dashboard because that was related to my question about what can you control to make adjustments on the way this growth model would work.
When the adjustments on the 5x5 grid were made,
My perception at the time when the board took that action is that there was a clear issue that you understood what the volatility was related to and you had come up with a model or a proposal to address and correct that volatility.
In other words, we knew where the problem was and we knew how to adjust or to make that fix.
So my question related to controlling for the volatility, and you know where I'm going on this,
on this growth model is, you know, is there a way to understand why there's this fluctuation or volatility that can define or suggest solutions for correcting or controlling forward?
I'm not sure that's apparent yet because it seems to be different from year to year what the issues may actually be.
And so that's the reason why I today am happy
to continue living with the question because we don't know in the same way that we knew or understood what was going on with our dashboard.
And I also read the EdSource article and I'm concerned for the same reason that board member Burr brought up.
There's a difference in what we at the state level need the growth model to tell us about the performance of schools and subgroups.
But there's a different, more granular need for what a growth model or any kind of school data report is needed at the school level.
And so in this conversation about a growth model, a single model is not going to address both statewide and more granular district or school level needs.
And so I think that in the conversation that a lot of people have been writing about,
they are conflating the work of a single report to cover both broader and more granular needs.
And that was more, I apologize, because that was more a policy observation than a real technical observation.
But it's very important to understand that that's in all of the letters that I saw and in the report that was in EdSource, there seems to be missing that there is a distinct difference in what is reported or what is needed to be reported at the state level and more granularly.
at the school site or local level.
And then I have not been at this as long as a lot of other people have.
So, I'm not going to pretend I have this level of expertise.
But I was a classroom teacher when the API was implemented.
And the thing that offended me that everybody else was touting as the API being the end all and be all.
Okay, let me change.
Let me stop.
It seemed like a good idea at the time.
It was never a good idea, even at the time, because there was, when the API was created, a large and allowable performance gap among student subgroups so that schools got credit for growth and making gains, even if African-American students were as far as 100 points behind.
the leading group.
So it was never a good idea, and it never addressed closing the achievement gap if you create a system that allowed that kind of large performance gap.
So it may have been touted as a great idea, but this was one African-American classroom teacher who never thought it was, because you created a performance and achievement gap in the accountability system that was approved.
So that's all I'm going to say about that.
Okay, I think we're now ready for the second presentation.
Great.
So the attachment two is picking up from where we left off last September, in which you approved safety net methodology.
And that was just for two indicators, the graduation rate and the suspension rate.
And again, just to keep in mind, this is for groups that there are 30 to 149 students.
And the reason that we had presented and you ultimately approved this idea was because we were seeing large swings in data triggered by the results of few students for this group of students.
So with bringing this to you in September of last year, we committed actually in March and you asked us to move forward with looking at it at the student group level for these two indicators.
So just as a refresher, what this methodology does is it removes the far left column, which has declined significantly, and the far right column, which has increased significantly.
So we've created a 3 by 5 grid for just this purpose.
So what we're recommending is that this be applied to the graduation rate and suspension rate indicators for all students.
We've done the simulations.
We were able to take the time this spring to look at it, to obtain stakeholder input on it, as well as make sure that it was technically sound.
This is the impact on student groups for the graduation rate indicator.
You see just over, just rather close to 8% of schools affected by this removal of the two columns and moving to a three by five grid.
You see about 3% moving from a red color to an orange color.
Again, these are student groups.
And for orange to red, so again, moving up just under about a half percent.
And then taking a step down from blue to green is just a little over 4%.
So we also provided you the race and ethnicity information in the board item, which is in table two for this attachment.
The same holds true, or similar pieces hold true for the suspension rate indicator, although it's significantly less.
So we're just down to about 5% of schools, or rather student groups, being affected.
So this is, if you're following along in the item, it's Table 3.
And then Table 4 looks at race and ethnicity.
So just to go through the table from red to orange, again moving up, we see about almost 3%
impact on that.
Moving up again between orange and yellow less than 1% only 12 student groups and taking a step down between yellow and orange is 2.1% and between blue and green less than 1% so you can see by the total number or by the note changes how many student groups we have in California when we look at individual schools so this is
This is impactful data, and we did get a tremendous amount of support from our LCFF stakeholder group, at least acknowledgment that this was a good idea to move forward with.
And keep in mind that is made up of education, advocacy, and the equity groups do attend.
And then we also presented this, rather Jenny presented this.
not here, to the Advisory Commission on Special Education.
And they always have something to say.
And sometimes they tell us what we're doing isn't right.
For this one, they were very supportive of moving forward with making sure that we were helping these, again, these schools that have swings in this for very few students.
So the next steps because our work will not be done on this methodology and in fact you saw maybe in one or two letters that said that we should look at other indicators.
So we are thinking about looking at chronic absenteeism and college career indicator and to go back to member Ortiz-Lacombe's comment we should probably provide you what when we would actually do this.
So we'll we'll put that in our in our work plan.
So this is our recommendation that you approve the application of the safety methodology at the student group level for this fall's dashboard, the 2018 dashboard, only for the graduation rate and suspension rate indicators.
So I'm happy to open up to technical questions if you have any.
Any technical questions on this?
You go back to the table for just a second Cindy the the number of student groups impacted and Tell me what that we have 1,600 student groups or it's the total population.
I'm gonna have Jenny present this to you because her folks around the data
Well, I thought we only had like 15.
So we don't have a total.
What I noticed is we didn't have a total student group count on this table.
Yes, that is true.
We don't have a total.
So when you're looking at student group, remember we have every school has a possibility of having 13 student groups.
And so we're looking at all of those schools and we're adding up all the student groups from all the schools.
Right?
So there's 1,600 student groups that went from red to orange.
And all of those schools.
So some of those schools might have had two or three student groups that we looked at, right?
Because if they're a small school with less than 150 students, maybe all of their student groups would have had that applied to them.
And of course, there are larger schools that may have very small student groups and that was applied to them as well.
Thank you for the clarification.
Thanks.
No further technical comments on that.
OK.
We're going to take a break.
Well, let's see.
OK.
You want to take it?
We'll take a short break now and reconvene at three minutes to 10.
Maybe 10.
Okay, we're on to the English Learner Progress Indicator.
Good morning.
Again, my name is Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Accountability Measurement and Accountability Reporting Division.
We're picking up Item 1.
We're talking about Attachment 3.
This is, again, the last piece of the materials that need action.
Picking up the English learner progress indicator and as way of background actually, I'm going to go back to my entry slide I just wanted to provide a little bit of context.
This is one of I would say the indicator we've had Fantastic stakeholder input in fact you had asked us to put together a work group about two years ago and that work group has been very helpful we actually
had a bit of a hiatus because we were changing to new tests and so we've changed those assessments and we picked up the work group again and we've had good participation.
But the other thing I wanted to keep in mind about this particular indicator and this student group
is that this student group is represented, of course, in every single indicator, and we always look at the progress of our English learners.
Well, this is the one that looks at progress of English learners, but we look at how English learners are doing not only in assessments, but compared to others, their peers in suspension, if they're
more chronically absent.
And so because we have such history with this group of students, I just want to acknowledge that we are obviously committed to this.
Even though this year, obviously, you've read to the end of the book, we will not be able to produce a color.
So let me walk through where we're at and where we're headed.
Of course, we are guided not only by our state law, but by the Every Student Succeeds Act.
And so just as a reminder, that law, the federal law, requires us to test our English learners in all grades, so kindergarten through 12th grade.
And while Title I only requires the EL accountability component to include grades three through eight, and then the same high school test that we all, our 11th graders, take.
We also must include in our accountability system indicator towards English learner progress, towards achieving English language proficiency.
So what we've been doing over the last year, and let me talk about actually where we came from.
So this is roll back two years to 2016, when we originally designed the methodology for the English learner progress indicator.
One of the things we knew was happening was we were changing to a new assessment.
The methodology was put together with the thought in mind that it could adapt to any assessment that was adopted.
So if for some reason we move away from LPAC in a couple of years, this methodology was supposed to withstand that transition.
So the methodology that is, again, we put back forward in June of 2016, had gone through the California Practitioners Advisory Group.
It had been vetted through many folks.
we ultimately adopted it.
So it was with strong support of where we were all looking forward to for our English learners and showing progress.
We, over the last year, rather a year ago, we provided you a memo, actually Michelle Center provided you a memo we found back in June of 2017, which gave you really how LPAC was going to be implemented.
And not only on the assessment side, but how it was going to impact accountability.
And looking back at it over the last couple of days, I realize that we may have been ambitious and over committed to trying to put something in place without doing our due diligence.
And you heard from me about what we do when we look at new things with growth model and of course our safety net methodology.
So I would apply the same thing to this.
We spent the last year talking to national experts such as Pete Goldschmidt, Robert Lankwanti, Gary Cook, Mark Hansen,
to advise us on how can we implement and transition to this new assessment as quickly as possible.
And so much of what you're going to hear today is with that in mind, with the national researchers who have guided us through this.
And then the other thing I want to say is that while we put together this memo back about a year ago,
we started realizing about last fall that we weren't going to be on the trajectory we thought we were going to be on.
And so one of the groups that meets on a regular basis is called the Bilingual Network Advisory Group, or Bilingual Network BCN.
Coordinator, excuse me, Coordinator Network.
These acronyms.
And just to note, Jonathan Eisler of my staff is here as well to answer questions if you have them, but Veronica Aguilar is here too.
So she's obviously well-steeped in all of these things.
So, looking at the status for LP, we wanted to make sure that it measures student growth towards English language proficiency.
And so, to determine that status, student growth results were aggregated.
What we've done is aggregate them to the school and LA levels to calculate percentage of students who moved up at least one performance level from the prior year.
This is the way we calculate status.
So the status calculation provides schools and LEAs with important information on how many of their students who are on track to make progress towards, of course, the ultimate goal of English language proficiency.
And then keep in mind, thinking about this in terms of our old test, CELT, EL students testing at early advanced or advanced on CELT just needed to maintain at the early advanced or advanced level to show proficiency.
When we look at change, change is of course the percentage point difference between current year status and prior year status.
And we look at the recommendation that the department put forward that our technical design group affirmed that change should measure year-to-year change in the rate schools and LEAs move up our English language students towards proficiency.
Change also allows schools and LEAs to determine if they're on track.
So we want to make sure that, again,
We're doing that for both status and change.
So this is our distribution of English learner percent distribution status and change using two years of longitudinal data.
We used the CELT data.
And what we did is we revisited what a district level distribution looks like only when two points of CELT data are used for one cohort of students to report status and change.
So in putting this simulation together, we calculated the district level.
English Language Percent Proficient by aggregating 2016-17 CELT data for current overall performance levels and domain levels to calculate current status for schools and then districts.
And we performed the same process aggregating prior overall performance levels and domain levels to calculate prior status.
Change was calculated by subtracting prior status from current status.
So that's what you see in the column headers.
Using only two points in time, the change number is positive across all fifth percentile cut points.
And we find this to be problematic in terms of reporting LB for schools and districts in the five by five grid to provide there is no meaningful differentiation between schools and districts, which is, of course, important to measure performance and required.
So this is what it actually looks like on the five by five grid, which is something that we don't see in any of our other distributions when we look at, when we've presented them to you before.
So this, of course, greatly concerned us.
So this result makes it difficult for the LP to inform decisions related to the identification of schools needing assistance because there's no, again, meaningful differentiation here.
You actually see no districts in the red.
So why are we having this challenge with only using two years of data and why we're presenting this to you looking at it being a three-year process to implement a performance level for the LP using our new assessment is because change is measured.
Of course, we've looked at it from other indicators.
We always look at two years of data.
We look at a matched cohort, and we want to make sure that
the percentiles are proficient, but the change does not measure year-to-year change in the rate at which schools and LEAs move English learners towards proficiency as change in the current LP does, or rather this prior LP does.
So we need to allow for adequate differentiation, which of course I mentioned previously.
in performance between schools and LEAs and make sure that if we don't provide this meaningful measure, we can't actually determine which LEAs are in need of technical assistance.
We have, as I mentioned, we've been talking through some of the challenges as early as last fall.
We did do a formal presentation and engaged the English Learner Progress Indicator Workgroup in June.
So June was a busy month with that and other stakeholder feedback sessions that we tried to get this topic in front of.
So members that were present agreed that they thought that status can only appropriately be reported with two years of
Summative results so for the 2019 dashboard So if you think about what we're doing similarly to the college career indicator right now, we're reporting the numbers only you don't see a color for status Three years of data they agreed are necessary to reproduce a color.
So we're looking at 2020 for the California School dashboard
I was not present at the meeting, but I'm sure they demanded, not just asked, for data reports to be made available through DataQuest, which we are in the process of revising that site and making it easier to use some of the filters to show how our subgroups are doing.
And so we do have, for example, our long-term English learner data on DataQuest.
We've had that for several years now.
So what can we do in absence of a color?
And so we want to make sure, similar to I think some of the conversations we just had about the growth model, what kind of resources can we show are available to use to think about the creation of goals in the local control and accountability plan reporting.
The other pieces that the work group wanted was to acknowledge that LEAs do have access to their students' data, their English learner data, which they can use and should be using for the LCAP reporting, whether it's their LPAC results, most specifically.
And then also, they affirmed that, of course, LEAs are obligated by law to monitor English learner student progress towards reaching English proficiency.
That doesn't go away just because we didn't create a color, of course.
The laws are still in place.
And we still monitor schools for that very purpose.
That's why we have a federal program monitoring office to do that.
And then finally, CDE, we are committed to revisiting this.
And so, like I said, we've reached out to the known national experts on this.
We know that we are really at the forefront with our methodology compared to other states.
But that doesn't mean that we can't keep looking for other ways to do this.
But we will be bringing this back to you.
And like I said, we will develop a work plan so that you have an idea of when you're going to see things over the next 6, 12 months, 18 months, 24 months.
We also wanted to make sure, of course, that it was technically sound.
So we took this to our technical design group, also in June.
And they also agreed to the recommendation that we were making.
So their thoughts were, of course, status can only be appropriately reported with two years of data.
So looking at the 2019 for the dashboard.
And then three years of data will be necessary to produce a valid
status and change or of course a color for the LP.
I said this in the beginning, but I'll keep it towards the end because the last bullet there really emphasizes that the TDG wanted to make sure that they acknowledge and we acknowledge, of course, that our English learner students are already included in all dashboard indicators.
And in fact, several districts are now in differentiated assistance because their English learners were not performing in one or more various indicators.
So looking at the state plan, there was a couple letters on this in the dashboard.
What the state plan, which is of course your next item that Marguerite will present, what it does is it outlines our future plans for use of the LP.
What we've committed to in that is once two years of data are available, we will be reporting status.
And so that is something I wanted to make sure that I clarified in here.
And then we've committed to revisiting this methodology
next year when these two years of results are available.
So these are our key activities.
This is perhaps a preview of what I've already committed to.
So I forgot that this slide was in here.
You know, what to anticipate from us.
And perhaps depending on the discussion, we can adjust these.
I think these are always open for discussion.
It sounds like if the board wants to hear about this more often than a year from now, of course, we can do that.
So you will formally adopt on the dashboard report, of course, you're over your next two meetings.
But looking at your involvement, we are looking for the status cut scores to be approved, of course, a year from next fall, so November of 2019.
And then as I've already said,
November of 2020 approve the change cut scores.
So with that I wanted to open it up for technical questions and like I referenced Veronica and Jonathan are here to assist with responding to questions.
Go ahead, Mayor Stroud.
So, first of all, thank you again and the team for all the work, all the outreach, all the stakeholder input on this particular issue.
I know we're changing to new assessment and I know we want to adopt valid and reliable measures.
So I appreciate the comment about the question about when the data will be reliable and that we may need more time.
That being said, I just would say I'm going to make a proposal in the move after public comment, but I'm concerned that we wait three years if there's a possibility that the data would be reliable after two years.
So I feel like we need to see the second year of data and see what it offers, look at possible consideration for our dashboard.
at that time, and then if we've got overwhelming evidence that we would not be serving students well, we can consider that as a board.
But I think we care, English learners are a huge population for us to serve.
If we serve English learners effectively, we impact everything, quality teaching in all of our schools.
And I just don't want to right now put it out three years till 2020 just to be safe when maybe in 2019 we're okay.
So I just want to just say publicly to the board as well that I'm going to be making a recommendation that we need to bring it back for further consideration for possible inclusion based on the data we have at the time and not
at 2019, at the end of two years.
And then if we're, I would just say, if the data comes back, like we've had to delay because we've got issues in growth model, then we look at it then.
But I'm not comfortable waiting three years out just to be sure.
I just wanna say that.
Okay, board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
My J sister, I love you so much.
I love Ileane.
And I want to acknowledge and, you know, obviously, I had a lot of questions leading up to today, but I definitely want to acknowledge the work of the department, Superintendent Torlakson's leadership when it comes to English learners, of course, Veronica and her team.
Not sort of, I never, do I think any of us think that this group has been neglected in terms of our work, our policies.
We pass the EO roadmap, we have the integrated frameworks.
And I know that they're in each of the indicators.
However, the EO group looks very differently in each of those indicators, right?
And the academic indicator, recall that.
you all voted to include our FIPS students in the academic indicator.
So it's English learners plus we classify students up to four years.
So that's a slightly different group of students when we look in the academic indicator.
And it's academics, it's subject matter, it's not language proficiency.
Suspension, that's school climate.
For graduation, that's only high school students.
And so this is a critical indicator for us to continue monitoring progress towards language proficiency.
I was at the EL roadmap kickoff and in small group discussions, there was a teacher that said, I think one of the challenges going back to my school is that we're a high performing school and our English learner population is so small.
So, it's going to be really hard for us to change practice when people feel like, you know, it's not broken, why fix it?
And I thought about this particular indicator, because this is the indicator that will tell us, are you really a high performing school for all of your students?
And of course, there's other subgroups that also would have their own indicator, but
I think for us, I want to agree with Eileen, with Board Member Strauss, that let's come back in 2019 and see.
I don't want us to go years without public accountability for this particular student group.
And if in 2019 we have the data, then let's do that.
Let's start looking at, can we identify, and I know we won't be able to identify for comprehensive or targeted support, because that's on a three-year basis, but we will be able to identify for LEAs at the annual, under LCFF.
Thank you.
Okay, any other comments on this item?
If not, then we're ready for public comment.
I actually have some good news to share first.
I have two or three more slides.
So I wanted to just take the opportunity to do some shout outs.
The governor in his January budget proposed $300,000 for updating the dashboard's user interface.
We, of course, supported that and the legislature supported it.
And of course, the governor signed that into law.
We have been working with our contractor, which is San Joaquin County Office of Education.
They released a request for proposal recently, and we did an info session for interested vendors, and we told them about all of the great feedback we've gotten and some of the bad feedback we've gotten.
You know, really critical of what changes need to be made to the dashboard, and also told them a list of things that we expected them to produce in a prototype, including a Spanish translation version, how that looked.
So Collaborative Communications, based in Washington, DC, was a successful bidder.
They've worked with groups like the Data Quality Campaign.
They worked on Illinois State Report Card, as well as, I think, DC Public Schools, if I'm right.
They have actually already been on board and provided us an initial design and they will be delivering a prototype to us this weekend.
I have to make sure that
You're all aware, but I'm going to remind you that just because we have a design, we then actually have to implement it in a website.
And so this particular contract was only to give us really the look and feel of it.
San Joaquin Office of Education will have to actually implement this.
And so we wanted to make sure that we did make sure, rather, when we put out the request for proposals, that they knew what the expectations were as far as
how San Joaquin works, what kind of software they work with, and such like that.
So trying to make this as easy of a transition as possible.
With that said, we have to make some decisions very quickly over the next couple of weeks because San Joaquin will need to get started on implementation.
because we have committed to the field, like we did last year, that they'll get a month of preview time to look at their data.
So what we did last year was we opened it up around the first week of November.
We're planning to do the same this year, and rolling out the indicators, a couple indicators every week.
And so by the time we get to a public release in December, they are very aware of things.
If for some reason the department made a mistake in a calculation, we've caught it ahead of time so that it's not something that, you know,
makes newsworthy.
So with that in mind, we have reached out and actually the state board staff and Sarah Petrosky has been fantastic.
I took a little vacation and she got all this done in my absence.
And so it's great to have that collaboration.
But next week is going to be a busy week of stakeholder input.
We actually have PTAs hosting a group of parents for us, AXA is hosting a group of administrators for us, and then we've done invitations to the major education and equity groups for an input session that the vendor is going to host this next week.
So with that in mind, I just wanted to let you know that
We are seeing some amazing things.
You will have a new look and feel for this dashboard.
And I think you'll be happy with what is ultimately selected and implemented in December.
And then finally, just to put it all in context, over the last 60 days, we participated in 25 outreach activities.
And this is as, of course, the year was ending for many schools.
But we were able to reach about 2,000 individuals.
And so I think that's really
Really important, but what I do want to mention is that we still have a long way to go Jenny went to I think there was a migrant the migrant conference was in San Francisco recently and she was offered an opportunity to present and she had a room for 60 or 75 people and we only had 12 participants and so we have to do a better job about getting out there about why it's important that they come to our sessions and they and
They participate in these meetings and we're going to look at new ways to partner up with outreach on the outreach side over the next couple of months.
So with that, I am done with my presentation.
I'll go back to presentation.
We're now ready for public comment.
Please call the list.
Will the following speakers please line up?
Not now.
Go ahead.
Will the following speakers please line up?
Doug McRae, Katrina Gregana, Andrea Ball, Carrie Heschnell, Samantha Tran, Cesar Cruz, Kimberly Godano, Kelly Joy, Riguel Masrano, Alma Lopez, Martha Alvarez, Felicia Jones, Gabe Garcia, Lee Angela Reed, and Elizabeth Robitalli.
Good morning.
I'm Doug McRae, retired education measurement specialist from Monterey.
I support all three of the staff recommendations today.
Regarding the action to delay a growth model,
My primary comment is the Smarter Balanced psychometric infrastructure is currently not strong enough to support a reliable and valid growth model application.
Details for this statement can be found in your electronic folder.
I'd also comment true growth model measurement for K-12 tests has been a holy grail for measurement specialists for more than 50 years.
during which time known uniformly accepted method has generated wide support.
My personal history goes back to 1966 when I was a grad student intern at one of the major test publishers.
Regarding three-year plan to implement LP indicator, I'd note yet to be validated operational LPAC scores from last spring based upon preliminary cut scores from last November argue against formal use for accountability beginning fall 2018.
Adding to reasons for the three-year plan, that adds to reasons.
More on this topic can be found in your electronic folder.
Thank you.
Good morning, Catharina Gargana on behalf of CABE and Californians Together.
First, we would like to state that we are appreciative of the progress made thus far on integrating the local, state, and federal accountability and continuous improvement system.
However, we have concerns.
We would like to echo the comments made by Board Member Strauss and Board Member Ortiz-Licn.
We have concerns about the suggested three-year timeline for the English learner proficiency indicator and request that the board consider revising the recommendation as outlined in our letter to state that when CDE has two years of data for the LPAC, the board will revisit the LP methodology cut points and timelines for the English language proficiency.
Additionally, if the proposed three-year timeline for the LP is adopted, there will be no indicator in the state accountability system that looks at progress of current ELs on the dashboard.
We request that the modification be made to be consistent with the proposal in the SS plan for identifying the bottom 5% Title I schools for targeted support.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Chair, members, Superintendent Torlakson, Andrea Ball on behalf of the California School Boards Association.
Three comments.
On the growth model, we do think it is important and valuable to continue looking at this and really making progress and helping districts who want this additional perspective on their students' progress.
So please continue to look at this.
Take advantage of the expertise that's been offered to you.
On the English learner progress indicator, we do have a concern about the lack of or the potential to not have districts focus on English learners to the extent we need to.
Board member Strauss' proposal is one that seems really interesting and hope you will explore if there's valid data in two years to come back and look at that.
And finally, on the last point that Cindy Kazanis made about the dashboard improvements, we're thrilled, and CSBA would like to offer to help you with that outreach, getting feedback, and participating in the stakeholder work on that.
Thank you.
Good morning, Carrie Hannel with the Education Trust West.
I want to speak about the student growth measure.
We are deeply concerned about the continued delay on the student growth measure.
We need a clear timeline, a short timeline at this point for moving forward.
We don't think a three-year plan is adequate.
We have talked about this for the past 15 years and think that we have enough information, enough data, enough study to make a decision with some additional refinements.
You say that this doesn't tell us if achievement gaps are closing.
The status measure and the change measure together don't tell us that either.
They're extraordinarily volatile.
What the growth measure does is it provides fair data on schools that have highly mobile populations and on schools that have significant portions of English learners, students with disabilities, or students who are performing very low or very high as compared with their peers.
What it does do is it helps us address the achievement gap, which is even more important.
It provides data on student learning, and it helps us identify as a state the schools that need the most support.
There are schools that are further behind that are making faster progress, and schools that are further behind that are making less progress, and we need to know the difference between the two.
The state is uniquely positioned to do that.
Districts and schools do not have this data on their own.
You have a responsibility to make this data available and use it for accountability purposes.
Thank you.
Good morning, Felicia Jones with COPE.
We represent families and students in the Inland Empire.
We agree that a student growth measure should happen swiftly and should be included in the dashboard.
We know too well what our schools look like when they're failing.
And we also know what they look like when they are actually serving and advancing learning for students.
But our families should not have to guess on where they're going to find that consistency in their schools.
Setting this standard makes it possible for us to get it right for students who continue to fall.
in that achievement gap and for those students whom that gap continues to widen.
We certainly are, again, supporting a growth measurement and really hope that you will make a decision quickly.
As a parent, I have been an advocate for a long time.
and have longed to see this type of measurement for my own child.
And I know that there are so many other parents that want the same.
We cannot delay the hopes and dreams of our parents and our students while we try and figure this out.
Please get it right for our parents and students.
Thank you.
Good morning, Samantha Tran with Children Now.
I just want to say we really do appreciate all the work that Cindy and Jenny and Michelle and the team at CDE and State Board have done over the last several years.
This lift to create an accountability system is massive and we're all trying to do it for the benefit of kids.
We recognize that the technical policy and communications issues related to a growth measure are really complex and intricate and interconnected.
And as such, you know, we recognize that more time is going to be needed.
But per board member Felice Ortiz-Lacombe's suggestion, a very clear timeline on that front would be highly valued by the field.
It would give us faith that things are moving forward.
In addition to that, we would strongly recommend that you bring together a body similar to the PSAA committee that we had before, because it gave us an opportunity for stakeholders and experts to dig into these complex issues together and to really hear each other.
Because right now, the modes of communication that we're using, you know, letters that are developed on short timelines, one-minute testimony, positive or negative press coverage, it's not serving any of our interests.
And I think we have much more in common than the different perspectives we have around these issues and the need to resolve them together.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Kelly Joy, and I'm a member of the research and policy team at Innovate Public Schools, a nonprofit whose mission is to increase the number of world-class public schools serving low-income students of color.
We strongly recommend that you do not delay the release of a student growth measure.
Innovate has a base of several thousand parents who are advocating for ways to improve educational opportunities for their children.
Reliable data about student learning at the school, district, and state levels absolutely essential to driving these efforts.
California's current way of tracking differences in student achievement over time is insufficient.
The education research field is definitely not happy with California's current change indicator and the system that we have now does not control for changing demographics or student mobility.
This means that it does not follow the same students from year to year and really limits the insights that we can get from that information.
Delaying the student growth measure would continue to hide inequities in our education system that hold back low-income students and students of color.
It also makes it difficult to identify the schools that are successfully educating these students and prevents us from learning from those models.
Parents, researchers, policymakers, and ultimately students would all benefit from a student growth measure.
We've already waited over 10 years.
A vote to delay until someday, one day is a vote to deny this critical information to families who deserve it.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
My name is Alma Lopez.
I'm a parent advisor at Sac City Unified School District.
And I'm here to urge you to adopt the growth measure.
I think it's something imperative because it would allow to measure the rate at which our students are learning from year to year.
And from my experience working with the students but also with their families as a whole, there is a lot of mobility.
I worked with low income students, a lot of population of English learners and also foster youth.
And so there is homelessness, right?
I dealt with a lot of students and families who are going homelessness, who can't afford affordable housing, so they're moving.
And I think it's important for our students and they deserve to know what their progress is individually.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Kimberly Gudino.
I am a Brown Issues advisor at a school in South Sacramento, a middle school in South Sacramento.
And one of my roles and goals as an advisor on campus is to dismantle the school-to-prison pipeline and create a middle school-to-career pipeline.
And the current growth measure, the current measure, it makes it a lot more difficult for me to do this.
So the growth measure that we should adopt can be used to predict an average school's yearly growth using average scores of different student groups, which are like low-income, ethnic, and racial groups, and English learners.
And adopting this measure would help address the needs of our students in our communities that we serve.
Thank you.
Good morning, folks.
My name is Gabriel Garcia.
I work with the Southeast Asia Resource Action Center representing Cambodian, Laotian, and Vietnamese Americans.
We are in support of the growth measure because we understand that we cannot see how our youth and our students are doing unless we can measure their achievements over time.
This is especially important for recognizing achievement gaps.
Like was said earlier, we simply cannot understand unless we are looking not only at growth, but also growth across subgroups.
This is particularly important for Asian American and Pacific Islander youth and communities where oftentimes their data can be reported together.
By measuring growth over time with subgroups in mind, we definitely believe that
It is a powerful way for us to address the achievement gaps that persist in our communities.
That's why we see the growth measure as a first step for evolving California's data systems to actually be reflective of the needs of California's youth.
Thank you.
Good morning, Marta Alvarez on behalf of AXA, the Association of California School Administrators.
We are supportive of the staff recommendations on the three items before you today on item number one.
We really want to thank the Department of Education staff, State Board of Education staff, because they have been truly working around the clock to get this work done with very thoughtful recommendations.
On the growth model, AXA continues to support the inclusion of the growth model in the accountability system.
For us, it's a matter of the timing and definitely finding information as we get more SBAC information over the next couple of years.
So, we want to ensure that we have the right model that's considered, as well as enough information to ensure that we reduce that volatility.
On the second item regarding a safety safety net methodology We support the staff recommendation and we also encourage the recommendation that was made about looking into the chronic absenteeism and CCI indicator to see if it should be applied there for the ELPI also support the recommendation and We encourage the staff to consider how to report on the dashboard that that will be in transition over the next year Thank you
It brings me great joy to be here.
State Superintendent Torlakson, many moons ago when we had more black hair.
Could you just introduce your name, please?
Yeah, my name is Dr. Cesar Cruz.
You took a stand and you joined us as we went without eating for 26 days.
That was back in 2004.
It's great to see you again.
I prepared the following statement.
On the K-12 academic journey, some kids are born into elevator-type communities that help them rise to the top.
Others coast a bit slower, but at the right pace in well-working escalators.
And then there are those kids who try to climb from broken and missing stairs.
My name is Dr. Cesar Cruz, and I come from a lot of broken and missing stairs, but I'm a proud California public school baby.
For 24 years, I've been an educator in Oakland and Richmond, standing in solidarity with kids on their uphill climb.
We want to measure students' growth, but how can we fairly compare how one group did last year to a random group this year?
Without this growth data, we will be ill-prepared to appropriately differentiate support.
In my work, this growth measure is vital.
I'm designing a new public alternative high school in Oakland for kids who've been pushed out.
Like one of our board members, Ortiz-Licn, said, we can't schedule this for someday, because someday is not the mythical eighth day in the seven-day week.
Please schedule it and please vote.
Thank you so much.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Rigel Massaro with Public Advocates.
I'm making comments aligned with the letter submitted by the LCFF Equity Coalition.
First, we strongly support adoption of a student growth model as part of the dashboard of the new accountability system.
This information will only contribute to local analyses regarding how to address equity and achievement caps.
We think it's important to realize that the growth measure information will not drive the entire local conversation.
Our entire accountability system from the LCAP to the dashboard to the system of support are based on multiple points and years of data, not a single year snapshot on test scores only.
This can help control for the impact of year-to-year fluctuations in any one measure.
Secondly, we're pleased to see work plans to make the dashboard more user-friendly.
We're concerned, however, about the revision.
We want it to be user-friendly.
And so to do that, we need robust and not rushed feedback from parent and community stakeholders.
And the summer months are not a good time to get meaningful stakeholder feedback.
We support Member Strauss' recommendation also the ELPI indicator be kept to a two-year timeline subject to revision.
Thank you.
Good morning, LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
I want to thank the board and department staff for their tremendous work on the development of and really reviewing the growth model.
SSDA strongly supports a growth model, particularly as we look at our alternative ed programs, because we think we really need to be able to show that.
But this delay is imperative.
It has to be information that's accurate.
And I think the RG model, while really good, does not provide that at this time.
When you have one student and you're looking at them from third to fourth grade, they're being compared against different students on different standards.
It doesn't provide the information that parents really are looking for.
I think the time will be well spent.
I also want to thank the department and board staff for looking at the safety net.
And we think it's really important to do the three by five and particularly appreciate looking at chronic absenteeism, which is a huge issue for some of our rurals and that volatility there.
So we look forward to being part of the conversation.
Finally,
I want to thank the board and department staff for the work on the dashboard interface and the tremendous outreach they've done to include stakeholders in that process.
We look forward to that conversation.
Thank you.
Good morning, I'm Sarah Lillis, the executive director of Teach Plus.
I'm here also in support of incorporating a growth model.
We appreciate board members Ortiz-Cohn's request for a concrete timeline.
We also really would push for really identifying a more robust conversation, whether it is a PSAA model or another model that really incorporates voices from the teachers, because we do feel
that in our new accountability system where we're really focusing on support and improvement, a growth model is important and meaningful information for educators to have, both in terms of identifying where there is progress and where there isn't progress, and really looking at issues of equity, not necessarily identifying achievement gaps, but if we are to address those students who have been underserved or who have been left behind for so long.
that this is a really critical measure.
We also do support on the idea of Board Member Strauss' recommendation on the ELPI.
We also want to offer our assistance as we're looking at the interface.
Our educators are really eager to better use the tool of the dashboard and be a part of that conversation.
So we hope that teachers can not only be at the table, but help lead the process.
Thank you.
Hello, board.
My name is Kathy Serzaga.
I am a high school math teacher of 30 years, started 1988 in Pennsylvania, New Jersey.
Past 15 years, I've been teaching in Arizona.
Just recently, I moved to California.
I'm showing up at this board meeting because I feel like I have a vested interest in what California has to do in the next 20 years of my potential career before I retire officially.
I think the things that I want to say is, in your comment of how to control, as a high school math teacher who understands statistics, maybe not necessarily the depth of this controlled model of growth, I would have to say some things that came to my mind is, how do you control student mobility?
How do you control staff mobility?
Is that a variable in this equation?
Has anybody thought about it?
Is it something to be considered, maybe a column to add to your statistical analysis?
And how do you control testing?
In Arizona, there's this.
Thank you.
Three tests that have been in and out.
Elizabeth Robitaille on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
We support the idea of taking more time to get the right growth model, but rather than delay indefinitely, we urge the board to place a high priority on finalizing a growth model in the upcoming school year and publishing a revised dashboard
in spring of 2019 that includes growth.
It's important to note that based on analysis that both CCSA and CORE have done independently of each other, that the state's current change indicator in the dashboard is actually equally or more volatile than the growth model that CDE has tested.
Without an actual growth model, California's dashboard will misidentify as underperforming schools with a large number of low-income students who are actually achieving high growth.
For charter schools, authorizers are making renewal determinations, in some cases deciding to close schools, when in reality these schools may be substantially positively impacting student learning.
Therefore, we ask that the state place a high priority on finalizing a new growth measure by next spring.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
That concludes the testimony and so we're ready for board deliberation and action.
Board Member Strauss.
So I'm going to make a proposed substitute recommendation and then we can talk about it as well.
I think we need a few clarifying points before.
And really this recommendation actually, I think the original recommendation in the board just wasn't as clear and specific as we need to be really clear about what we want to do as a board.
And I think it follows based on what we heard in the presentation and in the technical clarification.
So it has three parts.
So bear with me.
And then we're going to pass out paper copies that we just did.
So this is a substitute recommendation for item one.
The CDE recommends that the State Board approve number one, further study of the growth model, including but not limited to the impact of future years of assessment data, changes in the model to reduce year-to-year volatility, and consideration of additional growth models.
That's number one.
Number two, the recommended proposal to apply the safety net methodology to student groups.
And number three, the three-year plan for the ELPI with the addition of the CD report to State Board of Education following the collection of the second year of ELPAC data for consideration of options for using the data for accountability purposes in the California School Dashboard in 2019.
Board member, motion, is it seconded?
Second by board member Burr.
Board member comment, member Burr first.
So just on the motion for a second, and then I want to make a couple comments about the testimony.
I think this is fine, obviously.
I second it.
But I hope that it will incorporate some of the comments that were made during your actual presentation about making sure that we're looking at the data that currently is available at what level, what it can be used for, for particular decision points.
Because we've used this phrase a couple times.
I think Member Sun initiated it.
We have been searching for the Holy Grail for many, many years in California.
Mr. McRae has been since 1960, middle of the 60s.
And I just, so I just want people to understand that.
And I think we may be wishing for something that doesn't exist.
We'll keep looking and and I have to say that the tenor of the letters Concerned me because they seem to be kind of accusatory that we were not going to try to move forward Which is absolutely not the case.
We're happy to keep looking at it We want to be clear about what we're using it for and how it will be helpful again at the local level to make decisions on behalf of success for students, so
I just want to say, Cindy, I know you guys were taking notes that make sure that we're addressing some of those issues and being absolutely transparent.
I wanted to just make, in addition to my comment about my concern about the letters, which seem to be overly confrontational, I guess, about this topic, which I would like people to think a little bit about.
There are two points that were made in the testimony that I just think we need to correct.
We do have an advisory committee on accountability.
It's called CPAG, the California Practitioners Advisory Group.
It meets regularly, operates, has teachers.
It's a very wide-ranging committee.
And again, thanks to Cindy and Jenny and Michelle and Hurst, everybody that goes and makes these presentations invites lots of public input.
Please pay attention to CPAG if you're interested in having those kinds of discussions.
The other thing, just to reinforce, and I know everybody knows this, but our accountability system and our funding system is built on what we do for student subgroups.
It has equity at its core.
So the comments about not, it seemed like I heard people saying we need a lot more information because you're masking what's happening with subgroups.
Again, I hope that you'll educate yourself about that and about the data that's available and how important it is that we not make the mistake of the API where we were masking what was happening with subgroups.
Just wanted to make those comments to make sure that people were clear about how they could provide input and how our data is reported and how we're focused on student subgroup performance.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you.
And I do like the motion, but for number one,
I would like, you mentioned a memo, and I would like us to identify when that memo with the timeline for further action would come to us for the study of the RG model.
So if we could be more specific as to when we could expect, you know, so I know there's gonna be further study, but when can we expect some sort of timeline that tells us when this information will be coming back to the board, whether it be as a presentation or via memos?
And in terms of some of the comments that were made, what I heard was not necessarily that we're negating or not paying attention to equity, but that what we currently have does not give us a measure of whether or not we're closing achievement gaps and how students are progressing.
Not one cohort, cohort A versus cohort B, but cohort A as they move from one grade level to the next.
And so I do want to, that's what I heard.
But I also heard a lot of people wanting to be part of the conversation and I think we should include them because it doesn't become your problem, it becomes our problem.
And if we're all listening and are challenged by the same methodology and we have to wrestle with the same issue,
then there's an understanding that it's not them versus us, it's really all of us collectively trying to figure this out.
So I think opening the conversation really is a win-win.
We bring more stakeholders, more voices to the table, but it also really dispels the myth that we're trying to do this
There's technical design group that no one knows who they are and they're not really perhaps focused on the same things we're focused.
Their urgency is not the same.
I think people are really concerned with a sense of urgency, of narrowing achievement gaps, making sure that we're really tracking students and really holding ourselves accountable for their progress or lack thereof.
And so I think that sense of urgency is what's really causing or, you know,
the comments and I read it more as, how can we help you?
How can we be part of the same conversation?
So I think we're all on the same team, people, yay.
Okay, board member Sun.
I agree, and I will support the recommendations as they're written here.
But I also want to emphasize that as we are looking at reducing the volatility and consideration of additional growth models,
I'd like us to think maybe a little bit outside the box, because it could be perhaps that this growth model, holy grail, does not exist.
But we do know what the problem is that exists, and it is our challenges in closing the achievement gaps.
And so we need to be able to measure it in some way and then be able to identify those practices that are accelerating the closing of those gaps.
If it's not the growth model, if it's some other way of looking at the data or some other way of digging down into the depths of this, then that's fine.
But I think we all are clear on what the issue is.
Let's open it up beyond growth model, perhaps, to be able to figure that out.
And the other piece I would say, I do think that with all of the different, all the work that we have, there's so many priorities.
I don't want this to fall off the list.
So I would agree with a very clear timeline.
And the other piece around this in the stakeholder input is because this is so technical and so nuanced that I do think that there needs to be a specific group of folks who come together to talk about this and with experts in this area, technical experts and access for those who want to hear the conversation and be able to provide input along the way.
Board member Rucker, I think was next and then Sandoval.
OK, so first of all, I want to join the chorus of folks who truly appreciates the work that the department does in not only doing this research and working with consultants and stakeholders, but in coming prepared to each of these board members.
I mean, each of these board meetings to lay out what all of the issues are.
And so it's always with a certain amount of trepidation when I study the board item that's this board item related to accountability that I have concern not only about how full and how packed the item is, but on all the multiple perspectives on what it is that we should be doing.
While there has been a great deal of effort to create consonance and create some agreements and consensus about where the priorities are and the direction that this board has taken, there remains this sense of what is the great unanswered or what seems to be the great intractable
and unresolvable issue.
You know, this is one of those times again when I find my English major and that degree I have in English of great use to me.
While people want to talk about or use this metaphor of the growth model as a holy grail, I want to remind you the holy grail was an idea.
and ideal.
It was romanticized in literature as something we continue searching for, but it was never attained.
And so if we want, if the goal is to actually implement a growth model, find a different metaphor.
Because...
The most important goal is to figure out how to close the achievement gap.
And while closing the achievement gap is something that I have observed at the policy level, people have given lip service to for a long time.
This state adopted an API that said schools were still making growth and gains and could actually be recognized as golden seal schools even when African American students were performing as much as 100 points behind
everybody else.
So that is not accountability that closes the achievement gap.
I think we have to understand what we're looking at in trying to define or quantify what the achievement gap is and how we want to report it.
That's the first thing.
And then we have to figure out when we give that report, what are we expecting schools to do with that data?
When I was a classroom teacher and we would have our meetings about accountability at the beginning of the year,
It lasted about three minutes because that was about how long it took to say three sentences.
The test scores are down, raise them, talk to you next year.
That is not a conversation that raises the achievement gap, nor is simply coming up with a better or more refined way of reporting data the conversation that leads to closing the achievement gap.
My favorite metaphor has always been from the days when we implemented NCLB is that weighing the pig doesn't make it any fatter.
Feeding the pig makes the pig fatter.
So if we're going to close the achievement gap, we have to understand the secret or the work is not in refining the reporting, but providing the important and incremental support to schools that the data says the schools need.
So I'm happy to continue participating in this conversation about the growth model and about the work that we need to do.
I think it's important for us to add this data about the English learners for reporting purposes to the accountability model and do that in a more precipitous way.
But when we finish refining all of these data points and we continue adding more tests and adding more data points, we still need to feed the pig.
Thank you.
Board Member Sandoval.
Thank you, Member Eckert.
That was really well said.
Thank you.
Beautifully said.
So I just want to thank everyone for breaking down some very complex information so that it's more digestible.
But I think that we're working hard to get it right.
And it's going to take time and not that anyone wants to delay narrowing the achievement gap.
But we have to be really honest about what this information would give us and how we're going to use it to help feed the pig, as you said.
But I think that the revised motion makes good sense.
And I also agree that having a timeline.
Could you go to the item?
There was not the recommendation, but the next steps.
that were proposed, especially for the study of the growth model.
One was looking at the information.
It was continue to provide LEAs and schools support on how to analyze their annual assessment results to set LCAP goals.
So I think that more done out in the field to help inform our stakeholders and engage them in conversations about how we can use the information that we're already gathering to inform, improve teaching and learning, and narrow the achievement gap is essential.
May I?
Carrick Ashley, Deputy Superintendent, Performance Planning and Technology Branch.
Thank you for that comment.
Thank you for the comment.
I just want to inform you, I guess, that we recently sent out a letter to all superintendents
telling them that now that we've got the assessment system that we have, they're getting results within two or three weeks from a student being tested, which means they've now had the results about six to eight weeks already.
And that they do not have to, they should not wait for the state to do a press release on all of the results until they do something with that data.
Because that's some of the information we were hearing back.
They were reticent to put any data out publicly about it until the state had done a press release.
So we did send that letter.
People should be using that information to identify gaps, identify needs, address those in their LCAPs.
They should not be waiting for our press release, just like they should not be waiting for a growth model or an accountability system, because neither one of those things changes teaching and learning.
The primary purpose of our assessment system is to improve teaching and learning.
And accountability systems help us point out where needs are, points out where people need assistance.
But it doesn't change what happens in the classroom.
And that's the urgency.
And that's what we want people to do with their assessment data now, not later.
And so the urgency is there.
And the data is there available to be used now.
Okay.
Any other board members?
Go ahead.
Oh, you weren't done.
I'm sorry.
No, I wasn't.
Just that it would be good to have a general, not right now, but perhaps at the next meeting or an information memo, a reasonable timeline for how this work is going to be unfolding.
And I think how we're going to use the good information that our stakeholders have provided and recommendations and proposed approaches, I think is important.
Thank you.
Board member Valdez.
So a couple of things.
As we think about the system and we think about, you know, we have LCFF, we have the priorities, we have an LCAP and we have the dashboard and all of that information, there is this real want, if you will, at the local level to let it soak in, to really begin to, as we're working with all of this information.
But yet there is a concern that it would be lovely to have this growth model.
We want the growth model, but it has to be able to close those gaps.
And as we were talking, perhaps,
instead of being known as a growth model, maybe we're called the closer, but that idea of closing the gap, right?
So we need to focus in on that.
One thing that we've heard from the letters and from today is that there are people, groups of, celebrated groups that work with lots of different people to have, and have many different voices, if you will, and perspectives.
And in the spirit of improvement science, have we thought about not just having stakeholder groups, and I was part of CPAC,
It was a great opportunity, and they are a very well-represented group.
But perhaps we do appeal in ourselves.
We create a problem of practice, and we talk about the problem, and not the problem, but the opportunity, because if the Holy Grail doesn't exist, I think we should be the research, that we should build, like Sun is saying, board member Sun, we become the research.
And in order to do that, and it's a problem of practice, but an opportunity of practice, to bring together different organizations,
that have voices, and we have a conversation about it.
Not just one-to-one conversations, but in this, let's just talk about it.
And I think that that leads to great action.
So it's just an idea.
We're asking counties and districts and different groups to do that.
Have we done that here?
So I want to just kind of summarize a point that I'm requesting for CDE in advance of our next meeting, which is in September.
I think we have an ongoing item on our board agenda on accountability, and I think we should have an item which gives us a full timeline of all the things coming up, the things that we need to work on, what we've agreed to,
what the work group, when it's going to CPAG, when it's going out for stake, just a whole timeline.
That would really help clarify.
I know there's a huge number of stakeholder meetings and inputs, and yet you hear from public, oh, there's no opportunity for input.
And I know we go to CPAG, and we all talk about it, and yet people say there's no
group that we can give input to.
So I just think with the commitment to look at further models and the timeline, I just think it would be really helpful.
So I'm just making a formal request in the agenda planning for our September meeting that on accountability, we have a full time.
I think it'd be helpful for everybody.
And I believe you work with one because you have to manage all the projects you guys are working on anyway.
So I'm just, I think that would help all of us.
Okay, Board Member Williams.
Just a small thing.
I want to emphasize the part of the discussion that I think everyone agrees on.
That we take the opportunity, since we're taking some time, not too much time, making it a high priority, wanting to move it forward.
But we take the opportunity to look at something other than the RG model.
And in the context of asking ourselves,
As I've heard most of you say, what is it we want out of this?
What is it we want to know?
What is it that the state itself, the CDE, the state board wants to get out of a model?
And what is it that would be most beneficial to the field in terms of using it?
to not only close achievement gaps, but also to move all students to meeting the standard.
So in that context, maybe you did this once before and I'm just spacing on it, but some kind of even matrix for me, this is a kind of a technical thing, but
some kind of matrix about these are the different kinds of models and here's what each state or this field learns from that.
And these are ways that data can be used and helpful.
So I agree with moving forward.
I agree with making it a really high priority to move forward quickly.
You guys must be just so exhausted.
And so let me also compliment you, all of you, all of you at CDE for the work that you do on this.
It's gone on for a very long time and it's very technical and very tedious and complicated and I really appreciate it.
And so moving forward, moving forward expeditiously, taking into consideration what you've heard,
considering more than the RG model, and with each one of them asking the question, what is the use of this information?
How is it going to help either the state make decisions about whether things are moving forward well?
And how is it going to help schools and teachers
make decisions about how to improve the performance of their students.
And I like the idea of another group, but I like the idea of another group with technical people, like the technical advisory group, or their, you know, companions.
They're people with really deep technical knowledge that we can have a chance to hear them as well.
Okay, I think that concludes the comments.
I have talked with the executive director about trying to think about how to get some more resources to help you in these tasks.
I mean, this is not in a lot of work schedules and the timing is an issue.
So I just want to let the board know that we're
we're going to be conferring together and with the board members about how we can bring this about without just saying, here's another task, go do it.
And do it by, you know, yesterday.
So we will... Thank you.
Just a little perspective.
What districts are doing right now is giving us all their data.
And that data period closes at the end of next month.
So between the end of next month, which is really like September 1st and December 1,
We will be all hands on deck to figure out how to put together this year's dashboard.
I don't want to overcommit, but we will get you a timeline.
I just want to put that in perspective.
It's really important that we get this year's accountability system out and this dashboard out.
January is after the holidays.
January is a new day and hopefully we'll have the ESSA plan well behind us.
So we'll have, you know, identified new districts and we'll have put forward what we have to do for ESSA as well.
Well, we want to work with you in the interim to talk about how to, you know, while you're doing what you have to do for everything else, how we can move this along.
Thank you.
Okay.
I think we're ready for a vote.
We have a motion and a second.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, it's unanimous.
Thank you.
We're now on to item two and that is the Essa Redux.
You know, this is like one of these dragons.
You slay one head and another one comes up and you knock that one off and another one comes up.
So here we go again.
Oh, sorry.
Okay, Marguerite Reese will present for us.
Good morning, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the board.
This morning I will provide information related to item two, update on the development of the California State Plan for the Every Student Succeeds Act, approval of the revisions to the state plan for resubmission to the U.S.
Department of Education.
The CDE and state board staff anticipated that the ESSA update provided at the April meeting would be the final state plan development update item.
And at today's meeting, we would be able to celebrate the approval of California state plan.
Alas, that did not happen.
That's right.
As the board takes one last look at finalizing California's ESSA Consolidated State Plan, I want to very briefly reiterate the foundational elements of the Every Student Succeeds Act, the reauthorization of the Elementary and Secondary Education Act or ESEA.
The ESSA maintains the original purpose of ESEA, equal opportunity for all students.
The act ensures that disadvantaged and high needs students receive the same educational opportunities as their peers.
As of today, the Secretary of Education has approved 48 state plans from states in addition to the Territory of Puerto Rico.
It is worth noting that no states were immediately approved upon submission.
All received at least one round of feedback.
California's approach is somewhat different than most of the states with approved plans and that the State Board weighs in on each draft of the plan.
Throughout the state plan development process, state board and CD staff have worked together on what has been a highly collaborative development process shared by our two agencies.
Given that the State Board has received updates from the CDE related to the development of the State Plan at nearly every meeting for the last two and a half years, my comments today related to the State Plan development timeline will be limited to the activities of the last several months.
Additional historical information is provided in today's board item as well as previous agenda materials archived on the State Board of Education's webpage.
At the April meeting, the board recommended approval of the revised state plan, which reflected several changes to the related Title I accountability provisions of the ESSA statute.
The revised state plan was submitted to the U.S.
Department of Education shortly after the April meeting.
At the April meeting, the state board also directed the CDE to develop a waiver request to the U.S.
Department of Education related to the English Learner Progress Indicator, or ELPI.
California submitted the waiver request in May after incorporating the required stakeholder feedback.
The U.S.
Department of Education has 120 days to issue a ruling on the waiver, and as of today, California has not received a formal response related to the request, although we do know that they have received the waiver and are in the process of reviewing it.
On June 11th, California was surprised to receive an additional feedback letter from the U.S.
Department of Education indicating that upon their final review of California's proposed state plan, they found a few remaining outstanding issues.
In an effort to bring resolution to the state plan development process and move California toward full implementation of the federal statute, CDE and state board staff worked closely with the U.S.
Department of Education to develop what we are certain is a final, final draft.
Based on those conversations with staff from the ED over the last several weeks, the CDE and State Board staff proposed to make the revisions to the State Plan included in today's meeting materials.
Prior to today's State Board meeting, the CD hosted a public, in-person, and webinar meeting related to the proposed revisions to the State Plan from the accountability sections on July 2nd.
Staff walked through the areas of feedback from the U.S.
Department of Education and described the proposed modifications to California State Plan for over 100 meeting participants.
The proposed language in the item reflects the changes that the CDE believes need to make in order to have an approvable plan.
Based on our conversations with ED staff, the CDE is confident that if the board ultimately adopts these revisions, the secretary will finally approve the plan.
Pending the action of the board today, the CD's prepared to submit the state plan today.
Once submitted, we are optimistic that the U.S.
Department of Education will approve our state plan fairly quickly.
We anticipate receiving a notice of approval in less than a month.
The slide before you includes the CDE and State Board staff joint recommendation.
I will read it now and repeat the recommendation slide at the conclusion of the presentation.
The California Department of Education and State Board of Education staff recommend that the State Board approve the revised state plan for submission to the U.S.
Department of Education pending the State Board of Education Executive Director approval of final revisions requested by the State Board of Education
correction of any typographical errors, and necessary non-substantive clarifying edits.
There are four attachments related to this item.
Attachment one includes an overview and summary of the accountability-related items the board will consider today, and a matrix of the U.S.
Department of Education's June 11th feedback letter cross-referenced with the revised state plan.
Attachment 2 is the State Plan itself, inclusive of the proposed revisions.
You will note that this version includes all of the amendments approved by the State Board at the previous Board meetings.
Only those changes being proposed for the SBE's approval today are reflected with brackets and strikethroughs indicating the various edits.
Attachment 3 is a resource detailing state plan approval processes in the ESSA statute.
And attachment 4 is a copy of the letter we received from the U.S.
Department of Education from Principal Deputy Assistant Secretary Jason Botel, indicating to the State Board of Education that his agency has reviewed the state plan draft before you and
And should the board adopt these changes and subsequently submit this version to the U.S.
Department of Education, he intends to recommend that Secretary DeVos approve California's state plan.
The majority of the updates to the state plan are clarifying and technical in nature.
Therefore, our comments today will focus on just three areas of feedback.
The chronic absence indicator, college career indicator, and additional targeted support.
The remaining minor changes are described in attachment one of the agenda materials and in attachment two, the revised state plan.
Due to the fact that California cannot create a five by five grid for the chronic absence indicator because we only have one year of data from the 2016-17 school year, the U.S.
Department of Education expressed their concern about this indicator in California's state plan.
The second year of data from the 2017-18 school year will be available in November of this year.
In order to address this issue, the CDE proposes to revise the section to indicate that California will not use this indicator for meaningful differentiation until the State Board is able to create the 5x5 grid.
At that point, California will submit an amendment to the State Plan reflecting that 5x5 grid.
The issue is identical for the college career indicator.
Under the current timeline, staff expect to bring the 5 by 5 grids for these indicators to the state board for adoption at the November 2018 meeting and promptly submit the amended state plan with them incorporated.
This is a technical change, and the U.S.
Department of Education has not questioned the 5x5 grids the State Board has already approved.
Therefore, we expect that this will be a straightforward review.
However, there is always the possibility that some unanticipated technical issue will arise that would prevent the State Board from adopting the 5x5 grids for one or both of these indicators in November.
This is the conversation we will have with the U.S.
Department of Education in the fall.
We will not exclude any indicators that the State Board has approved in our accountability system for the 2018 dashboard.
The final issue we will describe today relates to the number four on this slide, additional targeted support.
My colleague Jenny Singh, Education Administrator from the Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Division, will join me in just a moment.
In order to best provide a summary of the proposed changes to the additional targeted support section of the plan, I'll actually begin by taking a few steps back and describing the different types of support as authorized in the ESSA statute.
The first tier or step of school identification under ESSA is comprehensive support or number one on the slide.
The CDE anticipates that California will release information regarding the lowest performing 5% of Title I schools that meet California's definition of comprehensive support in conjunction of the release of the 2018 California School Dashboard.
Similarly, states must identify high schools with graduation rates below 67% for comprehensive support, indicated by number two on the slide.
The definition of comprehensive support remains unchanged in the version of the state plan included in your materials today.
The next tier of support identified for improvement under ESSA is schools with consistently underperforming student groups, which is known as targeted support, or number three on the slide.
The final tier of support and the final tier of schools identified for improvement is known as additional targeted support, number four on the slide.
Schools identified for targeted support, number three, with one or more student groups performing at or below the level identified in comprehensive support will receive additional targeted support.
The feedback from the U.S.
Department of Education in their June 11th letter indicated that California needed to modify how the state planned to identify schools for additional targeted support in order to meet their reading of statute.
My colleague Jenny Singh will now provide a summary of those changes.
Jenny Singh again.
So I just want to very briefly go over what happens with schools when they are in certain supports.
We've had a lot of conversations about this.
We've had a lot of changes on how we're proposing to identify these schools.
So we thought a quick review would be very helpful.
So for the lowest performing 5% and schools with a graduation rate below 67%, they are identified for comprehensive support.
These schools are being identified once every three years.
They must develop and implement a comprehensive support and improvement plan.
This plan must not only be approved by the LEA, but it also must be approved by the State Educational Agency, the SEA.
So that is something that we will have to do.
So the SEA must also monitor and periodically review these schools.
So that is something, again, that is the responsibility of the SEA.
And then they get identified for more rigorous or intensive interventions if they do not exit within four years.
And that's what we've had in our plan.
ESSA allows up to four years before we do more intensive interventions.
So for targeted support, that's a little bit differently.
Remember, there's two different types of targeted support, which can get confusing.
This one is for consistently underperforming student groups.
And in ESSA, ESSA allows the states to determine what the criteria are for consistently underperforming student groups.
These schools are identified annually.
Okay, they must develop and implement a targeted support plan for each student group that meets the identification criteria.
So their plan is limited to those students that were identified, the student groups that were identified.
And the plan must be approved at the LEA level.
So we don't have a role in the targeted support.
for the consistently underperforming student groups.
Then we have the additional targeted support.
And this is where, this was identified in ESSA law that these are the schools that get identified where the student groups on its own meet the same criteria that we're using to identify the lowest performing 5%.
So we're using the same color combinations.
Again, here they're being identified every three years.
They must develop and implement a targeted support and improvement plan for each group that meets that criteria and that plan is approved by the LEA.
So they get identified for comprehensive support if they do not exit within four years.
That's what we have in our plan.
We can go up to four years and we're taking the four years.
So this group can then move on to more comprehensive support.
So going back to the consistently underperforming, you have to note that we did make a change in our plan and we had to do that to be able to identify schools for the additional targeted support for 2018 dashboard as we're required to do under ESSA.
So the definition is a student group that receives at least two color-coded performance ratings.
And we did this because we didn't want to over-identify schools where they only had one red indicator.
And that red indicator was suspension.
So they have to have two color performance ratings.
And on its own, it would meet the criteria, the same criteria as the Title I schools that are being identified for support, but we're using two years of data.
We're gonna use the 2017 dashboard and the 2018 dashboard.
So we're using two years to identify schools for consistently underperforming.
And with that, I will bring back Marguerite.
Thanks, Jenny.
So it's worth reiterating that in the proposed changes, both the consistently underperforming section has a proposed revision as well as the additional targeted support section has a revision in order for California to begin identifying schools for additional targeted support in the 18-19 school year to align with the US Department of Education's reading of statute.
So here's your recommendation again.
The CDE and State Board staff recommend that the Board approve the revised plan for submission to the U.S.
Department of Education pending the State Board of Education Executive Director approval of final revisions requested by the State Board, correction of any typographical errors, and necessary non-substantive clarifying edits.
And from there, I'll turn it back to President Kirst.
Thank you.
Sorry, President Chris, this is Cindy Kazanis, Director of the Analysis Measurement and Accountability Reporting Division at the Department of Education.
And just picking up from the last items discussion, I wanted to make sure that you were aware in whatever memo we give you about our work plan, there are several pieces of what has just been presented that will require us to revise the state plan, of course, once it's approved by the U.S.
Department of Education.
And so we'll try to do in a way that makes sense.
sort of when you need to take actionable, you'll have an actionable item for those revisions for accountability purposes since that's sort of what's sort of I think not said in this in these slide decks.
But since we had a robust conversation last time, I want to make sure that you are aware that we are aware of that concern and we will commit to providing that information in a transparent way.
Okay, so any technical questions on this?
We can, board member Burr.
OK, speaking as the number one fan of federal intervention here, I really need Jenny to understand this identification issue.
And you have to help me understand how this is consistent with the state's approach to accountability, which is what we always said we were going to do, was look through the lens of the state accountability system
And I worry when I see all these changes here that we are gonna send substantially mixed signals to LEAs and schools about what our expectations are.
So help me with that because I don't know what it's gonna mean when they get labeled.
You're one of the five, all of those different targeted, comprehensive, additional targeted.
What does that mean at the local level?
in the context of what they're doing, and how does their plan, if I add it up, it's kind of like adding up the aggregate number of student groups, they're gonna have like 25 plans they have to do, and how does that integrate with what we're expecting them to do with an LCAP?
So I think that's conversations that will happen at future board meetings.
Once we have an approved plan, we can then discuss how we're going to implement that plan.
But of course, we're always trying to take into consideration how to make it as easy as possible to utilize things that are already in place.
So schools already develop a plan.
This would just be a component that they would have to address.
But again, that will come up in future conversations for implementation.
So go back to the slide, because then I'm misunderstanding.
It looks like if you get labeled as one of these groups that they've targeted, it says must develop, this is additional target, must develop and implement a targeted support and improvement plan.
That's not a new plan?
That's under their LCAP?
We would like to incorporate some of this in with what we currently have, such as the LCAP plans, and all schools develop their own school plans.
So it is our goal, hopefully, to use plans that we already have so that we don't cause extra burden on schools.
Yeah, Dave Sapp wants to comment on this, yeah.
David Sepp, State Board of Education, Deputy Policy Director and Assistant Legal Counsel.
I think I'll just point back to the discussion we had in April.
And there was a question, I believe it was Board Member Rucker, who said, there's a lot of stuff to be implemented that isn't in our plan.
The way the law was written,
There were certain things that must be captured in the state plan.
There are other things that are required by the federal law that are not required to be captured in the state plan.
And this is one of those examples of the exact requirements of what a quote-unquote comprehensive improvement plan or targeted support improvement plan are is actually very open-ended in the federal law.
And there was no space in the state plan to actually say this is how we will implement it.
And there are other examples, for example, there's the expenditure reporting requirements, there's these various report cards that we must implement in order to meet the federal law.
And there is work underway, there's going to be stakeholder engagement once we hopefully have an approved plan on some of these things.
Because even some of these have moved around a little bit as a result of some of these minor adjustments that we're recommending with this item.
But we actually do have a memorandum, an info memo that we've been working on to sort of put out to the board once we have an approved plan of these are the outstanding implementation questions.
Here's the timeline of sort of when stakeholders would have, we would expect to reach out to stakeholders, have those conversations, and here's when it must be finalized for implementation as well.
But to this specific question, Board Member Burr, I think
In April, there was a reference on the comprehensive support piece, which I'm just gonna scroll back briefly, about what's sort of required here.
The board agenda materials in April noted that there's an opportunity within the existing LCAP process.
We do expect LEAs to be looking at how their schools are doing, and if there's a school that's really struggling, there's an opportunity to sort of make that explicit in the LCAP process, so it wouldn't be something new and different.
that's imposed as a separate plan, but think about how we can incorporate it into those existing processes.
The same thing is true at the school level, and I think, you know, what Jenny was alluding to, there's this thing called the single plan for student achievement.
Sorry, it's called different things, but we'll call it the SIPSA, because we love acronyms in ed policy.
That, you know, there's an opportunity to think about how for the targeted support, which requires the LEA to approve the plan that the school develops, that's already a requirement under state law.
The local governing boards must sign off on that single plan that's developed by schools, you know, at the school level involving the school site council, et cetera.
So those are some of the discussions that are sort of underway, and I think there's going to be more information that'll sort of
Be forthcoming for stakeholders and update to the board on those Implementation issues as well as which are actually gonna have to come back to the board for further action No, I appreciate what you just said David and I think you know looking at the Sarks looking at the sips is looking at the LCAP Addendum how these all go together.
That's an opportunity for us as we move forward.
I appreciate that.
Thank you
Board member Rucker.
I also appreciate all the information that you just gave us David because yeah as I did point out in an earlier meeting there is a lot of information that we're required to implement that's not being addressed in the state plan and it bears on a lot of the questions that board member Burr is raising.
I think that the other part of the question that I have is for the changes that are being required
and that are being contemplated by the action the board will take on this item.
How does it change the work plan for implementing these other items, especially in having conversations, say, for example, with the CPAG or in the ways that we inform the legislature?
about the work of the school site council and any changes that they are making or recommending concerning the SPSA that could be contemplated on this.
What are the difference?
I know the SPSA guide, you can find it on other websites, the old guide, but it's not currently available at this time on the state's website.
You know, so as you're doing this work, having taken the guide down,
How are the, how is the public being informed on what changes are being contemplated or what has to happen in changing the guide?
I think some of the questions
that board member Burr is raising is really helping us to be mindful of the fact we're not done when we get this plan approved.
There's still this really is a case of making a mountain out of a molehill.
By comparison, the state plan itself really is, you know, dwarfed in size in comparison to the rest of the work that still remains to be done.
So I'm making that comment urging
that the information memo about the rest of that work maybe needs to come out sooner rather than later because I think that that would resolve some of the anxiety I have in approving this item today because I think that there's a lot of work that the state is charged to do with implementing this, that this plan still does not answer or fully address yet.
I just wanted to add one thing.
Although we did take the guide for the SIPSA down, it is back up.
As of when?
What's that?
We can find out.
We'll find out while you were talking.
We'll find out and get back to you.
I'm just going to say last time I checked it wasn't there.
And we did.
It was down.
Because we were trying to align it more closely with LCAP.
In the meantime, the superintendent has sponsored a bill, AB 716, that's working its way through.
It'll still be, if it were passed and signed, it would still be SPSA, but the single changes to school plan for student achievement, because single plan was when we had these multiple state programs.
It was quite a while ago.
Lots of categorical.
A lot of categorical programs.
And what the bill language currently says is that if you follow what would be in Ed Code according to this bill, then you would meet the requirements of a CSI plan, a TSI plan.
Now, to the extent that we want to include it in the LCAP, that's a discussion to have and we may want to go there, but what this bill would do,
is that this would allow that to happen, because as Jenny was saying, if you were a Title I school-wide project plan, you already have to have a plan.
That's a requirement by federal law.
So this bill would just align kind of our state requirements with those federal requirements.
And of course, there's already an Ed Code requirement that requires the superintendent of a local school district to make sure that school plans are aligned with their LCAPs.
And so I'm so happy you brought up that piece of legislation.
So I'm going to ask you what I hope is not a technical question.
Does the legislation change
the schools that are required to have this plan or so that only schools that receive federal funds are required to have this plan or will all schools in the state still be required to have a school site council that writes a school plan for student achievement?
So current law does not require every school in the state to have a school plan.
And what's this going to do?
And this bill does not change that.
And so I bring that up also because if that were, again, if it were to pass and be signed, then we would once again take down our guidance so that we could update it and make sure that those things are as aligned as possible.
Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I said this before.
I think the, well, I thought passing the, getting it approved was the easy part.
Perlina, we're number 48.
Are we with Florida?
Who's that?
Florida?
Florida, Utah, and California.
Yeah, Florida, who didn't want to include an LPI indicator.
Okay, so my concern is also how do we implement this?
Because when I'm looking at comprehensive support, targeted support, there's going to be notification and identification by the LEA.
and the plans will go to the LEA.
And there's different timelines.
There's going to be three years.
There's going to be annual identification.
It's at the school level.
At some point, though, if they don't exit in four years, they become comprehensive.
And at that point, we as the SEA are the ones that have to identify.
And so it will be great to see how do we communicate?
How does that flow of communication
happen, the different reports, templates that have to be completed, it would be great for us to see all of that because administrators and superintendents, I mean, could focus all their attention just on completing these and not actually implementing them.
And then there's also expectations that I think are still a little unclear, and I know that for Title III that was raised with the LCAP addendum, and the idea that it would be a one-shot deal.
You submit it, you describe your professional development, and that's it, you're done.
But we know that Title III professional development changes, the activities change,
So how can it be a one-time occurrence, right?
And so I'm not sure if that is what is being communicated out to the field, but we also need to make sure that we understand what is the frequency that happened with the LCAP template when people thought it's three years and that's it, you could shelve it.
And then we said, no, you have to update it based on your most current data.
So I want that same type of guidance when it comes to the addendum, because I think there's a lot of confusion even here
We're sitting here and we're very confused by this.
It's a very dense policy when we're looking at LCFF and we're looking at ESSA.
And some of us know both policies quite well and it's still hard to keep up with it.
So if we could have a lot of information, I'm interested in the amendments, is that, does the ED have to approve those or is it we have an approved plan, these are the amendments, FYI, are they subject to approval, do we know?
We do know, and the U.S.
Department of Education has to approve any subsequent amendments, so there's a formal amendment approval process, just like there was under No Child Left Behind.
But the U.S.
Department of Education, Dave's right, hasn't laid out or clarified exactly what that process will entail.
because we will be submitting amendments for some of the indicators as well as the LPI.
And the U.S.
Department of Education is already aware that, you know, more amendments are coming.
We just have to cross this first hurdle of plan approval.
What I'll say related to both Member Rutger and Ortiz-Lacombe's comments is
There are a number of documents essentially sitting on my desk in draft form related to ESSA implementation, sort of guides that show much what these slides have provided of the difference between CSI, TSI, ATSI.
And we keep revising them and keep holding on to them and we can't
In good faith release guidance to the field because we don't yet have an approved plan so yes on one hand it was frustrating because we had to go through this exercise of revising the plan and Seeking your approval once again, but it was more deeply frustrating because it put us on hold for these various communications and notifications to the field so
Hope I can assure you today that CD is working closely with board staff to develop these various materials And we are looking forward to presenting them to you at upcoming meetings as soon as we have that approved plan Thank you Yeah, okay
I actually wasn't done with Jenny.
I hope it's an easy question.
I just want to know on what indicators will these schools be identified?
Because I heard that we're putting on hold chronic absenteeism and college and career.
So what are we basing the identification on?
So we are putting those two indicators on hold, but it's our plan to bring those indicators to have a five by five adopted in November, and then to submit it very quickly to the U.S.
Department of Education so that we could use those two indicators in the identification process.
And if we don't, what are they being based on?
Well, then they're based on the indicators that we currently have in place.
Which are?
We have suspension, we have the academic indicator, we have the graduation rate.
Okay, I just wanted to make sure it wasn't just on test scores.
No, it's not just on test scores.
Thank you.
All right.
Ready for public comment.
Will the following speakers please line up?
Katarina Gregana, Andrea Ball, Samantha Tran, Rigel Massaro, Martha Alvarez.
Caterina Gregana on behalf of CABE and Californians Together.
As board member Ortiz-Licon mentioned, we are opposed to the one-time submission of the Title III addenda completed by districts with their 2018-19 LCAPs.
We believe that the Title III addenda should be submitted by districts every three years with their LCAPs and updated yearly with the annual yearly reviews of the LCAPs.
Language from the SSA plan describing the process minoring Title III programs and services does not state that this is a one-time occurrence, and we believe that this revision is needed.
Thank you.
Thank you, Andrea Ball, on behalf of the California School Boards Association.
We want to thank the department, the board staff, and you board members for your stamina and continued attention to this.
Really, anyway, we support submitting, making the recommended revisions, submitting it.
We look forward to continuing to work with you on the implementation and the outreach and
particularly what is the system of support and the support for the Title I schools identified going to look like.
CSBA looks forward to joining you in that effort.
Thank you.
Morning, Rigel Massara with Public Advocates.
We also urge approval and submission of the state ESSA plan.
We do ask that the board and the department have robust stakeholder engagement around the development of the local federal plans.
The LCFF Equity Coalition certainly looks forward to working with staff and members on that process.
Thank you.
Good morning, Marta Alvarez on behalf of AXA, the Association of California School Administrators.
We also are in support of the revisions that are being proposed today and urge the state board to adopt the revised plan.
We also would like to comment specifically to member Burr's comments.
regarding the implementation of the plan.
Our members, administrators who are the ones responsible for doing any improvement plans, any of the reporting and communication to the public, they are interested in better understanding how does this federal requirements fit and align with California's accountability system.
To that end, we would like to welcome any opportunity to collaborate to do a webinar or some communication to the field and the public
In the fall, once we have more information about the alignment and integration between the federal and state accountability system.
As we know, this plan has been a long time coming.
And so now once we have it approved, it would be really important to talk about the implementation challenges or any questions that the field might have.
Thank you.
Good morning, LeAngela Reed on behalf of the Small School Districts Association.
Excuse me.
I want to take a moment to thank State Board and Department staff for their diligence and patience in moving this forward.
I don't know that we would have gotten here if you hadn't had the key folks involved that have been doing this great work.
I'm glad it wasn't me.
I also want to say we support the action being taken today relative to the plan.
And I want to echo the comments from my colleague from AXA relative to sharing information with the field and being a partner with you to get that information out there.
We would be happy also to host webinars.
And I think it would be very helpful to have
Something that could be shared that explains what is required under the plan and then what other requirements there are that are not part of the plan so folks kind of see the universe.
And I also think it's important, you know, the department has a bill, ACSA has a bill relative to some of the plans that are required that we keep in mind with the CPSA, with the LCAP and the addition of the federal addendum.
and the fiscal transparency document and some of these other things, sort of the burden and the balance with capacity.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Samantha Tran with Children Now and we support the staff's recommendation to approve the plan and move it forward and look forward to working with you and the CDE team to work on the implementation pieces.
Thank you so much.
Any further discussion or need a motion on this?
Go ahead.
Well, first of all, thank the staff.
Thank the great conversation we had here and our stakeholders for their input as well.
Very frustrating process.
I get it.
And as the liaison for ESSA, it is extremely frustrating that this had to come back again to us.
And I agree too that there is a myriad and a slew of implementation issues that we still need to work on and in providing information to stakeholders as well.
However, we cannot move forward in any of that unless we move forward to get this plan approved.
And from what I have seen in discussions with staff in looking at this proposal, it does not take California off track of where we are going.
It puts a few little speed bumps in the way, but it does not take us off track.
So I will move the staff recommendation.
Okay.
Moved and seconded.
Any further board discussion?
Not.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay.
Thank you.
And now we're, now we're on to, well, don't, we saw it last time.
Yeah.
So we're now on to item three, the request for the contract with ETS and UC Santa Cruz.
Good morning.
Michelle Center, Director.
Take down the PowerPoint.
Keep going.
Yeah.
OK.
Does that work for you?
Thank you.
This is an action item before you that asks the board to authorize the CDE to begin the process of negotiating an amendment to the Educational Testing Services CASP contract and to authorize the CDE to enter into negotiations with UC Santa Cruz to provide an educator reporting system for the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California, or ELPAC, as well as other CASP assessments.
When the governor signed this year's state budget on June 27th, over $54 million was allocated for the development of a computer-based assessment for LPAC, as well as the development of an alternate assessment for LPAC.
With me in the audience today, in case you have questions or comments, we have representatives from both ETS and UC Santa Cruz.
John Oswald is vice president at ETS over student and teacher assessments.
And then Tony Alpert, the executive director of the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium at UC Santa Cruz is also here.
We are excited for this opportunity to more fully develop our LPAC program consistent with our long-term vision for California statewide assessments.
Key to this vision is a comprehensive technology infrastructure, which is to say a unique network of software and programs that manage assessment production, registration, delivery, data storage and reporting, and educator resources.
The goal of the infrastructure is to contain a series of integrated modules that appear to users as a single integrated system.
Once logged in, users should be able to navigate the various components of our system securely and seamlessly.
I know Member Sunk likes that part.
In 2016, the Smarter Balanced Technology Hosting Solution project was completed.
This implemented a technology infrastructure for the Smarter Balanced assessments in California.
In response to that project, the California legislature then revised education code to require that all California computer-based assessments utilize that same infrastructure when feasible.
California has since expanded the use of that infrastructure to support the implementation of other state tests, such as our California alternate assessments, as well as our tests for science.
The expansion of that infrastructure has been successful, with over 16 million assessments administered on that infrastructure just last school year.
It is important to also note that the department has been investigating the transition of the LPAC to a computer-based test for some time.
This is a transition that the majority of states have already taken for their English language proficiency assessments.
In June 2016, the CDE directed our LPAC contractor, ETS, to conduct a study on the feasibility of transitioning the LPAC from a paper-pencil test to a computer-based assessment.
The final report was presented to the State Board in June 2017 and is posted on our CDE website.
In the first part of 2018, the CDE engaged in conversations and gathered feedback regarding the LPAC transition to a computer-based test.
We gathered input from the LPAC Technical Advisory Group, the CISC Regional Assessment Network, the Bilingual Coordinators Network, our Statewide Assessment Group, which contains representatives from many educational associations, as well as the Advisory Commission on Special Education.
These groups expressed support for the potential transition of the LPAC from paper-pencil to a computer-based assessment as a step in the right direction for that assessment.
The CDE looks forward to continued collaboration with those stakeholder groups to inform the transition to a computer-based LPAC.
Additionally, the CDE looks forward to negotiating a thoughtful transition.
The computer-based assessment for LPAC should use differing approaches to ensure student access and success.
The department also looks forward to negotiating a contract to expand our educator reporting system.
We currently use the UC Santa Cruz educator reporting system for our Smarter Balanced interim assessments and we've received great feedback from our educators here in California.
The expansion would include both LPAC onto that system as well as other CASP assessments that are not yet utilizing that educator reporting system.
This expansion fits with our vision of an infrastructure for our educators that is seamless and supports the local use of assessment results.
In support of the vision, the CDE recommends the following actions that support this incorporation.
One, direct the CDE in consultation with staff from the State Board as well as Department of Finance to negotiate an amendment to the current ETS CAS contract to include work related to administering the LPAC.
Amend the contract end date from December 31, 2020 to December 31, 2022.
Ensure the following activities are included in the amended scope of work.
Transitioning the initial and summative LPAC from a paper-pencil test to a computer-based assessment with students and test examiner interfaces where appropriate.
Ongoing administrations of the paper and pencil LPAC until the computer-based LPAC is complete.
Activities associated with developing the alternate LPAC, which is a computer-based assessment for students who cannot participate in the current LPAC.
Ongoing administration of components of the CASP system through the 21-22 school year.
and direct the CDE to present that draft contract to you at your November 2018 board meeting.
I'm sure I will look very tired at that meeting.
For the interagency agreement, the UC Santa Cruz agreement, the CDE recommends the following.
That you authorize the CDE to enter into negotiations with UC Santa Cruz to provide an educator reporting system for the LPAC and other assessments as appropriate.
Direct the CDE to present a draft interagency agreement to you at that same November board meeting.
The final negotiated budgets for ETS and UC Santa Cruz collectively will not exceed $279,862,456 and is subject to appropriation by the legislature.
So I am happy to answer questions or also happy to bring up representatives from either of those organizations to answer questions.
Questions from anybody?
Okay, let's have the public comment.
We have one speaker.
Doug McRae, would you please come to the podium?
Still morning.
I'm Doug McRae, a retired testing specialist from Monterey.
I'd support the merging of the two contracts, but I would not support a recommended two-year sole source extension for the merged contract.
The current expiration for CASP is after the 2020 test administration year.
An open bid process for a merged contract for initiation at the beginning of the 2021 school year would generate fresh perspectives and varied vendor experiences and expertise, as well as likely cost reductions in the tens of millions of dollars.
Additional detail on how a merged contract
would operate over the next two years, as well as elements to be included in an open competition in early 2020, are included in materials submitted to your electronic folder last week.
So the only thing I'm talking about is the extension of the contract in 2020 up to 2022 on a sole source basis.
Thank you.
That ends the public comment.
I have a question for Michelle and maybe you can't answer it all, but there is a bill moving through the legislature, Assembly Bill 1951, which would allow school districts to substitute ACT or SAT or other approved exams for the Smarter Balanced assessment.
And I notice that we're merging
LPAC into a smarter balanced and all one system, does that have any effect?
I mean, I don't think SAT or ACT were ever designed to do this business.
Is there anything that you could say about that might cause problems?
Since it's an integrated system that then culminates with ACT or SAT.
So just to clarify what we mean by integrated system, the LPAC program and the CASP program are still separate programs in EdCode.
They're still separate programs in terms of our California Code of Regulations.
So these two programs still exist.
The integration is within a contract, which allows us to leverage the work that is already being done in our CASP program to more fully support our LPAC program.
So, for example, right now we have difficulties in trying to combine trainings to our educators because of how the money is associated and the fact that it's over two contracts.
Right now we could have, in the future, training where we're talking about both LPAC and CASP at the same time.
So we're talking about leveraging things.
We're not talking about combining assessments in any way.
The assessments still are separate.
So I don't believe that the combination within a single contract of LPAC and CASP relates to the 1951 bill.
It does relate or does not?
Does not.
Okay.
Other questions from the board?
Board member Burr?
So just to clarify, Michelle, it sounds like you're also trying to use a common platform, especially now that we're moving the paper and pencil test for LPAC onto a digital platform, right?
So do you want to, could you just say a little more about the proposed extension on the contract?
What you see the benefits are of extending the current contract?
Sure, and just to...
clarify the funding amount includes funding for LPAC all the way back to 18-19, which we currently have a contract with ETS for that time period.
We would end that contract so that we could enter into this more combined integrated contract.
So in case that wasn't clear in the budgeted amount, I wanted to clarify that, Member Burr.
So the question about integration
Question about extending existing contract versus going out with a new So the rationale for extending the contract the rationale for extending the contract is a concern about this major transition that we are Implementing going from a paper-based assessment to a computer-based assessment is a major transition and
There is concern about a change in contractor while we're in the middle of such a major transition.
So that is the reasoning why we have also recommended a two-year extension is so that we can get through that transition period.
I'm prepared to make a motion if there aren't other questions.
Okay, go ahead.
So I would move the department's recommendation.
Michelle read it to you, but it's quite a long one.
It deals with both the transition to the electronic form for LPAC as well as the Santa Cruz contract and the two-year extension.
And I'll just say in making the motion that I am very pleased with the progress we've made in our testing system.
I think we have wonderful partners with ETS and with Smarter Balanced.
So, I would move this recommendation without hesitation.
Okay, second.
Any further discussion?
Not all those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, that's approved.
Thank you.
All right, the board will recess.
We have lunch and
Okay, so the board will recess till 1215 and then we'll get our lunch and come back.
The State Board will reconvene and we're now ready for item 4.
Michelle Center, Director of the Assessment Development and Administration Division.
Item 4 is asking for your approval on amendments to the California Code of Regulations related to our LPAC assessment.
Specifically, the item asks the board to approve the finding of emergency, approve the proposed amended emergency regulations, direct the CDE to circulate the required notice of proposed emergency action, and submit the emergency regulations to the Office of Administrative Law for approval.
and authorize the CDE to take any necessary action to respond to any direction or concern expressed by the Office of Administrative Law during its review of these documents.
I'd like to highlight several changes to the regulations.
The first changes will align the LPAC with the Every Student Succeed Act or ESSA.
The CDE clarified that ESSA allows only students with the most significant cognitive disabilities to be eligible for an alternate assessment.
Therefore, the CDE is ensuring that only students with IEPs are eligible for the alternate assessment in these proposed regulations.
Another proposed change to the regulation consistent with federal flexibility will allow an IEP or Section 504 team to exempt a student from a domain.
in which no accommodation to that domain is accessible to the student.
So an example of that would be an English learner with a visual impairment who is not yet familiar with Braille.
They would be unable to access the reading domain.
Therefore, they could have an exemption for the reading domain.
If the IEP team made that determination to exempt them from the reading domain, they would still receive a calculated overall score based on the other three domains.
The student would also receive a written language score based on performance in the writing domain as well as an estimated reading domain score.
If the student continues as an English learner, they may be assessed in their reading domain using Braille at a later time if the IEP team determines that it is appropriate to assess them in reading at that time.
Next, there are proposed revisions and additions to accessibility resources, including our universal tools, designated supports, and accommodations.
examples of these changes.
One would be allowing the use of American Sign Language as a mode of communication for our listening and speaking domains.
This is already allowed for our writing prompts now.
Allowing highlighting and marking in the textbooks and repeating and pausing audio for our listening domain.
Finally, the CDE is proposing to eliminate the apportionment deadlines for test administration reports by our local educational agencies.
This will eliminate the waiver process for apportionment, which we hope to be a benefit to all of us, LEAs, the CDE, as well as the State Board.
A complete list of bulleted changes can be found in the board item as well as the justification for the emergency process can be found in the finding of emergency.
You will note based on the changes that I have just documented, these regulations do not pertain to a computer-based assessment.
Just want to clarify that.
These are for our current paper pencil administrations of our LPAC.
That is all I have.
I am open for questions.
Board Member Ortiz.
Thank you.
I have a question about accepting the students from certain domains and how do we then calculate?
So let's say that there are only administer the assessment in three out of the four domains.
So how do we weight that?
How does a teacher interpret that data?
Can you give us an example or walk us through that?
Of course, my psychometricians have left the building.
So we use all of the information that we have about the student, as well as information that we have about all students, so that we know, typically, a student who has this type of scoring would normally, typically, receive this type of scoring reading.
For example, if we use my reading example, then we would use that estimated reading score in the calculation.
It would have the same type of weighting in that score as if it was an administered reading test.
That being said, of course, I think you are correct.
We should ensure in any guidance document that we put out that they should take that into consideration when they are making decisions about students and reclassification.
So happy to make sure that we address that in our documents.
And just to clarify, we also have the permanent regulations that are before us, but those went to consent.
However, any changes we do to the emergency regulations will also be reflected on the permanent regulations.
So I'm not sure if you make changes in these, if we could, we may have to pull it off consent.
I would, I'm looking to Judy.
I don't know that we would.
If there are no changes, then the fact that the next one is on consent would be no problem.
Yeah, I don't anticipate any, but there goes David Saab.
So what he just said was that the two items are consistent.
So if you approve the emergency regs before you, they are identical to the permanent reg package in the item that is on consent.
They both go out.
comment period.
Any other board comments?
Board member Valdez.
No, I appreciate this whole process and there's such a need for what this is going to do and so I thank you for the work that you're doing.
Okay, any public comment?
Okay, do I have a motion?
Go ahead.
motion to move the department's recommendation.
And I'll second.
Hearing no further discussion, raise our hands.
That is approved.
OK.
And now we're on to the waivers.
And I understand two of the waivers have been pulled.
And so we will both waiver.
Eileen has to recuse.
Eileen what?
She has to recuse herself.
Oh, okay.
Board member Strauss has recused herself.
So we have the consent calendar.
And so we have on consent, waiver one, waiver two, and waiver four through 22.
And so
we can have a motion for Waivers 1 to Waiver 4 through W22 and we will hear Waiver 3.
Any public comment?
Okay.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
And Waiver 3, I think Eileen Strauss can return.
So we're going to hear that one and the department will present on Waiver 3.
Lisa?
Good afternoon.
Lisa Constancia from the Charter Schools Division.
I'm here to present Waiver Number 3.
It is a request from Contra Costa County Office of Education on behalf of the Golden Gate Charter School.
And they are requesting to waive a portion of the California Code of Regulations Title 5, Section 11963.6 in order to allow the charter school to request a non-classroom based funding determination for the respective funding time period.
Golden Gate submitted a determination request after the December 1 deadline.
So because they missed the deadline, they do have to submit a waiver to allow them to submit the actual funding determination.
So the waiver has to be approved by the board before they can submit a funding determination.
So this waiver is to allow Golden Gate, whose first year of operation was 17-18, to submit a retroactive funding request that would cover the period from July 1, 2017 through June 2019.
If the waiver is approved by the board, then the school may submit a retroactive funding determination for consideration by the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools and then by the State Board of Education.
CDE staff is recommending approval and I'm here if you have any questions.
Any board discussion on this item?
Board member Rucker.
You know, I recognize that the approval of the waiver of the timeline to apply for the funding determination is purely a ceremonious thing to be done.
But my concern remains that we continue to have these requests from charters that do understand and do know that these deadlines are in place in the same way that we have school districts that make these requests for adjustments on
Submitting chart submitting waivers concerning their testing
apportionments.
You know, I just think that at a certain point in time, there should be some accountability in the management of this process and in the work that goes on because we continue to see these requests every single year.
And in some cases, we continue.
While this is not a repeat offender, my concern is we also continue to see these requests coming.
And there doesn't seem to be any determination or any work done to try to make sure there's some improvements so that we don't continue to see these.
Can you tell me if there's any conversation with this LEA or with any of the LEAs that keep making these requests about what this means and about what their responsibilities or obligations are to do this in a timely way?
What we do in our normal process is we do actually take a look at each year those that are coming up that will need to come up to back to the board for a funding determination.
So on a yearly basis, we do take a look at those.
We start emailing them to let them know when the deadlines are.
The December 1st deadline is for new schools.
There's a February deadline for those that have been in operation more than a year.
So we do send out email reminders.
As we start getting closer, we continue to check our lists to see who we still haven't received.
Hi, Judy.
Okay, who we still haven't received a funding determination from.
So we do make an effort to try and contact them and let them know when the deadlines are and those that we still haven't received a funding determination from.
But that is kind of the best effort that we do.
But we do have communication with them to remind them of the deadlines.
So this is Judy Sias, Chief Counsel with the State Board.
I would say that the number of waivers has gone down every year.
So one thing we have looked at is this is just one waiver this time.
So I would say, you know, CDE has made a real effort to communicate more proactively, like you asked for, like Lisa said, with these charter schools.
So this is a new charter school that just started last year.
So they, you know, so I would say that, you know, there have been a lot of efforts and it is improving.
Thank you.
Board Member Valdez, did you have
Just a quick question.
It might have been in there.
I don't think I saw it, but why did they miss the deadline?
Let me check that.
They're in the waiver.
They've stated they weren't aware of the December 1st deadline and since they are a new school We do hear that with the new schools that sometimes they're not aware of when they when they do need to submit the funding determination Because they do get advanced funding Through through our fiscal services.
They do get advanced funding and then in October
You know, then we start checking those in October, then they submit their attendance reporting to us.
And as you know, how that goes through.
So they're receiving the funding.
In some cases, as new schools, they don't realize that they've missed a deadline to submit a funding determination to us so they can continue to get their funding.
So Apropos of the comment you made in response to my question, they received an email from you advising you that this deadline was coming up.
And they're saying, and that's the reason why I asked the question, they're saying in their waiver application they didn't know, and this is despite the fact that you sent them an email saying, please be advised.
So what is it they didn't know?
That they need to read the email or that you meant business?
I'm not sure.
They just do state that they were not aware of the deadline and their fiscal office calendars didn't update the indicator and they now have it updated as a high priority for them so that they have made changes in sounds like in so that they won't this won't happen again.
OK.
All right.
Any public comment on this.
Ready for a motion.
Oh that's public comment.
Sorry.
Hi, Angela DeRamos representing California Teachers Association.
Because there are no mitigating circumstances for missing the filing deadline, CTA recommends denial of this waiver.
If I were late on my taxes, I would have to pay a penalty.
And in this case, when things are not late or things are not put in order when they're supposed to be put, I just worry that the kids eventually will lose because what else is not going to be put in place?
Thank you.
Okay, that's the end of the public testimony.
Ready for a motion on this.
I move approval.
Okay, moved and seconded.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, now we're on to the proposed consent calendar.
These are items 5 through 15, 5 through 15.
All those items are on the consent calendar.
Do we have any public testimony on the consent calendar?
No.
I move approval of the consent calendar.
All right.
No further discussion.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, that's approved.
So now we're on to the public hearing.
And so let me say that there are four different charters, petitions that we are considering.
The commissioner is not here yet.
They were told to be here at 830.
We're trying to track them down.
If we maybe could go to SB priorities real quick and then as soon as they're here.
Okay.
Oh, she's coming right now.
Is she on her way?
She's here before the break.
Oh, she was here last night.
So they might just have took the kids to lunch in the park, I think.
All right, we'll take SBE priorities.
Okay.
All right, so let's move on to item 23, SBE priorities.
And so on this, I need approval of the minutes and recommendation on that.
Have a motion, please, and approve the minutes.
Move approval of the minutes.
Second.
Okay, move and second.
And all those in favor, raise your hands on the minutes.
Okay, now what we're doing with SBE priorities is to
We're going to go through alphabetically.
We used to do it by the liaison and all of that sort of thing, but now we're going to go through alphabetically.
So we'll start with Member Burr, your activities.
Thank you, President Kirst.
My main work has been around the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence, which I chair.
I'm delighted to say that we selected a new executive director.
I think I let all of you know that our
esteemed director, Carl Cohen, announced his retirement effective in August.
The person we selected is Tom Armolino.
Tom is the former county superintendent of Shasta County.
He's also a former school district superintendent.
And most recently, he was the statewide president of AXA and ran the National Association of School Superintendents.
So he has a very wide and ranging background.
I'd like to thank Chief Deputy Price for assisting us with the recruitment.
And I don't know if you'd like to say anything about Tom, but Tom has already started.
He started effective July 1.
I know he has had the opportunity to meet with President Kirst and with Vice President Strauss and is really now making a tour of the state to talk to all of the interested groups about the collaborative and its work.
And we will be meeting on August 23rd
to do a planning session.
It will be a workshop, probably an all-day workshop to start on a long-range strategic plan.
Because as you all know, now the work is in front of us.
We've identified the LEAs.
We've had the, we've actually had the opportunity in the past really to be trying some things out to get them in place going forward.
But now we know who the LEAs are.
We'll need our assistance and the subject areas in which we really need to focus So that's going to be Tom's work in front of them.
So that's what I've been up to I don't know Glenn if you want to say anything Okay, that was important move student board member gray I
Hey, I think I'm going to just talk a little bit about my experience this year.
I can't believe it's been a year already.
Time flies really fast.
This has definitely been one of the best experiences that I've ever had.
And I've learned so much, not just about educational policy, but about decision making and looking at issues through multiple lenses, which is something I think is really going to help me and serve me well later on in life.
If I could sum up this year in one word, it'd definitely be humbling.
Just knowing all the students that, you know, I represent and just the decisions that I'm making here and knowing how many people they impact is really just, it's kind of mind-boggling and hard to wrap my mind around.
And just knowing how important each and every student is how much potential each and every student has and Like if this year and some of the events happen this year showed shows us anything it's that students really have a voice and despite the fact that we're young like
the movements that happened this year just show that the potential that students have to create change.
So I look forward to Hema very much next year.
I've talked to her a lot.
I know she's going to do an amazing job.
I'm really excited for her.
And I just like to thank everyone for this year.
So yeah, thank you.
And we have a cake in celebration of your ascension.
And we'll, next break, we'll go out there.
And so you can look forward to that.
OK.
So I'm next.
And I've been attending meetings that the, to bring the levels of education together, we have, there's been formed a new education leaders
group, and it's the chief executives of all the higher education systems and the K-12 system.
And so, not just the chief executives, but the board chairs, which is really unique in California, as far as I know, for all the board chairs to be there with the executives.
to talk about more of our relationships across the systems.
And of course, the transition from K-12 education to post-secondary education is a key part of that.
Tom Torlakson attends, as does Glenn Price and myself, for the K-12 area.
And these have been interesting conversations.
There's a work plan going on to come up with ways we can better collaborate.
We're still in this process and I have nothing to report in a concrete way at this point.
I also attended on Monday a meeting on the master plan for higher education.
which was called, there was an earlier one that a lot of public officials came to, and I attended that, and that was last year, and then this one.
And I think it's been very interesting, and that's another area where, you know, the master plan, as we all know, was written in 1960.
And it was voted on by a legislature that had LA County with one vote and Siskiyou County with one vote.
So it was quite a different political.
And as you may know, there's been a few changes in the economy since 1960.
All attempts to overhaul the master plan in any significant way, there were five of them, have failed.
And so I think there was a lot of view, should we even start with the master plan as a way to think about higher education in the 21st century?
And it's essentially a treaty between systems, the three systems.
And they have gone into their own postholes.
And we're in another posthole.
Clark Kerr was asked, I was at a hearing before he died, why K-12 wasn't in the master plan.
And the view was, in 1960, that K-12 is just fine.
The problems are in higher education.
And I sort of did a double take on that.
But no need to talk about them.
So that has grave limitations in that way.
So there's to be a report to the legislature.
There is a legislative committee in the assembly to look at the master plan as well.
But a lot of discussion was, you know, if you put yourself that the master plan is the thing and then we're going to amend that, is that a place to really start your thinking about this?
Or do you just say, OK, it's there.
We'll preserve the treaty between systems.
We could put the master plan in a mausoleum and have, you know,
people worship before it and incense and so on and then move on.
And that would, you know, be another way of approaching it.
So that seems to be at least one of the discussions.
So these are preliminary, but at least I think we'll be moving on, I think, soon with some recommendations.
So Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you.
I'll start with the health framework.
And so the Health Subject Matter Committee of the Instructional Quality Commission will be meeting August 13th here at CDE to review over 300 comments received so far on the health education framework.
It's a very progressive framework.
I'm very proud of it.
I know that
A lot of educators and other experts have come together to give us their best effort in this initial framework.
Any edits and recommendations made from the public comment will be made to the full IQC in September 2018.
After 60 days of public review, we should expect to have the framework before us in May of 2019.
The other liaison report I have is with a committee that's becoming very near and dear to my heart, which is the Ethnic Studies Model Curriculum.
And I think that, well, we've seen darker days, especially here in California, the 1990s.
I think that we're training wheels for what we're experiencing now.
But I'm so proud that we have something where our students of color could turn and point to a point in history where their people made a significant contribution and that our histories have not always been told, but we have certainly contributed and I'm very happy that we are starting the process.
to develop this ethnic studies model curriculum.
And today during the consent items, we approve the timeline of significant events.
The advisory committee for the model curriculum will begin meeting in February of 2019.
And all of those that are interested in applying, there will be an application posted from August to October.
So please do keep an eye out for that.
For EL, I attended the EL roadmap launch at the Orange County Office of Education.
Special thanks to Superintendent Al Mijares, who gave us very animated welcome remarks.
It was a full house of educators, including my husband, who I took so that he could learn a little bit more about the work that we're doing.
I provided welcome remarks on behalf of the State Board.
We reflected on the swing that California has experienced from the dark days of Prop 227 to the passage of Prop 58 and the unanimous approval of the EO roadmap by this body.
Page 6 activities.
I want to thank Board Member Nikki Sandoval for being our speaker representing the State Board of Education at the Long Beach Unified Dual Immersion Day.
at Patrick Henry Elementary, where my students attend, my kids attend, as well as her nephew Emiliano.
Along with board member Sandoval, Senator Lara also spoke, as well as LBUSD leadership, including President Megan Kerr, as well as the district leadership.
So thank you, Nikki, for joining us.
Okay.
Board member Rucker.
I attended the IQC meeting in May and the next IQC meeting is scheduled to coming up at the end of this month.
We're continuing the work that's being done on developing not only the standards, but guidances in subject matters, including the world languages, which is the next item coming up.
We're very excited to see the work that's being done in that area.
Board member Lee Cohn already spoke about the health framework going out for public comment that was approved.
That I at that particular IQC meeting at the end of this year.
We'll see several IQC members who will be termed out and going off One of the thing that's been most interesting in watching the IQC over the time that I have shared the responsibility with board member Strauss is not only the
The work that they come there to do as policy makers, but their growth as education leaders They start on that position that committee and on that Policy group in one particular position and they have grown and have changed in their work and grown in their own career And it's just nice to see as those people leave the IQC at the end of this year that that will continue I also I have a gift for you all and I'll just pass this down on June 22nd
At the invitation of department staff, I participated again in the 2018 Early Math Symposium.
It was held at the Fresno Pacific University.
I'm giving you a copy of the folder, the packet that was handed out to participants.
And the reason I wanted to share this with you, Early Math covers the students that we don't necessarily include for guidance and discussion in our frameworks.
but it focuses not only on mathematics instruction, but good first instruction for students in the early grades beginning with pre-K and going all the way up to kindergarten, first and as well as second grade.
And as you can see from this, this is a full day of activities and workshops for the teachers who registered and came.
The work included from several keynote speakers who talked about not only what good math instruction looks like, but what it means to develop mathematical literacy in young students, what their conversations and ideas about mathematics are.
The program includes for you a copy of information about the breakout sessions.
And I'm really glad the program also gives you some background about each of the presenters, the people who did these breakout sessions and for
For Superintendent Torlakson, I had spoken to him with great enthusiasm about John Collins.
John Collins is not somebody everyone knows about, but he is very well known in many circles.
John Collins is important for the reason that a lot of my fifth grade boys who may be listening today, and I know some of them do because one of them is a police officer in the Elk Grove Police Department.
That's a whole other story.
But these boys, I never had a class where I didn't have a young man who made a paper airplane and launched it in class.
John Collins is famous because he created and flew the paper airplane that broke the Guinness World Record for continuous flight.
And that world record was broken here at McClellan Air Force Base.
in a hangar at McClellan Air Force Base.
So John was one of the featured speakers.
And not only did he give a great presentation, his slideshow is there, but he also gave his book out.
It's an excellent example of the application of STEM and art.
So his was a true STEAM program, a true STEAM presentation.
It was very engaging for a full room of teachers learning how to make paper airplanes, but also understanding the math and the science
behind why paper airplanes are a great application to use in the classroom.
So it was a wonderful day of learning and workshops and interaction and engagement.
I'm really happy to bring this handout to you to share with you.
Okay, I want to mention that in the budget there was 11 million dollars
for an early math initiative, preschool through grade eight, grade three, sorry.
And this was carved out of some of our federal funds and is really, I think we'll hear more about it from CDE and the state board staff.
But I think this is an interesting initiative and was part of the budget.
Okay, Board Member Sandoval.
Okay, well, I will start with visual and performing arts.
The 32nd session of the California State Summer School for the Arts is underway.
And we have more than 500 students studying animation, creative writing, dance, film, music, theater and visual arts.
And another important thing to note is that 23 students at least will be receiving college scholarships.
So they'll continue their study.
And that the California State Summer School for the Arts has partnered with at least a dozen universities throughout the United States for multiple year tuition discounts for CSSSA graduates.
So that's really exciting.
Also with Visual and Performing Arts,
The Instructional Quality Commission will be meeting later this month to review the updated California art standards and ready them for the 60-day public comment review period.
And members of the public can review the draft standards on the CDE website starting next month.
And we can look at taking action on the revised standards in January of 2019.
And let's see, I wanted to mention
Patrick Henry Elementary, I had the honor of going to their dual immersion day.
And it was a really powerful moment for me because I grew up speaking English and Spanish.
And as an adult, started learning our indigenous language, Samoan.
So to be able to address students who are speaking two languages in the three languages that I am blessed to know,
knowing that my grandfather in the 40s went to the Sherman Institute in Riverside and was forbidden to speak any of his indigenous language, that I could stand here in 2018 in Southern California and be able to address at a public school in more than one language and to think that that is our future.
And I believe that I see us heading in that direction.
So it was just a wonderful, powerful moment.
So I'm so grateful for that invitation.
So thank you.
Special Education, the Advisory Commission on Special Education met July 20th and, no, June, I had the date wrong, last month, the 20th and the 21st.
And I want to congratulate Fullerton Joint Union High School District, recipients of this year's Grazer Outstanding Achievement in Learning Goal Award.
This district serves students in a 50 square mile radius.
And their adult transition program has resulted in very dramatic increases in employment for students with disabilities.
So starting with 31% employment rates in 2014 to 96% employed in 2017.
So this initiative has really done exemplary work in supporting students with disabilities to prepare them for college and career and independent living.
So that was a really joyful presentation to witness.
And I also want to acknowledge the work that special education is doing with the data boot camps.
So, the Special Education Division is looking at data dashboard with those entities that have been identified for assistance, specifically those identified due to outcomes for students with disabilities, and really helping them understand how to use the data to improve teaching and learning for our students.
And then finally, at the Advisory Commission for Special Education meeting, we heard from the California Teacher Credentialing, or CTC, California Commission for Teacher Credentialing.
All these acronyms, I'm getting them all twisted today.
And we learned about the revisions to the program standards and teaching performance expectations for exceptional students.
So there's mild to moderate and then extensive, moderate and severe support needs credentials.
And while this is very important work that is being done right now, I do want to convey that I heard commissioners voicing continued concern about how we're supporting and preparing our teachers in general education settings.
to meet the needs of our students with disabilities, especially as we work towards inclusion.
We need to be preparing all teachers for the classroom.
So then we heard from the Family Empowerment Center representatives and they called for more professional learning for classified staff members who work directly with our students with disabilities on campuses.
These are classroom aides, yard duty personnel,
They're working with our students daily and we need to support them with improved professional learning opportunities.
Thank you.
Okay, good.
Board Member Sun.
Thank you.
Just a quick report on the California Workforce Pathways, a joint advisory committee we met back in May.
And we now have a set of draft principles which we are ready to start circulating for folks to provide some additional input.
So we will have a regional meeting in August, August 22nd, for getting some input on the work that we've been doing and then also providing us a little bit more direction on what our next steps will be.
And I am looking forward to presenting in front of this board, along with my co-chair Pamela Haynes,
to talk a little bit about our work and what we found in our last year and a half, well, about a year, year and a half now of looking at the CTA pathways and ways that we can better communicate with the community colleges and to work together as we develop our students for the workforce in the 21st century.
Okay, there also was money in the budget, maybe Glenn, you can, or Karen, for a new CTE.
It could be implementing some of the older projects we did under the Career Pathways Trust, but a new CTE initiative in collaboration with the community colleges.
And I think there was how much, Karen?
$300 million total, including some for the existing K-12 systems as well.
So the legislature's continued the commitment to career and education in a really positive way with $150 million investment being made in strong workforce program to be implemented by the community college system.
And K-12 coming.
It all focuses on K-12.
And then $150 million to be administered by the department.
but for us to collaborate closely together, which I think is probably the best part of it.
Right.
Yeah, we don't talk about the budget, but we should.
The budget also had two other aspects of it.
We're talking about the budget control language, everybody.
One was a new plan to have a document for the LCAP that reconciles the LCAP to the regular school budget.
Right now, in some ways, they proceed separately and people can't see how do the things in the LCAP relate to the
school budget?
And moreover, how did the things that were in the LCAP, were they actually expended in the school budget?
Because sometimes they can't hire people.
So there was extensive language on this new developed part of, I guess you'd call it an instrument or something of that sort.
Do you want to comment on that?
You pretty much said it, Dr. Kirsten, and I think it remains to be, it's going to be a separate reporting piece, but I think the holy grail will be to, maybe misuse that word again, would be to look for integration with the LCAP.
Yeah, and so that and the ultimate objective.
Yeah, it also has a mentioned school site data in there as well.
It's really very extensive language and then there is also a budget allocation for improving parent engagement in the LCAP process.
And that's, you know, I think, badly needed.
And so that's also been funded.
There are extra funds for this in the budget.
Yeah, as most of you know, there's a budget and then there's a bunch of, quote, trailer bill language.
And it used to be that was technical cleanup in the old days.
Now there's whole new programs in there.
And you've got to look at that, too.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I neglected to say there's funding that's coming to the collaborative.
The community engagement money is coming to the collaborative.
It is.
Yes, to put together a process to select a county office or consortium of county offices in collaboration with the department and the board and others to put together community engagement.
effort to improve community engagement, to create models, because I think our LEAs are struggling with that.
There's also two other pieces of funding.
I don't know the amounts.
Glenn might know, or Dave.
But one is to select leads for special education, to actually select SELPA leads.
to help improve our success with students with disabilities.
And the other one is to select geographic leads, so counties that have content expertise.
So all of this relates to our system of support.
Again, now that we know who needs help, we're trying to create this system of folks who are available to provide that assistance.
for the ladder piece for the geographic lead agencies, which is a really welcome investment in our system of support.
Those will be county offices that will be supporting and building the capacity of other county offices to provide support to LAAs in the system.
And we're working hard with the State Board and with the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence to get those RFAs out very quickly so we can start to get that money invested.
So be looking for those.
Vice President Strauss.
Okay, so I have a report on a variety of issues that some overlap with and complement what some of my members, colleagues have shared.
In May 14th, I was in North San Diego County with AXA Palomar region, and I gave them an update, which I often do to AXA regions.
about what we're doing with the dashboard, what are our safety net measures.
And when I got done with sharing our system of support, I asked them to work in groups and give feedback.
And we had overwhelming support for the safety net model, just so you know, particularly because they have some small situations there.
And so that was positive.
And then we talked a lot about coherence with all the initiatives and all the measures and how you work together.
And so that seems to be a theme in practitioners' work as they translate
our work and accountability and improving standards and instruction, how do you lead that in a district where there's so many district priorities going on and how it impacts a teacher and a principal about how much you can actually do effectively.
So we've done some of the work at AXA Symposium and then the follow-up just listening to the practitioners and sort of what the next steps were, I thought I'd share that.
And then I was invited on the 16th of May to visit Garden Grove as a follow-up for the
California Collaborative on District Reform, and got to see just amazing work in dual immersion, amazing work, especially in the early grades, and an avid program in full implementation.
And then looking at how the district models professional development and capacity building in a large district with a very diverse
population.
So it's really, and it's a pretty focused district program with great growth.
And so that, with long-term consistent leadership at the district level, which I think is significant.
And then on May 21st, I was in Ventura County at their science leadership meeting on continued NGSS implementation.
And very exciting to hear Dr. Brian Reeser from Northwestern talk about supporting shifts in classroom practice.
with NGSS storylines and listening to coherence from students' perspective.
You're hearing a lot about improvement science in all of our work, and they talked about that model in science as well.
And just a compliment to Ventura County, who continues to do amazing, continued leadership work in the implementation of NGSS.
We have a standard steering committee, implementation committee, which is actually a communication group of CDE, state board, and the successor group, the county leads, talking about where are we in a standards implementation, what's going on, what the collaboration committees are doing.
We have a science collaboration and community of practice, and we have a math science community practice.
And talking about sort of where are we in all of our different rollouts.
And we aren't doing much with the LAELD anymore,
I think we still have a lot we need to do in literacy development.
And we're talking about where we are in history and the continued need for rollout.
So that coordination, which I think is good, we meet quarterly to talk about where all the projects are and what the different groups are doing.
There's another group that we also have a role and CDE also meets with.
it's called PACRS, you've heard me talk about them, Promoting Authentic College Career and Civic Readiness Assessment System.
So, besides paper and pencil, what do we do for assessment that's authentic?
And they've been working on, and Tom Adams gave some update on the history social science framework and where we are in history social science.
And lots of discussions about how we promote civic engagement among our students, which we know is really important.
Their plan as they move forward is to continue to build coherence around
civic engagement, equity and support so that students are college and career ready, but also talk about civic readiness, and then taking a look at what it means for system of support for adult learning.
So I think the nice thing about having CDE and State Board on some of these advisory commissions that work, or this is not an advisory commission, it's a committee that works together with funding, is that we're trying to be coherent about it and communicate.
So I think we'll hear more about that.
The Concurrence Commission, that's another commission that really only meets twice a year, and it's the subject matter projects that do a lot of teacher training in our state.
So they met June 13th.
Mostly the June meeting is to deal with continued funding, but Tom Adams did a report on ESSA and where we are and where we hope to be in ESSA.
And as a result, they are actually having a special meeting with all the leads of the subject matter projects to try to align their resources and their training with the reform efforts that we're involved with.
So we'll hear more about that, but I think
We need to all be connected on this conversation, and so Tom did a really nice job of updating them.
But they are gonna do, in fall of 2019, the UC and CSU is committed to doing a sustainability education summit at UCLA, spotlighting the importance of integrating sustainability and climate change as a critical part of K-12 and higher ed curriculum and coursework, and to show how we can promote that with state standards.
So I'll get more about it if they're just starting to plan.
I think Glenn may have some more information about that.
Yes, we let Board Member Holliday know about that.
Okay, I'll let him know because they are going to have a first call with the committee, so I'll be glad to do that.
And then CTC met, and just to support what Member Sandoval was saying, is that there's continued discussion about the need to prepare general education teachers to support special education.
So it's interesting for us to talk about the need in our advisory commission, for us to talk about the need in our standards to support differentiation of learners, and then to realize what it takes to prepare our teachers.
So there's an agreement that we need to support all teachers to be prepared to teach special ed.
There's not an agreement that we're fully there yet as far as the standards, as far as giving teachers literacy strategies.
And so there'll be continued conversation at the CTC meeting.
And we have state board liaisons that staff that go along.
And they did talk about the incentive in the budget items to address the teacher shortage.
Again, CTC is obviously really important because we are retiring more credentials than we're starting.
And there's incentives in the area of
special education, also STEM, and taking a look at issues that we could target to help increase our teaching force.
Also a need to increase not only in STEM, but in career tech ed.
So those are areas that we're hearing a priority in the work group.
that Ting Sung and I think Felicia and Patricia Rucker are involved in.
And I think we're beginning to see, we're seeing some cross, different committees talking about the need for teacher preparation, preparing our kids well.
And so you'll hear more about that, about needing to have transition to college and also support for students with exceptional needs.
And then my
I have two more things, is that on June 27th to 29th, Glenn Price and I attended, along with Estella Ben-Simon, who's a USC professor, and Lark Park from the governor's office, and Christia Osmena, Christian from the community colleges.
We attended the Education Commission of the States in Washington, D.C.
So I'll give you a quick outline of some really exciting things.
And if anybody wants any of the PowerPoints, it's really interesting.
There were some plenary sessions where more than 573 education leaders came from 43 states.
Where is education policy?
Where have we come and where are we going?
And what's the theory of the education workforce that's changing?
And how the population, if you think about all the boomers retiring, they call it the growing of the silver population.
And then the changing of the diversity of the growing population of the diversity of our, and the changing workforce.
And then there was one comment.
about the fact that the person who's going to live to be 150 years old has already been born.
Is that amazing?
Anyway, this is from some of the research groups that Glenn and I were sitting at the table together when we heard this statement.
It won't be probably us, but anyway.
But they talked about looking at employment pathways, looking at early childhood education, which you hear a lot in California.
And then all the demographics and how things are changing.
And then issues of equity and access.
If all means all, what's it gonna take?
Which we all talk about.
What's that mean?
What does it mean to strengthen school leadership?
Which our collaborative ration committees talk about.
Success is talking about that.
Every subject matter group talks about needing to train leaders as well as training teachers.
And then they said, so this is sort of interesting, the midterm elections in 2018, 36 states and D.C.
will hold governor races and there's a guaranteed 16 new governors just because the term limits were one of them.
Seven states will hold chief state school board elections.
Seven states and DC hold state board of education elections.
And 87 out of 99 legislative chambers are going to have general elections.
So there's a lot of changes going on in ed policy nationally.
I think we were just taken back by the data.
And then finally, next week, this is really exciting, on Monday, IQC members
and the facilitators will come together for reviewers training to review NGSS aligned materials, of which there are 37 different programs.
And starting Tuesday, all the panels will come together, and by the end of the week, they will have reviewed and recommended which programs are ready for approval.
It has to go through a process where it goes back to IQC, it'll have another hearing.
But in November, we're going to be able to approve
NGSS aligned materials for our state framework.
So by January, districts will be ready to adopt aligned materials and they've had some time to work on the framework.
So I think it's really exciting going forward and that's next week here in Sacramento.
And that ends my report, thank you.
Member Valdez.
So this morning, Superintendent Tarlekson talked about the Global California 2030 Initiative.
And so I had the opportunity in June to attend the World Language Standards Committee.
And I have to tell you, the group of people, it was their sixth day or the fifth of the sixth day together.
And what we are doing in terms of bringing teachers and leaders together to have conversations about world language standards coming forward, it's all part of this whole vision, if you will, is phenomenal.
And so their work now goes forward to IQC, and IQC will be developing the final framework, if you will, over time.
So we're very excited about the work that they did, so.
Okay, Board Member Williams.
This has been primarily computer science year for me, but I still have charters and NGSS.
On the computer science front, the first-ever California Computer Science Strategic Implementation Planning Advisory Panel,
CISP, something like that.
Yeah, it's a really long name that was in the statute.
They were, this is the panel that was appointed primarily by the governor with a couple appointments by, six appointments by the superintendent.
and a co-chair by the superintendent, a co-chair by President Kirst, and members of the Senate and the Assembly.
And so it was a pretty high-level panel.
They all had to have expertise in some fashion in computer science.
They weren't all computer scientists, but many were.
Either they taught computer science in K-12, or this panel in particular, every single slot was designated in the statute.
So as opposed to standards committees, for instance, they didn't have more than half teachers.
They had six teachers total and then a variety of other, how many higher ed, how many tech.
industry, that kind of thing.
So they have completed their meetings.
They did that last week.
They met six days total.
The law required them to develop recommendations that would broaden the pool of teachers that are qualified to teach computer science.
And under, there's three main charges in the statute.
Under each one, there are lots of suggested things that they should look at.
For instance, on the broadening the pool of teachers, they should be looking at creating
Well, I'll just read it to you right now.
They should be looking at creating a teacher certification pathway in computer science, expanding scholarship eligibility and loan forgiveness programs for computer science teachers in low-income and underserved school districts, things like that, teacher preparation, things like that.
In addition, they were asked to create
what was called Computer Science Principles, P-L-E-S, that were sort of the big overarching things that should be considered in expanding computer science in California.
And as you might imagine, there was pretty strong references to the importance of computer science for all students and equity and access issues.
And then in addition, well, that was actually one of the third things, which included ensuring all pupils have access to quality computer science.
So the way this is going to finish up is that this group has finalized and reached consensus.
I attended all six days.
Finalized and reached consensus on their recommendations.
Gave permission to the facilitator, CDE facilitator, Barbara Murchison, who did a really fine job, gave permission to her to work with the co-chairs to do any wordsmithing and fixing this and that, tweaking.
Then that will go to the IQC and the IQC will work with CDE.
I'm going to get this not quite right because it wasn't spelled out totally clearly in the statute, but the IQC and the CDE will then work together to put together a plan.
to execute recommendations.
So this panel is only making recommendations, they're not developing the plan for execution.
The CDE will be doing that.
It's going to go out, I think it's the full plan that will go out for public review, come back to the IQC.
and will come when that's done to the State Board in March of 2019 for consideration of adoption.
This coming September, the Board will have an opportunity to review the recommendations from this panel, but not the plan for execution, just the recommendations, and to provide input and discuss those recommendations.
which the CDE will then take with them to do their work and consider that in the plan.
So that's the Strategic Implementation Planning Commission.
On computer science standards, they had finished their work and it goes to, and it's been out for public comment.
Those go to the IQC this month at the IQC meeting on July 26th.
I will not be coming up to Sacramento for the IQC meeting, but I will be calling in during the estimated one hour that they will be talking about these computer science standards.
And then those will come to us in September for consideration of adoption as well.
A little fun thing that I'm going to do, not that the rest of this wasn't fun, but is that I was invited by
Code.org to go to their training professional development training that they do they call it a teacher con for computer science principals AP and also their middle grades curriculum, which is called Computer science discoveries and they have thousands of teachers from from around the country that that go to these two events that they hold in the summer I'm going in Phoenix
to Phoenix in two weeks.
And they have a particularly large number of teachers from California that have signed up for this PD.
They offer the curriculum and the PD, including the accommodations and the airfare, free of charge for them to get there.
They just have to sign up and commit to teaching computer science the next year.
And so they asked me to come.
I was interested.
I've been working on this for years.
I'd never seen a computer science principles course or seen how it's taught, so I was interested in learning, but they also asked me to be there to meet with the teachers, both to give the California teachers an update on California computer science policy,
and for the teachers to have an opportunity to tell me why they're taking this training, how they plan to use it in their schools, you know, what made them interested, what do they find most interesting about doing this work, why did they choose to do it, what are they having the most difficulty with, what do they wish the state board or CDE might do to support their efforts.
So, I'll be doing that later this month.
In addition, staying with the computer science theme, two years ago, I was approached by Dr. Henry Sanchez of the University of California, Boers, to see if I wanted to come up to Oakland to talk with him and his staff, Monica Lynn, about NGSS.
and about computer science and about Area D. And so, and whether or not computer science, they might want to consider allowing some computer science courses to be approved under Area D and what that would take to do it.
And since that time, they've undergone a pretty rigorous process to consider this with UC faculty, science faculty, computer science faculty, workforce that met for, I think, 18 months.
12 months, 18 months, they've made recommendations about how that might happen.
Those recommendations have gone back to BORS, they've gone to the Academic Senate, they've gone to the UC Assembly, I might be getting some of those names of those groups wrong, and they are now with the UC Office of the President to consider
how they might handle this approach and this question.
They do have a really strong interest.
The UC Boards, especially Dr. Henry Sanchez, who's a pathologist and a scientist, is strongly committed to next-generation science standards, and also articulates an understanding that in today's world, most scientists
have to also be or work with computer scientists to study big data, to do modeling, to do simulations, engineering design, that kind of thing.
So he has a really strong interest in this.
And I was invited last week.
One of the reasons I'm raising it is because I was invited last week by Dr. Sanchez and Monica to participate in an hour video call with the two of them just to
give me an update on where they are in this process, to raise ideas they were thinking about, to ask what, you know, what was going on with the State Board, some sort of informal inter-segmental cooperation and collaboration, he called it.
And it was really interesting and enjoyable for me.
I really appreciate it and feel honored to be able to communicate with them around this.
So that's the CS report.
Of course, I went to the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools last month, my 44th, not counting.
But it's, I started when, yeah, well, nobody had ever gone.
A board member had never gone to ACCS before me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did she go to ACCS?
Because I was told when I went that I was the first one to show up.
Okay, well, she went, she came when I was going, and then, and then when Bruce came on board, then he said, okay, if this is what we do, you know, I'm with you, I'm with you, I'll go.
So, did that last month, and so feel reasonably prepared for to, to the, those agenda items.
In addition, I snuck in just a little bit of NGSS time.
I'm going to surprise Dave Sapp by engaging in a couple of conversations with State Board staff Dave Sapp on the, what process they're using as you heard earlier today to
Redesign the dashboard and then we had a conversation about how NGSS was going to get included on that dashboard and when that might get included and and I and I was Assured I think you're going to be fine with this statement I was assured that the designers of the dashboard are making sure it's flexible enough in the design that it can accommodate Whatever next thing the board decides to put into it
That was at least one of the things I was hoping for, so I feel good about that.
The last thing I want to say is you were talking about early childhood math.
Well, our Carolyn Pfister was a major driver in pulling that meeting off and supporting it.
And it's one of the projects, she tells me, she loves the most in her state board role.
So I'm giving props and kudos to you for that because it looks like it turned out to be a really fabulous event and a great cause.
That's it for me.
OK.
Well that concludes our SBE priorities.
We have a lot going on that doesn't show up at the meetings.
I hope people understand that.
So now we're ready for item 16 through 19.
This is a
petitions to establish four Olive Grove charter schools and they will be heard as a single public hearing.
This is quite unusual.
First, we will hear a single staff presentation on the four petitions.
Then the petitioners will have a total of 20 minutes to present in favor of their four petitions in the public hearing.
The four districts and the County Office of Education will also have 20 minutes
to present their opposition to the petitions.
And following the presentation, members of the public will have a chance to comment on all FAR items at two minutes per person.
So we will start with Lisa to talk about the CDE's analysis and recommendation, and then we'll move directly into the public hearing.
Jason's cake is ready.
Those of you that want to go out and get some.
Okay, I'll go ahead and get started then.
As President Kirst mentioned, this is item 16 through 19 for Olive Grove Charter Schools, and I'll talk a little bit more as we get through the presentation why these are being combined.
So just a little bit of background, Olive Grove is a state board authorized charter school currently that is operating multiple resource centers.
So Olive Grove is seeking to actually restructure each resource center to be an individual charter school.
So instead of being Olive Grove charter schools with resource centers, they will be each a charter school to come into compliance with the Anderson decision.
Four of these resource centers, Buellton, Lompoc, Orcutt, Santa Maria, and Santa Barbara are all in Santa Barbara County and are before the State Board today as separate schools.
Each of the four Olive Grove Resource Centers first petitioned the school district in which they were geographically located and then subsequently to the Santa Barbara County.
So to give you a little timeline, again, each of the individual petitions were denied by the local school districts.
Santa Barbara Unified School District denied the Olive Grove Charter School on December 5th by a vote of five to zero.
Lompoc Unified School District denied the Olive Grove Charter School Lompoc on December 5th, 2017 by a vote of three to one with one abstention.
The Santa Maria Joint Union High School District denied the Olive Grove Charter School Orcutt Santa Maria on December 12, 2017 by a vote of 5 to 0.
And then the Santa Ynez Valley Union High School District denied the Olive Grove Charter School Buellton on December 12, 2017 by a vote of 5 to 0.
Subsequently, on March 1st, 2018, the Santa Barbara County Board of Education voted to deny all four petitions at the same meeting by a vote of five to zero.
The petitioner then subsequently submitted all four petitions on appeal to the state board on March 15th, 2018.
The CDE is recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing to approve the request to establish all four Olive Grove schools as individual charter schools under the oversight of the State Board for a five-year term of July 1, 2018 through June 30, 2023.
Our recommendation is based on a sound educational program, that the schools are demonstratively likely to successfully implement the programs, and that we have reasonable comprehensive description of most of the charter elements in the petitions.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on June 12, 2018.
The commission moved staff's recommendation to approve all four petitions to the State Board of Education, and the motions all passed by a vote of seven to one.
A little history of the schools as a state board authorized charter school.
So Olive Grove was initially approved at the July 2015 state board meeting for a five year term from July 1, 2015 to June 30, 2020.
They are a TK through 12 independent study program.
Total enrollment is currently 710 pupils and that is currently two times what was originally stated in their original petition.
They've had a good financial record under the state board authorization.
They currently are projected to have a funding balance of over $600,000 with a reserve of over 10%.
And the audited financial data from 2016-17 report had no significant audit findings that were noted.
In terms of their academic history, they have been approved for a dashboard alternative school status in the fall of 2017.
In February of 2018, the school-wide percentage of pupils not meeting state standards in math exceeded statewide averages by more than 15%, but we were in contact with the schools and the school did commit to adjusting their instruction to target their academic deficiencies, and they will talk a little bit about that in their presentation as well.
During our annual oversight visit of the schools in May 2018, Olive Grove was in compliance with their memo of understanding with the state board and their charter petition at that time.
In terms of their educational program, the pupils will participate in the independent study blended learning environment program with parent as the primary deliverer of the education program.
The schools will provide guidance, support, assistance, and resource materials to enable parents to meet the individual needs of each of their pupils.
Each pupil's academic performance is individualized, and the petitioners are proposing to preserve the current educational program delivered at each of their resource centers.
In terms of their fiscal analysis, all projected budgets, including ORCUT, are fiscally viable with reserves of 5%.
And I do have an error in this next bullet here.
At the ACCS meeting, part of our staff recommendation was that we did have a concern about the budget for ORCUT.
So, the item requested a balanced budget with a 5% reserve by June 30th, 2018.
The budget was submitted to CDE on June 14th, 2018 and we did review that budget and did determine that it is fiscally viable.
They do have a positive ending fund balance and the appropriate reserves for the term of the charter.
If approved by the State Board, we did find some elements in the petition that we feel do need to be clarified by the petitioner, and I have listed them here.
If these are approved by the State Board, we will continue to work with the petitioner to ensure we have the appropriate clarifications needed in the petition prior to the school's opening.
In summary, CDE staff is recommending approval of all four of these petitions.
They are in good standing with the State Board and have a good sound educational program as well as overall fiscal viability.
And again, we will work with them on clarification on some of the charter elements in the petition if approved by the State Board.
I'm available if anyone has any questions at this time.
Board Member Sandoval.
Thank you for the summary.
So this group has been authorized under state board for three years.
Yes.
And I didn't find any information about student outcomes in those three years.
So where's that information?
I can pull that up for you for some of the information we do have.
But because of the DASC certification, there really wasn't a lot of academic
performance data available to us.
Right.
Based on test scores?
Yes, based on test scores.
But the petitioner does have information in their presentation that they're going to discuss with you as well.
It is a small number.
What, 700, you said, students?
Yes.
So there would be other measures of student progress over three years than test scores.
And the petitioner does have that information.
We didn't include it as part of our presentation because we didn't look at it as a renewal.
OK.
But the petitioner does have some of that information to share with the board as well.
And my second question is on the demographic data tables.
So there is demographic data for the surrounding schools that pupils would otherwise be required to attend.
So I know this isn't I'm noticing this is not a comprehensive list of the local schools.
So
My question is, why are some schools missing from these tables from the local areas where these charters, where the proposed school will, for example, like Santa Maria.
Santa Maria High School is missing from this table.
So is Orchid Academy, which is a charter.
So I feel like I've just that's my question is why are those missing?
I can take a look at that I don't know the answer to it offhand, but I'll take a look and I can get back to you Yeah, and then I would just strongly recommend looking at the tables for all of those areas because in the Santa Ynez Valley I noticed there were also some missing.
Okay schools Other comments to Lisa at this point Remember Ortiz Lacone
This is a general comment, so I'm going to direct it to you versus the school or the district.
But I noticed that one of the areas that we will monitor is EL reclassification.
So can you remind me what percent of students are EL?
I'll have to look that up.
I'm sorry, I don't have that offhand, but I'll look it up for you.
So I'm wondering how does the training happen so that a parent is best suited to assist their EL child as they're moving up towards proficiency?
And I think this is general because it's always a question that I have when I see some of these schools.
I know that for teachers, we're still trying to make sure that we reach every school to train according to the common core and our standards.
And there's so many things that are happening at our state right now, so many frameworks, and it's a lift to get all of that support and resources and training to teachers.
So now you have the parent, that's the primary person delivering.
How are they meeting?
How are they trained?
How do they assist their child?
to develop language proficiency and everything else.
And that's just a general question because, again, we've gone through so many shifts and if that's an area of concern, then how are we making sure that the parent who's the main facilitator is actually trained or is qualified to do that?
I can take a look at that in a general statement.
Board Member Williams.
I'll address this in the same context to you as well, but I'm pretty certain we'll probably hear it from the petitioner, which is I think it's important for us to understand, you'd think we would since we approved the school three years ago, but it was a lot of charters ago, that to understand what sorts of families are in this system and are making this their public school choice and why.
what are the challenges that the students bring to the system and that Olive Growth is helping them with.
I think that context will help us understand this.
And I'm sure the petitioner can address that as well.
Okay, seeing no further comments, then I'm ready to open the public hearing.
And so first we'll hear from the petition supporters, and then you have 20 minutes.
Please come forward.
Identify yourselves as you speak.
Actually, afternoon now.
I am Laura Mudge.
I am the executive director of Olive Grove Charter School.
And my name is Dawn Wilson.
I am the COO of Olive Grove Charter School.
All right.
So we'll respond to you as we're doing our presentation, if that's OK.
I actually just spoke with our EL coordinator, and she's going to directly answer that question for you.
All right, so we're gonna try to do this kind of concisely, but if you have questions, I mean, we have been state board authorized for three years now, so if you have additional questions, we're happy to answer them as well.
I'm not sure we need to go over everything that was just stated, but Olive Grove Charter School was a dependent charter school previous to this incarnation of Olive Grove that first opened 17 years ago under Los Alivos School District.
In 2015, Los Olivos decided to go basic aid.
Well, they wanted to fall further into basic aid.
With the charter, they weren't able to do that.
They were worried about LCFF funding changing how they were going to be receiving funds for the students that were not in their district.
A large group of our staff decided we were going to try to keep all of Grove around for those students that really needed us throughout the county.
You guys authorized this.
Thank you so much.
In 2015, we have a really good and successful track record since then, financially, operationally, and academically.
Do you want to take the next part?
We sought the four new charters to comply with the ruling in Anderson versus Shasta lawsuit.
All four new charters were denied, and we appealed to the State Board of Education last year.
Based on CDE staff recommendation, we resubmitted to differentiate our four charters, and we resubmitted the petitions to align with local, county, and CDE recommendations already.
All four petitions were denied the second time, and we are here before you again.
So in the past four years, we've gone through this appeal process three times.
It's been a challenge.
But we do wish to thank the CDE for its recommendation to continue granting us our charter on appeal.
And we've had a really, really wonderful working relationship with the CDE over the past three years.
We're really thankful to them for that.
It's been great.
We also want to thank the ACCS for its strong support and we definitely concur with all the suggested technical amendments and will implement those by July 31st deadline So as far as our enrollment growth We came to you in 2015 We had around 320 students
We did tell all of our students.
We helped them find new placements.
And we just went through a really
pretty difficult transitional year that first year.
We had 104 students at the beginning of the year, went up to 214 students the first year.
Second year, we started with 276, quickly got back up to our 320 number.
We thought we were going to stabilize at that point because over the past 17 years, all of Grove Charter was kind of stabilized around 350 students.
But then we just kept going and enrolling every family that came to us because
We just saw such a need the parents when they came in with their students Many times we're crying and desperate for I mean literally crying and desperate and so we just kept hiring teachers to support students And we ended the year last year Well the year before with 465 students as you can see then this year this past year we started with 520 ended with about 780 students
And all of this growth is based of word of mouth and based of recommendations from the local school districts that we work with.
And this is coming from the counselors, the special ed departments, and also coming from doctors.
We do not do any marketing.
We couldn't handle more students than we're already getting.
But it's the word of mouth that we have gained respect for in the community for dealing with students who are DAS qualified and need specific supports.
So this is all organic growth.
None of this has been forced.
Parole officers bring students to us, child protective agencies.
Physicians, you already said that.
So I know there's been some confusion over our dashboard alternative school status.
Los Olivos never went and applied for ASAM.
At the time, I mean, there wasn't need for them to.
When we first became a school, we started looking at our student populations.
I mean, we knew from our historical data, but we weren't sure if we met that threshold.
As soon as we started realizing, oh yeah,
We really do meet this threshold.
We started the process, but then at that time there was a transition from ASAM to DAS.
So we are still waiting for those indicators and the eligibility criteria before we finally were able to apply for that status, which we did receive.
OK, so because of our DAS status, we felt that it was really best to compare our CASP results with other DAS schools in our area, because those are the same students.
We get a lot of students from those schools as well.
So when you look at the math CASP results, and again, we are
We have a lot of improvements planned for this school year coming up, and I can go over those, but when you look at our math results, in comparison to Maple, which is in Lompoc Unified School District, La Cuesta, which is in Santa Barbara, and Delta, which is in Santa Maria Joint, their DAS schools had 0% that met or exceeded math.
We had 10%, which is low, but at least we do have students that are meeting and exceeding, and we're working on improving that number.
Our English Language Arts Cast results, you can see we have 41.77% that met or exceeded, and the other local DAS schools weren't really close comparatively.
We're really proud about that and I do want to point out as we are at the ACCS meeting and one of the chairperson Was talking about the meat and the metons exceeded or met standards When they were comparing it with all Lompoc Unified School District, but that's not comparing apples to apples and we're trying to show you with Dash Dash qualification
I don't know what it is yet, DAS or DASH, that we are succeeding.
We are putting a lot of effort into this.
And we don't accept where we are.
We keep pushing forward because that's at the success of the student.
But when you compare apples to apples, we're doing a really good job with the student base that we have.
And part of that is based on our hiring.
We don't hire anybody who isn't a warrior for kids.
And that's really what the start of our interview process is.
So this is based on dedication that goes far beyond eight hours a day.
We're really proud of these numbers.
I know it might not look like this, but when you look at the comparison in our counties, we're doing some really good things.
And one thing we have found, actually, this past year we started implementing, Olive Grove has never had counselors before, so last year we hired two counselors school-wide.
Next year we now have four hired, so one at each learning center.
What we've noticed by, and we have a counselor, well, the head of our counseling department here to discuss what, that we've discovered over this past year is a lot of students that we didn't previously know were parenting or homeless, we've been able to identify since through our counselors.
And we've been able to put additional supports in for them.
So our numbers really are higher than what we first qualified with, so.
Oh wait, this is the new one.
Oh, okay.
So our cohort graduation rates combined, well, our cohort graduation rate, 62.5%.
As you can see, that's about three times higher than Maple and La Cuesta.
And it's a little below Delta, but when you add in our still enrolled population, we do exceed all the other local DAS schools.
This is, I think, what we're most proud about because many times our students come to us without having
had any success in their education.
And so they come to us and a lot of times you know the parents are desperate and parents do come with their students to our school most of the time.
Sometimes that they're not able to but the students a lot of times won't even look us in the eye at first and they don't have much self-confidence.
And so
you know, very quickly they realize we are advocating for them as a person and as a human being who's worth advocating for.
So these numbers on the school climate report card are really, really what we're most proud about because these students are feeling successful.
They feel like they're being supported.
We're on the 99th percentile both statewide and similar schools and our numbers did even increase over the path from 2017 to 18 so We're happy about that.
Okay, so
Our Renaissance growth is really how we track students individually.
So we test them when they first come in.
We test them at the beginning of every year, mid-year, and at the end of the year.
And so in 2016, we started with 276 students.
So this only reflects the students who were with us for an entire year.
So you can see we did have growth in both.
Then this past year, we did start lower, but we had over doubled in students.
What we liked about this, though, we could see we had made actually greater gains.
Even though we started lower, we had made greater gains than we made the previous year with these students.
So that was exciting.
So we don't have our LPEC scores back, I don't think, yet.
But I put in our results from the year previous.
And after we implemented new EL curriculum and supports this past year, we did reclassify 19%, as opposed to only 6% the year before.
We are increasing, and next year we have plans for further improvements as well.
All four schools are already admitted to El Dorado Charter SELPA.
WASC accreditation process has already started.
OGCS is fully WASC accredited at this moment for grades TK through 12.
We worked with the auditor and CSMC so fiscal systems are already in place and ready to track each school separately And we worked with our attorneys young median core CSDC CCSA and CSMC to ensure the administration and governance are ready and in place as well
So again, we're thanking everyone, but I did want to address your concern about ELs, which we'll have our EL staff come and speak as well.
So we put in a lot of supports for our EL students.
do have online supports, in-house supports.
Students meet one-on-one with their teachers and they come for additional classes.
We've doubled that time for next year as well.
And while we say parents are the primary deliverers, that's usually in our TK through eighth grade, when students are in high school, we bump up the supports for them so that they get a lot more classroom-based.
Support throughout the week So and then with Renaissance when we were showing you some of the data We're going to be remapping our SIS system to communicate with Renaissance as soon as we know that we're breaking up the schools And functioning differently, so we'll have better subgroup information And we can probably have that to you guys within 90 days if you have further questions on that Sherry who's going to be handling the remapping is here to answer that
But we do meet with students individually.
So really, each student is their own person in our eyes.
So whether they're e-mail, I mean, to them, they're just, we care about each one individually.
So we're tracking them as a unique individual.
And since we are DAS, we're tracking them individually.
We are DAS qualified.
I mean, each student, whether or not they're EL, they also have these additional needs.
They've had gaps in their education.
They've been homeless.
There's other things that they have that we're helping them with.
We started this year, too, also providing bus passes because we noticed kids were not able to make it to support classes.
So we're trying to find out why.
Why aren't you able to make it?
So we're purchasing bus passes.
We're doing everything we can to help get them to school and accessing those supports.
That's it, unless you have questions.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
We'll have questions later for you.
And so that now completes the supporters of the petition.
So the opponents have 20 minutes.
Opponents to the petition have 20 minutes.
Please come forward.
No, no presentation.
Does this work?
Just close it.
Technology.
Need that computer science stuff you were talking about earlier.
All right, well, good afternoon, President Kurse, board members.
My name is Kevin Fannin.
I'm with the law firm of Dance Well over Kelly.
I'm here on behalf of Santa Maria Joint Union High School District.
Superintendent Mark Richardson requested that I appear at this meeting today on behalf of Santa Maria, and I'm here with
Hi, I'm Kristen Lindgren.
I'm with Liebert Cassidy Whitmore, and my firm represents the Santa Ynez Valley Union High School District.
And Superintendent Scott Corey also asked me to come on his behalf.
So we are already planned to present together.
So I'm glad that we ended up with that plan for all four petitions, primarily because they're so similar and a lot of the issues are the same between them.
But I'm going to start with some sort of broad strokes about this appeal.
And really, this appeal is not for a new charter school.
This is an existing charter school with existing operations.
And we hope that the appeal process should really reflect that.
The petition should really explain what the charter school is doing and not what it will do in the future.
And our districts have sort of felt that the petitions were lacking in that respect.
Now, by way of history, the CD discussed the history of these charter schools, but we want to emphasize that six separate school districts have denied this charter school.
Of those six districts, four of those petitions were appealed.
The county board
denied that petition as well and all these denials have essentially held the same thing that petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the program and the chart petition does not contain a reasonably comprehensive description of all the elements.
We've cited mostly all of the same elements.
We've come to the same conclusions and we're separate districts with separate staffs and separate councils and we've all came to the same conclusion and
The petition before you, which the CD didn't mention, was initially appealed to the SBE.
The CD recommended denial, and then NACCS voted 4 to 3 to deny.
And then petitioners withdrew for the petitions from consideration, amended those petitions, and then resubmitted them locally to us.
And as local districts, we kind of expected the petitions to be significantly different to address our concerns since they went back during the appeal, and that was not our feeling.
And all four districts, including Santa Maria and Santa Ynez, we denied the petitions again, generally on the same findings that were not cured during this process.
However, this time the CD recommended approval with conditions, many of which are significantly material to the denial, to our denial, and they do not reflect a program that is currently open and existing.
My colleague will go into these problems in more detail.
But CDE recommends revisions to the petition for key elements to the program.
These include the education program, the measurable pupil outcomes, employee qualifications, admission requirements, suspension and expulsion procedures, and the dispute resolution procedures.
These are key elements of what a charter should propose.
And if a currently existing charter is already operating, it should be not very difficult to describe those in a meaningful way.
So just by way of example, and I'm glad we're already speaking about the English learners piece, but a lack of description about serving English learners may be indicative of a lack of serving English learners.
And the data certainly supports that.
CD found lots of budget deficiencies.
They found that the petitioners overstated LCFF revenue.
And they had to adjust those calculations in order to do its budget analysis.
They found that the budget understated expenditures for employing health and welfare benefits, and they could not determine whether salaries are reasonable because of a lack of description.
So what was requested was to submit a new budget by June 30th, and they found that as proposed, the budget was only marginally viable.
And now a new budget has been submitted.
data that has been made satisfactory to the CDE, but this was essentially created by the CDE.
And just in general, when you make a budget, I know when I budget my own expenses, it's very important that I make the budget because I'm the one who's following it.
So we question the ability to just sort of change a budget right before the approval as an example that it will actually be followed through with.
And as post-Anderson, I know the state board is really developing a larger portfolio of charter schools.
And we hope in the future that budgets should be more than marginally viable and that petitions should really reflect their operations that are actually going to occur.
So as proposed, the CDE, six districts, the Santa Barbara County Board of Education, they all concluded that this petition was
essentially not within the meaning, would not satisfy the Charter Schools Act and the only way that it could be is for it to be significantly revised with conditions.
And so we essentially feel that that shouldn't be how charter schools are
brought forth to the State Board.
The Education Code and CDE provide resources for school districts and county offices.
They provide a process, guidelines, a template for review.
All the districts, including my district, San Ynez, and Santa Barbara County, we've utilized this process, these templates.
We've all came to the same conclusion, now multiple times, and we've committed significant time and resources in taking this
sort of, we've taken this process really seriously.
And we just essentially hope that the state board sort of gives deference to our expertise.
So my colleague is going to now speak about specifics in the petition.
And I thank you for this opportunity to speak with you.
Hello again.
So we share the concern about English learners in this learning environment with the blended independent study and homeschool environment.
It's very unclear from the petition how English learner parents will be supported in a way that they'll be able to assist their students in coming up to speed to the point that they can become reclassified or otherwise being able to modify the curriculum for them.
CDE staff and its recommendation to the advisory commission noted that the EL plan actually fails to contain a comparison of the pupils' performance in basic skills against an empirically established range of performance in basic skills.
based upon the performance of English proficient pupils of the same age, so that they could demonstrate that a pupil sufficiently has become proficient in the curriculum of native English speakers.
It maybe feels like a small portion of what we're looking at, but it feels really important that those kind of
Measures are in place, you know when we we hear that they have a 19% reclassification rate How is that being done?
We don't know and so that is of a major concern with respect to the EL plan in the charter petition We pulled some numbers and the most recent we were able to find to show that the County of Santa Barbara has a 32% English learner rate
And the currently operating all Grove Charter School has a 13.4% rate.
I acknowledge those may be slightly old numbers.
That's what we were able to pull up.
But it does seem that there may be
English learner parents who are not even applying to the school because the program is going to be problematic for them to implement, particularly in TK through eighth grade, where the parents are the primary providers of the educational program.
Again, as my colleague notes, this is a charter school that's been operating for several years.
We would expect them to have that information in the charter petition and did not see any of that.
With respect to measurable pupil outcomes, which is a little bit of a similar issue, CDE noted that the measurable pupil outcomes were not clear in the petition, either with respect to general measurable pupil outcomes
or with the eight state priorities for the LCAP.
So what we saw and Santa Maria particularly noted this in their staff report with respect to denial that was adopted by their board is that for the eight state priorities,
There are listed plans of things that will happen as opposed to actual outcomes for the students.
So we will increase support or we will provide access to a counselor, but we don't know what those outcomes look like.
And with respect to the general measurable pupil outcomes, they're pretty vague.
It's unclear.
And while I appreciate the petitioner's hard work and the fact that they have increased their test scores, given that,
We would want to be sure that those measurable pupil outcomes were clearly defined and able to be measured and carried out.
And it does not appear from at least the face of the petition that that is something that we can count on moving forward with this program.
With regard to special education, we have sort of a similar concern as we do with English learners.
It's really unclear how this blended program is going to be able to support the majority of students who are eligible for special education.
The CDE staff noted that there are no
Qualifications given for the special education director.
I'm not sure there is a special education director that information has been sort of evolving throughout this process Which has been long we agree.
I
But we are unclear how many special education students are actually being served at this point, or how many will be served.
The budget seems to indicate not very many.
And again, we're concerned about the problem of special education parents feeling like they can't bring their students to the school because the supports are not there.
And they're to be the primary providers, particularly from TK through eighth grade.
Just a couple other.
Notes with respect to student discipline.
There are a couple of issues that popped up.
I
And one of them applies to special education as well.
As you may know, a student who has engaged in certain behavior but is eligible for special education services and is under an IEP, if they engage in severe bodily harm, they bring a weapon to school, they bring illegal drugs to school, there's a process by which they can be given an alternative interim placement for 45 days.
But you can't do that unless you have an administrative law judge, hearing officer grant that request.
And the charter provides that.
That can just be done without a hearing officer's approval.
The charter school could actually do that 45 day.
interim placement on its own, which violates federal special education law, which does apply to a charter school.
So things like that kind of raise concerns about how special education is being carried out in the district.
Also, the petition does not provide for recent changes to the Charter Schools Act, which requires certain due process requirements for
suspensions of students of less than 10 days and greater than 10 days.
And so, yes, that can be fixed in the petition.
Maybe that's a technical change that needs to be made, but it raises concerns about the knowledge of the petitioners as far as changes to special or to education law, the education code, the monster that we all deal with every day, right?
And that is something that we need to see in order to approve a petition, which is why our districts have not approved the petition.
So, those are just some of the most important points that we wanted to make.
You guys have all the documentation, all of the basis for all of the rejection.
We didn't want to take your time reiterating everything, but we just wanted to point out a few of those points.
And again, as my colleague mentioned, we hope that you will agree with all of us.
Thank you so much for your time.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Okay.
So, we want to go directly to public comment at this point.
Directly to public comment.
Please call the roll.
Would the following speakers please line up at the podium.
Wendy Sanders, Elsa Martinez, Mari Mitchell.
Okay.
Now the public hearing closed.
Yeah.
And people have two minutes.
I thought you closed it after the public.
Jennifer Cloud, Allison Reed, Sherry Kynart, Brooke Lawrence, Laurel Severo, Ryan Joy, Brandon Ray Devine, Jim Burke, Lorraine Richards, Angela Deramos, Ramel Antone, and Eric Premack.
I'm Wendy Sanders, the incoming special education director for the North State Charter JPA.
The JPA provides special education expertise to charter schools, working closely with the Ed Code Charter SELPA.
My JPA colleagues and I have been working with the Olive Grove for three years, helping first with setting up a compliant, effective special education program.
And since, continuing to answer questions related to special education program implementation.
Olive Grove has actually been sought out by and very responsive to students with disabilities and their families.
Currently they serve approximately 90 students with disabilities.
20% of those students came to Olive Grove eligible for IEPs as students with emotional disturbance often because those students were unsuccessful at their district schools and parents report unwelcome.
The JPA would continue to work with all the Olive Grove schools for the 2018-2019 school year, providing special education consultation, including consultation for any mental health, behavior, suspension, expulsion, and dispute resolution situations that would arise.
I am confident that Olive Grove schools will continue to meet the unique, wide-ranging needs of special education students on the Central Coast.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Maddie Michelle, and this is Elsa Martinez, and she'll be taking up some of my time as well.
I don't know.
Not on this?
This one?
It's on, yeah.
Okay, speak up then.
Okay, sorry.
My name is Maddie Michelle.
Okay.
And this is Elsa Martinez, and she'll be taking up some of my time, so she has less.
So I came to Olive Grove Charter School because I wasn't on the right path.
I would always be getting D's and skipping school, doing drugs.
I was dealing with a lot.
I was dealing with depression as well.
School wasn't my thing from the very beginning.
I was bullied a lot when I was younger and didn't have great experiences with school.
I never liked school or teacher I just thought of all of them had no passion and just didn't care.
When I entered high school I moved three times simply because I didn't like school and I would always be ditching.
Sadly I was stuck in the district until my junior year when I found out about Olive Grove.
Let me tell you, from the very beginning, they did everything in their power to help me and make sure I succeeded.
I was truly happy at the school.
I came in very guarded.
I had my walls up, and I didn't want any help because of my past experience with school.
But my teacher never gave up on me or anyone there.
It was like they were family and they never let you down.
They helped me get through a lot.
They understand.
They ask what's wrong.
They simply care.
They saw the potential in me when I didn't.
They pushed me to do things that I would have never thought of doing.
I'm not a big fan of public speaking.
Honestly, I don't like it at all.
But can you believe I took a speech and debate class with the push of my teacher because he simply believed I was good at speaking and I should work on it?
Even with my mom, my mom is a Hispanic who doesn't speak English.
In regular school, nobody did anything to inform her about my behavior, grades, or attendance.
At Olive Grove, could you believe my teacher would take the time of his day and write a letter to her and translate it on Google Translate?
He would always be texting her and my brother telling them if I was okay, how I'm doing, if I need help with anything, always.
My mom... Go ahead.
I'll go ahead?
They said that they can't combine the time.
Oh, well, you can, yeah, then you can talk next, okay?
I was giving her my time because she had so much to say.
Oh, OK.
Well, we'll give you more then.
Yeah.
You finish.
Go ahead.
OK.
My mom was very surprised and appreciated very much that someone involved her.
I definitely felt that I was meant to be in this world.
If I wouldn't show up to a meeting, my teacher would go crazy trying to contact me, looking for me at my house, because he would not let me go back into my bad habits.
The whole entire time I've been in school, my best grades were all out of growth.
My freshman year I went from a 0.83 and over 100 cuts to graduating with 3.2 with zero cuts.
If you would have told me this today four years ago or just simply saying I would have graduated, I would have never believed you.
I probably would have dropped out of school by now.
I'm currently working on going to Allan Hancock to study psychology.
I wish I would have known the school existed a long time ago because I would have wanted to be here all my life.
Olive Grove gave me hope in school again and
And I know I'm not alone in anything, and I'm truly grateful.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm not on speaker.
Well, I'll just use my teacher voice then.
I might have cut in line.
I'm Jennifer Cloud.
I'm the principal at the Lompoc Olive Grove Charter Learning Center.
So we had another great successful year.
And I just brought my little sticky note, teachers love sticky notes, of some things to come.
So we initiated a STEM program.
So I was really grateful to hear some feedback about STEM.
And we're advancing that into third through fifth grade this year.
So we're really excited to offer that.
And the parents were really excited to hear that we would proceed forward.
We have a new science teacher coming in to offer science support labs.
And he's also going to be offering other supports, programming, someone mentioned that in here.
And occasionally in our STEM class, we do make paper airplanes and throw them, so Ms.
Rucker.
And all in the name of science and STEM, of course.
And I'm super excited this year.
The last time I spoke, I was looking forward to the prospect of adopting new ELA curriculum for 6th through 12th grade, which has happened, so I've got my hands on it.
And I'm developing that along with the other English teachers.
And we're also adopted new social studies.
So I'm really looking forward to bringing that on board on the new Common Core curriculum.
And we also have a new supplemental math support.
We see a need for that in our classroom.
And our test scores, unfortunately, they do prove that.
So we're really working hard to remedy the gap.
But the counseling services, that's something new.
I called it my unicorn because when I was a kid, I loved unicorns.
But they were just like fig bar in my imagination.
And so now that we have one on the ground, and she's just awesome.
She wasn't able to attend.
But she's just offered so much for our students already.
And I'm really looking forward to working with her next year, this coming year, excuse me.
I wish I could tell you more about all the fabulous kids we have and the parents, but maybe you'd like to come and visit.
Thank you very much today.
Hi, my name is Allison Reed, and I've actually been a teacher at Olive Grove for, this is my 13th year, so I've been around for a while, I've seen a lot.
And I've always believed in our school, I've always thought we were doing amazing things, but now more than ever, it's just,
We have gone above and beyond with the support classes we offer, like the EL classes, math and English labs.
We have more than we have had in a while, and we just keep progressing.
And that's the biggest thing that I've seen in the 13 years is that we never stop.
We're always trying to improve.
And I could sit or stand here and tell you about all the amazing stories that I've seen over the last 13 years, and I keep in touch with a lot of my former students.
One I just want to bring up is the fact that we do serve students who have anxiety, who can't go to school for a variety of reasons.
Maybe they're bullied or they have medical issues.
I had a student this past year who was coming to our school because his older brother was
Had a rare heart condition.
He ended up passing away at 19 and the younger brother ended up being diagnosed with the exact same condition.
So his mom has I mean she had to take him to doctor's appointments in L.A.
and all over the place.
And I mean they couldn't attend a regular school.
They didn't have any options.
They found Olive Grove.
And I mean he's doing amazing.
I think the prognosis is looking good.
So he's just, I still have him as a student and he's doing really, really well and his mom is just, you know, over the moon to have found us and so he's not missing out on school.
You know, I have students that I still keep in touch with and it's amazing to see from when they came in and they were, they come in and they just, they don't have faith in school anymore.
They've been maybe beat down by
just large groups and not being focused on that individual attention.
But then when you actually talk to them, you're sitting down and you get to chat about, you know, their home life and, you know, their favorite things to do.
What are you doing this weekend?
You know, and they just, you connect with them on a different level.
And so it's just, it's really cool to have that relationship with them.
And I really- Time.
Okay.
Well, thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Brooke Lawrence, and I'm a teacher with Olive Grove Charter School.
I'm also the ELD coordinator, so I just wanted to speak to you a moment about what we offer our students, and our EL students in particular, and answer any questions that you may have.
So Laura actually did an amazing job covering what we do.
We have curriculum that is ELD aligned.
It's common core aligned to the standards.
And I know our friends had a question about what are their student learning outcomes.
And ultimately the outcome is that they increase their proficiency in speaking, reading, and writing.
And that is what our lessons are geared towards every single day.
We have doubled our supports for those students.
They have in-class support where they come four hours a week and they'll be receiving that instruction that's aligned to the common core curriculum that they're being given and they're also being exposed to project-based learning units.
They're going to be receiving experiential learning through field trips and so we do offer a lot of support and
Honestly, I believe our students receive more support than at a traditional school simply because they have so much one-on-one time with their teachers.
I have a student this last year and he was with me almost all week.
He would come in and anytime he had a question, I was right there for him.
I was able to support him in his learning.
And this is a story for so many of our students where they can't function in larger group settings as Ali was sharing.
And this is just a better fit for them.
And so thank you for considering us because I know that is an option that our students need and that they greatly depend on.
Are there any questions about our ELD supports?
We'll have those later.
This is public testimony.
Oh, I'm sorry.
OK.
Thank you.
Good evening, I'm Brandon Ray Estrella.
Can you not hear?
Yeah, speak up a little if you can.
OK.
I've been with Olive Grove for five years.
I was recommended Olive Grove because they couldn't handle me in public school because I would speak out and I would try to go ahead, which was unrecommended, and looked down upon.
When I came to Olive Grove, I was terrified.
I was a social butterfly, and I thought that being homeschooled was going to take that away.
But the one-on-one teacher, the one-on-one
like the way the teachers helped me one-on-one it helped me excel in school and see myself do better things so I fell in love with the piano and Olive Grove gave me the time to develop that skill and I've been playing for three years and it's all self-taught and I've made three symphonies and I have performed them
I started off at Olive Grove with a 2.5 GPA.
I finished with a 3.8, almost to a 4.0, and graduated early.
Olive Grove has been there for me, and they're like family.
The teachers are loving, they're kind, and they're always willing to help.
They always have time, and that's something that I didn't see in a public school.
With a class of like 30 people,
And you don't see people's personalities, because there's always other people over-masking it.
But they see who you are as a person, and they develop that.
And it's a beautiful thing to watch.
I've been a TA for some of the teachers.
And I've seen kids come and go who have been struggling and seeing how the teachers react to it is so professional and so beautiful and so encouraging to give the kids the hope that they need.
And being one of that is just amazing and astounding.
Thank you.
Right here, right?
This one?
Hi, my name is Ryan Joy.
I'm an education specialist at the Santa Barbara site.
I just wanted to quickly talk about the importance of our school and our delivery model as it pertains to special education.
Working with students one-on-one is just so beneficial to me as an educator and to all of our teachers because it allows us to individualize
Lessons and assignments and instruction to the special needs of our students, which is of course like best practice for all students But it's particularly important when you're talking about Students with different learning disabilities or different strengths and different weaknesses.
So our model really allows for so much flexibility in that regard And I think it's also what I found this is I don't have the 13 years Ali does this is my first year with our school, but what I found is the one-on-one
Setting allows you to develop a relationship that is so much more impactful as you've heard from some of these students and so much more motivating and like in our core values group on part of the emotional social emotional team and we've talked about and discussed the importance of like charismatic teachers and developing those relationships and we've all seen cute YouTube videos of teachers standing at the door and doing handshakes with their students and
to develop relationships like that is so important.
And our delivery model allows for that so much more than other settings that I've worked in.
And I just think that's a really important thing that we bring to these students.
So thank you for your time.
Hello, my name is Laurel Servo and the Dean of Students at Olive Grove.
Before I was at Olive Grove, I actually was at Orchid Academy, which I know was mentioned by one of you earlier.
And I was also the dean there.
And one of my frustrations was it was a dependent charter with Orchid School District.
And they had all kinds of stipulations, so a student couldn't start with our school unless they had a 2.0 when they started.
So they have the best test scores in the county, but when students weren't successful, they were dismissed.
And so I became frustrated with that.
And so I came over to Olive Grove, and since being there this year, I just wanted to show a few data points with you.
We are now four counselors strong.
Last year we had two and with the two counselors that we had, we had 79% of our students complete the FAFSA and enroll in a community college in the area.
We established partnerships this year with our local community college and are working on CTE courses for concurrent enrollment.
The number of students taking community college classes while they're in high school increased by 25% this year.
And the counselors were able to meet with each student when they come into school and develop a plan for the whole time they're in school that includes their academic and social and emotional support.
One thing I also wanted to note was that when I asked students how they were referred to us, the majority of the time they're being referred to us by the principal or vice principal or counselor at our local school districts that are denying us.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Sherry Kynert and I am a registrar at Olive Grove and information specialist and I've been with them for two years.
I as well came from the Orchid School District and Orchid Academy High School.
I worked in the Orkut Union School District for 27 years.
I was very disillusioned and needed to be re-energized in education, came to Olive Grove and got just that.
I was fortunate to see the enrollment process as a registrar, to see families come, to see parents literally crying with no options and to be taken in.
And I was also able to see students that were completely credit deficient come in and after six months,
Going strong here students that say I Had no place in public education.
I was lost and I was just told that I'm smart, you know It's an incredible place dedicated extremely professional environment and I have been in education for quite a long time and
So I feel very blessed and very fortunate to be able to actually see the data, to see the test scores, to be able to print diplomas and participate in graduations.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Borden.
Ramel Antoine with the California Charter Schools Association.
I'm just going to keep it really brief.
Just a couple of things.
First, the leadership of this school.
I don't say this often, but this leader, Laura Mudge, is in it for the long haul.
She's been at this work for a long time and is clearly committed to continuing to retool her process and to bring her team into the process, doing what's best for the kids.
Ultimately, that's what she's doing.
You know, she could have just really done the bare minimum and then tried to get that through, but she has gone back to the local district and worked with them through that process and ultimately could not get approved there and is back here before you through a long, arduous process.
But she is still sticking it out, and that takes grit.
It takes tenacity.
What's also important to note is that there are over 700 students who are currently at this school, and these are students who, if they were not at this school, likely would not be at any school.
And this school is really doing the work of keeping students engaged in the educational system and doing the best that they can while also trying to improve.
We hear that from the stories of the students that were here today that have spoken, but also from the teachers who have such passion and drive for this work.
So I urge you, we urge you to consider approval of this school.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Lorraine Richards, California Teachers Association, speaking against the petition.
In all districts, the petition from this group from a non-classroom based charter was denied by six locals and Santa Barbara County based upon same or similar facts.
Most significantly, low standards and poor achievement throughout their history have indicated 75% of the students at low performance.
County referred the petition with unsound and insufficient data to properly implement a successful program.
Another significant area is financial stability, which was previously addressed as marginal, then resubmitted based on California Department of Education recommendations requests.
Questionable whether financial capability on their own.
And lastly, consider this charter has been around since 2002-2003 to make improvements to the application.
These significant areas mentioned reflect denial.
Thank you.
Angela de Ramos, also representing CTA, also speaking against this petition.
The CDE notes that the Olive Grove Charter needs to address by revision several issues including reclassification criteria, measurable pupil outcome, employee classification, and suspension and expulsion procedures.
These are not simply technical amendments, however.
They're significant omissions, making their addition a material change.
Furthermore the move to belatedly claim as an alternative dashboard school would indicate that the charter at school acknowledges They have not met student academic needs adequately as planned CTA urges the board to deny the petition.
Thank you
Good afternoon, Paul Kiefer with Pacific Charter Institute, and I urge you to vote yes on the petition.
I appreciate CDE and the state board's oversight over the last three years, and I trust that you'll continue to do the good oversight.
And I know this program, as it grows, obviously is demonstrating that it's meeting the needs of the community.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We support staff recommendation on this as well as ACCS recommendation.
We've been working with this group for 17 years, or this school for 17 years since its inception and all of its challenging iterations over time, including helping them through the appeal that you granted a few years back.
We've been very impressed with their success throughout, but most impressed with the recent leadership team
They've done a great job financially, operationally, governance, legal, and we strongly suggested that they do interim assessments given the squishiness of the DAS data at this point and are pleased to see that they've done that as well and have strong results to show there.
We think this one's a slam dunk and urge you to approve all four of them.
Thank you.
Hi.
My name is Jim Burke.
I'm on the school board for Olive Grove Charter School, which still surprises me, but that's a whole other story, oddly.
I was 40 years a teacher from the federal government, California state schools, 40 years in the classroom.
In the last the last five of those years I Was I'm pretty sure I was the first teacher at Olive Grove when the Los Olivos school put it together and I thought I was going to be a tough sell on it, but I
What that experience gave me was something that I always knew to be true, facing 25 or 30 kids in a classroom, is that I wasn't going to be able to get to very many of them.
It's just a fact of life.
With that many kids in a classroom, you have the dominant kids, and you have the kids that aren't quite so much, and I couldn't get them all.
And that was frustrating.
Any teacher worth their salt finds that frustrating.
And I tried putting a mailbox on my desk all bolted and locked up so they could jot notes.
But that just wasn't personal enough.
And when I got into the charter school, it just suddenly made sense.
I could really get down with my kids.
And they were all ages.
So it was a wonderful experience.
Olive Grove is about the individual.
It's about the individual student.
And a few weeks ago, I went to the high school graduation.
And when I saw all those mortarboards flying up in the air, and the kids just so excited, I think it was like 80 of them.
And the parents and the, am I done?
Yeah.
And I'll be done really quick.
And the parents just hollering and the horns blasting.
in this gymnasium, and it was just an incredible moment, wonderful moment.
And I just believe in Olive Grove.
And I believe in the effort and the difference.
OK, time.
Thank you.
All right, I think the board, before we discuss this, we ought to take a break.
And so we'll get back a quarter or three.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene.
So we're through the public hearing and we've heard the public comment.
So we're now ready for board member questions.
And so who wants to start with the questions?
Well, I think I'd rather have her come later.
Sue Burr.
I actually was interested in some of the information I think that Member Sandoval asked about, and I don't know, Lisa, if you have it, but I would like to see the demographics, which I'm pretty sure we haven't seen yet.
But I do apologize, we made a mistake and left it off of all of the charts.
So we did do the comparison, but when we pulled Olive Grove total, we didn't pull it by each of the specific resource centers, so we didn't grab the information.
Let me ask, do you have the demographic information?
And you're asking about our specific learning centers, right?
Okay, that's what I thought.
Yeah, on our student information system, I just have to.
I have the 17-18.
But that's for all of them.
Right, it's not individualized, but it's all of your schools all together.
So I can at least start with that information.
So this is the 17-18 information.
The enrollment, this is from about 521 students, so it's not their 710 that they're currently at.
But out of those students,
There are 286 Hispanic or Latino, 196 white students, 16 that are two or more race.
There are five Filipino, three Asian, four American Indian or Alaska Native, seven African American.
And that makes up the total of the 521 at that point.
So it's not the full 700, but that does give you a total of the schools altogether.
So that's not individual, but.
OK.
And if you have the individual, then... Yeah, I'm pulling up right now.
Once I have the first one up, the others will be easy, because it'll just be a matter of changing the location.
And if you could also add free and reduced price lunch, special ed.
I think those are in this report.
I'll check.
All right.
And then a foster youth too, and unhoused youth.
Yeah.
And again, some of those numbers like homeless, we have found through our counselors that those numbers are higher.
And so we'll be inputting those as we get that information in the next school year too as well.
All right.
So I have Santa Maria.
So do you just want by percentages, or what's best?
And I don't know if there's a way to hook what I'm seeing up so they can view it.
No?
OK.
So Santa Maria, 5.2% American Indian, 0.3% Asian, 0.3% Asian Indian, 3% black or African American, 0.7% declined to state, 3.8% Filipino.
31.9% Hispanic or Latino and it's just like 0.3% Japanese, 0.3% Laotian, 0.3% Mexican-American.
Wait, no.
6.3% Mexican-American.
Yeah, on here.
6.3% was a Mexican-American.
They self-report.
So 0.7% Middle Eastern, 1% other Asian, 0.7% Samoan, 0.7% unspecified.
0.3 Vietnamese, 44% white.
And then 70.1% Hispanic, 29.9% not Hispanic.
I know.
Did you have a question?
Oh, sorry.
Right.
Well, when we do our Hispanic and non-Hispanic, that kind of breaks it.
OK.
Female, 58.7.
Male, 41.3.
And then one thing I did want to state that I didn't state before is 75% of our students are in high school.
So that's why a lot of our supports are really geared towards high school.
And then another 15% are junior high.
So really, students aren't coming to us until they're really to the point where they're having problems at their local school.
Gifted, 5.6, Title I, 2.1, socioeconomically disadvantaged in Santa Maria, 70.5, special education, 10.8.
And then our languages in Santa Maria, 13.9%, 1.4 Arabic, 1 mixteco percent, and 11.5% Spanish.
And then 2.1% students living in hotels, motels, 0.3% licensed children's institution, 5.2% other homeless.
It says 89.2% permanent housing, but we found a lot of these people are reporting that they have permanent housing when they're living with grandma or someone else that really puts them as a,
homeless student, 2.4% temporary shelters.
So that's Santa Maria.
Okay, so should I go to the next one?
All right.
So Lompoc will be next.
Okay, Lompoc, 8.8% American Indian or Alaska Native, 3.4% Black or African American, 0.7% declined to state, 2% Filipino, 0.7% Hawaiian, 37.4 Hispanic or Latino, 7 Laotian, 6.1 Mexican American, 0.7 Salvadorian, yeah, and
39.5% white.
76.9% Hispanic, 23.1% not Hispanic.
59.9% female, 40.1% male.
Gifted and talented, 4%.
Title I, Part C migrant, 2.7.
Socioeconomically disadvantaged, 74.1.
And special education, 16.3%.
And then we only have Spanish 17% ELL at Santa Maria.
And then again, the homeless reflect the same numbers.
I could go over them again if you want, but they're pretty much the same.
Santa Barbara.
So Santa Barbara, 5.7% American Indian or Alaska Native, 0.5% Argentinian, 1.6% Asian, 3.1% Black or African American, 0.5% declared to state, 0.5% Filipino.
16.7 Hispanic, 1 Japanese, 6.8 Mexican American, 0.5 Samoan, 0.5 unspecified, 62 white.
46.4 not Hispanic, 53.6, sorry, 46.4% Hispanic, 53.6 not Hispanic.
54.7% female, 45.3% male.
10% gifted, 0.5% Title I migrants, 43.2 socioeconomically disadvantaged, 17.2 special education.
All 7.8% yells are Spanish.
7.8, it's a lot less in our Santa Barbara Learning Center.
And then, which one did I not do, Buellton?
All right.
6% American Indian or Alaska Native, 2% declined to state, 8%.
Hispanic or Latino, 4% Mexican-American, 4% unspecified, 76% white, 24% Hispanic, 76% non-Hispanic, male and female 50-50, 8% gifted and talented, 42% socioeconomically disadvantaged, and 14% special ed.
6% of the students are Spanish-English language learners at that location.
So there are differences and they're pretty much reflective of the areas that the students live in.
Is that it?
Okay.
And also I had a question about the absence of some of the schools in those local areas from the data tables.
if someone could address why they're not included.
When we have to look at the schools that students would otherwise be required to attend in the local areas, there are some schools that are missing from the tables.
We do do a random sample.
So we select five schools within that one to five mile radius of that school.
And then we do look at the schools where the students would otherwise attend.
So we don't we may not capture all of the schools but we do try to capture a random sample.
Yeah, thank you for clarifying that, because that's helpful for me to know.
But I know that when we already, for example, in the Santa Ynez Valley, the Buellton, looking at that petition, there's an independent charter that's existing that's authorized by district.
I think it's Walkman District.
But when that one, a comparable program is absent from the data tables,
It doesn't give us a complete picture of what options students have in that local area.
And when we don't have information about other charter schools in that area too, I just feel like there is some very important data missing.
I think if we're asked to make a decision that's so important, we really have to have a full picture of the context of these different communities where these schools are proposing to be continuing.
Understood.
I'll take a better look at that for future items.
I apologize for that Okay other questions Board member Rucker.
I think you wanted Okay, so let me begin by saying this was probably and all the time I've been on the board the most frustrating Petition and appeal that I have studied in reading I couldn't decide whether I was reading a plan that was a material revision of
a plan that had already been approved for a charter that's already a board approved charter, or if this was an appeal for a new charter, or if this was an ongoing running conversation to revisit the Anderson decision.
The reason I'm saying that this was frustrating is, first of all,
There was a lot of information that should have been in this charter, particularly as it relates to talking about student services for English learners in particular, since parents are going to be the primary agents of support for those students
not only on instructional issues, but on support for language development that was never spelled out in the charter.
And this is not the first charter where I have had issues with what was not included in the charter concerning
English learners, but this is the petition that was the most spare of information.
And the reason why I was frustrated is I couldn't understand or decide whether they were simply getting the benefit of being an already existing charter and the staff were relying on information they already knew
about the operations of the staff in the charter that was not covered in the charter or if the staff simply decided it wasn't required or it was sufficient with the technical recommendations you were making.
Which goes back to the other reason why I was frustrated.
Every time I read a charter petition that comes to us on appeal and we have this collection of technical amendments and conditions that you say are non-material,
Some of them are more material than others and we continue to have this running dispute and debate about what is a material revision and what is not.
And I don't agree that on some of these conditions that are related to approving this charter that they're not material.
I don't disagree that the conditions that are being added will improve the petition and will actually address the issues that were connected to why the other districts in the county office would not approve them.
But because if those amendments are added, if districts had seen that same petition with those added amendments, they probably would have approved it.
which is what makes me see in my mind that these are material visions.
But I need to understand as it relates to
the special education parents, and as it relates to the English learners, I actually heard more in the public testimony about what was going on in the program than I actually read in the charter.
So I want to, is this level of, I'm asking the department staff because I'm just so surprised at how poorly what was presented to us was actually presented and you still recommended it for approval.
What actually are you looking for in making these recommendations on this plan that you could approve this and it contains far less information than other plans that we have looked at and approved before.
So I'm very frustrated because this plan was so poorly developed on areas that are so material to the students they serve.
This is a charter that's been in place
for a long time.
So to me, for them to come to the board and to do this work, even if they weren't coming to us when they submitted this charter for approval at district, it should have been better done based on their experience and the work that they've already been doing for the student population that they so tout that they're so good at, but they don't say anything in this plan about what they're actually doing, particularly for the English learners and the students
with special education needs.
It was so poorly done and I'm so frustrated that this is the worst petition I've ever seen turned in and yet we're still being recommended to approve it.
I don't get it.
Okay.
I can tell you that we looked at each petition individually like we do with all the other petitions.
We did call out what was in the petition that the petitioner stated would cover their EL criteria.
They did talk specifically about, I'm pulling up their section now, about their methods for English language development.
They discussed newly approved curriculum that they were going to be offering to the EL students.
when that curriculum was going to be happening, that they would be working with their students.
So what we felt was lacking was the information about the EL reclassification.
We didn't feel like they addressed that in their petition.
But overall, we did feel that they addressed that piece of the petition.
But we did look at them specifically as they came in newly this time around.
We weren't relying on a previous petition they had submitted before the board.
Board member Strauss.
So it's my understanding that the reasoning these charter appeals are before us is because of the Shasta decision.
Am I correct on that?
That's correct.
They are still within the current term that they were previously approved by the board.
Right.
And
I mean, I remember hearing about Olive Grove when we heard it in 2015.
And I just, I think we're clear that they serve a very challenging secondary population.
One, and I think the testimony from the students was heartfelt.
And I would just say, I would have taken any one of the teachers that testified to work in my high school in a minute.
I think these are really committed teachers and leaders.
who are working to support kids who haven't found the system to work for them.
And so I thank you.
Last August, I was very fortunate to spend the day with the Santa Barbara County superintendents.
And I would say sincerely that there was a lot of discomfort about the Olive Grove program, which we heard today between the challenge of the district and the Olive Grove program.
And that's too bad.
I think there's probably a variety of circumstances that have created a lack of positive collaboration.
But I think we always wish that all the programs that serve a local community could be more collaborative and positive in their work together.
And I think there's a lot of history.
that's built on that.
And I heard that from the districts who sincerely are trying to serve the kids as best they can.
And I would say as a former high school principal who sincerely tried to serve 3,500 diverse kids, we just didn't connect with every single one as we heard some students today.
That being said, it's my understanding that they were a collaborative group that had to be broken up into several different charters to meet the Shasta decisions requirement.
And that's why we're here today.
And I do appreciate what the attorneys presented as far as the demands and the challenges at the districts in reviewing it.
I think it's, you hear unanimous lack of support from the district and the county.
That's what I heard.
But I hear an amazing heartfelt support for the kids and the program.
So that's a dilemma for us as well.
I also heard in the data that the school shared that it's interesting that it's more female than male population, which is interesting, more non-white than white, a poorer population, a higher special ed population than typically is served percentage-wise in the local school.
These are not the kids that get it the first shot all the time, and we heard that from some students as well.
Wish if I could fix everything that you'd you'd be a district that was that was working collaboratively and so appreciated the energy and support and I guess that's the dilemma if I Could say going forward that what would be good is because they've been in existence a long time so they have a long time history of not cooperating maybe as well as they could have but I
If there was a way looking forward, and it isn't just in this situation, but in other charter situations where the animosity builds over time and it's just not as positive a relationship as it could be, I'd like to see it moving forward.
But I do have to say, this population has special needs and special services that the school's working really hard, and I appreciate the direction to improve English language services, personal counseling services, and things that this population needs to succeed.
Those are just sort of some highlights of comments.
And again, these are schools in existence that are coming before us because SHAS required them to come before us at this point.
Thank you.
I have a clarification question.
Is this the same charter proposal that was brought to CDE in 2015 and just replicated and cut up?
There are new, clean, separate four proposals, but they're the same proposals for all four, correct?
Okay, and and then my other question is on the the other desk goals in the area Are there other desk goals that these districts who denied?
that I have available for students Who are at risk to attend?
I don't know that offhand.
I can take it take a look and see if there are do you know Laura?
There should be right.
Oh That was the chart.
I didn't say sure.
Okay, I Think I got the answer.
It was on the chart.
Okay.
Thank you
Yeah, I'd like to ask, how much of your instruction is online?
Maybe the school directors could talk about this.
I wasn't quite clear how much was really online, how much was face-to-face, how you mix together the face-to-face with the online.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
Classes that, well, not classes.
So students can choose a textbook or they can choose online platforms.
However, our support sessions are face-to-face.
So it's a blended model.
We don't have teachers that meet with students much over the internet or anything like that.
So our instructional piece is live in our learning centers.
Okay, so there's textbook and there are, you know, there is some instruction on our online courses as well.
And then we have the additional backup support sessions.
Right, so it's very different from an online charter.
It's very different.
Because most of our supports are in our learning centers.
Okay, thank you.
Other board member questions?
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you.
I think there's clearly a need for a school like this.
There's obviously interest because we've seen the numbers increase.
But I also think that because we are so far away, we do need to have a complete picture.
And this is mainly directed to the department.
You know, board members, you happen to know the area very well.
I know we've had other schools that have come before us where I know the area very well.
And one of the things that I've, a comment that I've made in the past is I think it's important for the department to help us see what you're seeing when you're going through all the materials by making sure that we also get the complete picture.
So in the past we've had proponents that have come up with API to justify their gains or their performance.
Today we had a charter school that had some limited data.
What I thought was very interesting was that they had a,
disproportionate number of Native American students.
We've never seen so many students serve more than 5% per each of these schools.
And so for me, that would have been a very interesting data point to see how are Native American students performing compared to other schools in the area.
You did some comparison, but it was at an aggregate, not by student group.
You have a large number of Latino students.
I also thought it was interesting that it was Hispanic, Latino, Mexican American.
But when we look at our data, that's all one group.
It's Latino, I prefer Latino over Hispanic, but it's Latino Hispanic.
And so just having a better and a clean understanding of the data would have been very helpful, including some of the major schools in the community.
And I really think that that's on us.
So that's on, well, one, if we authorize it, we are the ones that should be communicating with the other LEAs, but also holding and making sure that that data makes sense to us.
You know, I used to do the charter, I was a liaison for charter schools when I was at LAUSD.
And if our proponents didn't have the information, we would make sure they had it before they came before the board.
And so I think that it's important for that to be like some kind of internal control that happens where you're communicating with proponents, making sure they have a very, a presentation that addresses some of the concerns you heard not only today, but you've heard over and over in terms of what data are they coming forth with,
Is it a data that provides a complete picture and if they don't then the department can so that we are being very Educated informed when we make our decisions.
Thank you I just have a question or two for the petitioner.
I
So the first one is about the dashboard alternative school status, which I know you're eligible.
So if 70% are our most vulnerable students, and that's who you're serving, but parents are the primary instructional deliverers, according to the petition, and we've got more than half of the population that you serve to be low income,
What does that look like?
How does a working parent, for example, in a low income family deliver instruction to their students?
So again, 90% of our students are in junior high and high school and we do offer supports
at our location for students that don't have the, we do have parents who obviously can't support their students and that's why we are there to support them.
Yes, there are parents who want to be more involved and we really
feel that in our model there is an increase in their engagement with their students and their students' education because they do come to school and they do see how impactful their support for their students can be.
And so while not all students have that, we do fill in when that's not available at home.
And again, to piggyback on that, we are blended models.
So with each student, we take into consideration the parent involvement.
Are we able to get a hold of the parents?
Are they living in a hotel?
And then we supplement what we need to do to get them on track.
And you've heard that from our students.
you've heard it from the teachers as well but we do individually get to know each one of the students.
Our counselors spend quite a bit of time with each new student and so do our principals.
They have one-on-one meetings with them and then we create the instruction that they need specifically.
So if you're living in a hotel room you're not going to have anything.
We become
with this incredible staff, we become the surrogate parents.
And we take on that role for them.
And it's not something that I think you can take nationally and run with it.
It's just something that we have a niche that we do really well.
And that's how we deal with that.
And when the parents are there, they're honest about what they can do and what they want more support on.
And so it's a group, collaborative engagement.
So again.
We take on what parents can't.
We found some parents that weren't formerly engaged are now more engaged and taking on more role.
But I mean, we do say it's the parents, but there are kids too.
So we take on a huger portion than probably what our petition does state.
You're right.
And the other portion when we're talking about EL learners, the one thing that we're able to do with the parents who are involved is when we're having those weekly meetings, the parents are there and we're training the parents.
So we're teaching the parents how to teach.
and we're also increasing their capacity as well.
So it's not, we have a very specific and unique situation where we do have the ability to collaborate very strongly with the parents in that situation and give them the tools that they need to better themselves so that they can better their student or their child.
But we recognize that after a certain point in a student's education, parents just aren't equipped.
That's why we have single-subject teachers.
Every location has a single-subject math, single-subject science, single-subject English to take on.
you know, the teaching that can't be done by a parent.
I mean, no parent.
I mean, I'm really good at math and science, but history is not my strong point.
I couldn't teach my own child history.
So that's why we pool in all the supports we have.
Thank you.
And then I have a question.
There are letters in our correspondence file, a date of July 6, where you respond to the specific
requests for information.
And the responses are, and I'm paraphrasing, we'll be happy to address it prior to the deadline.
So most of them were pretty like a one sentence addition.
And some of them were laws that had happened since we wrote the petition.
So they weren't even part of the Ed Code at the time.
So we knew, of course, we're going to add in what wasn't
Around before the petition was first created.
So yeah, we're happy to make those additions Okay, and just this is just a comment but in on page 11 petition for the Bulton Center, there's a statement made that And I'll read it
that the school has a considerable population of Chumash Indians enrolled, but yet there's no information.
So just a comment is just that when statements or claims are made, as a reader, I appreciate having substantiation to back up the claim.
And there's just, in that example, I'd love to know what the numbers are of students.
And I heard percentages and I see projections of percentages, but what does that mean as far as actual students?
Dealing with small numbers of people.
So that would be helpful in any future correspondence.
Thank you.
I'm taking notes up here.
That's why I'm so nervous.
Board Member Rucker.
Okay, so first of all, as it relates to the work you're doing on developing parents in parental capacity, I need to say I know that that's not something new.
There was a time when public schools received funding through a Nell Soto grant for teachers to do at-home visits and teach parents things like reading literacy and activities that they could do with their kids at home to
to do work and help parents become more engaged with their students.
And so there are a lot of programs that do those things.
So I'm not saying that I doubt that there's a way to develop that work.
What I'm saying is, but you didn't spell it out in your petition.
So I was happy to hear you say just now that you recognize that there's probably some detail that, as has been pointed out by board member Ortiz-Leone,
We need to have a clearer picture of what you're doing, not just what you've been successful at doing, but in taking on and expanding this program, what it means that's going to be in addition to what you're doing now, what it is you're taking on and what you recognize.
You're doing not only to develop your capacity to do the work with your students who come to you at your resource centers, but what it means to build out and develop the capacity of the parents who are going to be a critical part of doing this work for students.
I didn't see that.
I learned more about you.
The reason why I didn't ask questions before the public hearing began, before the testimony began, is I wanted to hear what people had to say.
I learned more about your program and what you were doing from listening to the public testimony than what I actually read in your plan.
I don't have enough in the plan to understand what you're doing.
And to quote again from Dr. Richard Elmore, if it's not in the core, if you didn't write it down, it doesn't exist.
Thank you.
Board member Williams.
I just have a question in the process.
So the six districts that you were petitioning to, what was the process like?
Was it because so much of this is relational as well as technical.
So did they work with you or did they only read the petition?
They invited you to the public hearing and they gave you a report and they made a decision.
Yes, and I reached out many, many times.
I mean, I've lived in the community for a long time.
Previously, I was the Santa Barbara County PTA president, and I'm currently on the state board PTA board, so I engaged with the county many times, with Bill Cerrone previously many times.
So I have good working relationship in that capacity, but as far as anything to do with charter, it was very just,
We don't want to talk to, you know, I invited, I've invited them out.
I invited every district to come meet with us to sit down and see how we're engaging with our students.
I think one district, Santa Maria did, Santa Maria came and they just kind of walked through.
They didn't really stay and they left.
And the special education person really wanted to further engage with our special education team and then
She was really happy, getting contacts.
And then I asked our team, have you heard from her?
Then nothing.
It was like someone told her, don't bother, is how I felt.
And I kept reaching out.
I was very friendly.
I kept trying to figure out what can we do.
Because like we've said, we have counselors and principals who are sending students to us.
And they're their hardest students.
I get it.
But if they're sending us their hardest students,
Do they not want to engage and find out what we're doing with those students?
And then Santa Barbara's superintendent unannounced walked into the Santa Barbara Resource Center.
He stayed and talked to Allison.
She could probably speak more to that, but didn't really observe much.
And so that was it.
So they could say they did it, but I didn't feel like they engaged.
I sent them multiple requests for meetings and engagement.
And the same with the county.
I get along really well, like I said, in the PTA capacity with the county superintendent.
But in the charter capacity, there was just no engagement.
It was difficult because our students, it was hard on our families and students to read in the newspaper these negative things about their school that they felt so strongly for.
So it's been a difficult process.
I feel it mostly for my kids though, because they're the ones that were hurt, you know.
We can handle it now.
Yeah, I wonder if any of the district or county people want to comment.
If not, I understand.
But, you know, we haven't had enough, any interaction with them.
Pardon?
Yeah, county, any comment?
And these lawyers, these are the first time I'm seeing these lawyers.
I probably shouldn't say that, but there was a different lawyer that came to the ACCS that's been part of the process for them the whole time.
This is the first time I'm seeing them.
And like at the ACCS, there was someone else that we've seen.
I'm just trying to give the county some time.
I know.
I'm going to ask board member Williams, maybe we can get a motion on the floor at least here.
So I have some thoughts that I'll share having listened to all of this conversation.
Some of it's a little bit surprising to me because I know that first the ACCS recommended approval and there was only one no.
The CDE recommends approval and my understanding is that CDE staff
and state board staff know this charter well because it's a state board charter and has been for three years.
And they have, my impression is that they have tremendous confidence in the leadership and the importance of the work that this charter does with the students that choose, the students and families that choose to come to this charter for all kinds of reasons of not feeling like they fit in or do well in a regular traditional kind of setting, even a traditional charter setting.
So they make this choice.
And as I hear the conversation, and you can correct me if I'm wrong here, but I hear more concerns
about the lack of what was in the agenda item and in the petition in terms of the detail that some of you wanted, the demographics more clearly spelled out, the instructional model more clearly explained in terms of how much support students get on an on-site location, how they get that.
There was some, the description of the instructional model where there,
where 90% of their students are in middle school and high school, that wasn't clear to me either to start with.
It sounded like it was a, you know, K-12.
And so that was important information, because obviously that changes how much the parent interaction is needed.
There were things like that that could have been done better, I think, in the petition and in the CDE agenda item.
I think maybe they weren't.
I'm going to speculate here.
I think maybe they weren't because they were already a state board authorized school.
Okay, let me finish.
I think that having them being already a state board authorized school may have, and a high comfort level that I've heard by the staff with the school and the operation, that there may have been a sense of, oh, we already know this school and don't necessarily need to, you know, an unintentional oversight, not something deliberately done.
And so what I didn't hear in most of the questions is a real concern about the finances, the operations, the governance, or the student academic achievement, or the work that they're doing with students to capture them and move them forward.
I heard more concerns with why didn't we get this information?
Why didn't we get this information?
I didn't put that together.
I think that the petitioner and the staff heard that we want to make sure that we have all the information that we need to make a decision in a petition, but I didn't hear any concerns about operations, governance, finances, or students that would make me think that we should not go ahead and reauthorize or authorize these schools as new charters under the Shasta rule so that they come into compliance with the Shasta ruling.
So I'm going to go ahead and make a motion that we authorize these four charters.
Is there a second?
Yeah, the motion is moving the CDE recommendation.
Yes.
OK, so I just need to say, Board Member Williams, I asked specifically when I made my comments, was the preparation on this item, were there so many gaps because the staff already had a relationship with and knew this charter because it was a board authorized charter?
Please correct me if I'm wrong, but the answer was no, that they looked at this as a new charter.
They did not consider the things that you just laid out based on their existing relationship with the people who are managing and governing this charter.
So, no.
They were not looking at the charter and did their evaluation based on their existing relationship.
Now, if I misunderstood your answer, please correct me.
But I thought because I voiced my frustration about what I was looking at based on the fact that I already knew the people submitting the charter were already a charter management organization that had an existing board relationship with.
And Member Rucker, I may have been getting a piece of cake when you did that, so I apologize if I didn't hear you ask that.
Okay, let's move on and do we have any discussion on the motion?
Yes, Board Member Sandoval.
I still don't I don't have the confidence to support the the motion just I feel like we don't have complete information of the context of each of these Schools, and I also read very carefully the county office analysis, which I thought was very clear factual and thorough
So I just wanted to state The holes that I feel are present and I don't feel confident that I can support it Because I want to do what's right for for students in these communities and I don't have enough information Based on what was presented today to be able to do that Any other board comments at this point, all right board member Valdez I
I, too, read the reports and even though there wasn't a relationship, if you will, in terms of let's work together, let's figure this out, staff did diligent work in all six settings to determine whether or not it was viable in all of the different areas.
And so I, too, feel that I can't support this at this time.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
I agree that there are some gaps.
I think where I'm really conflicted is, to some extent, we should also take some responsibility for the level of information that comes to us.
And I do like what Santa Barbara County, what they used was very thorough.
It showed the educational plan, every single section, and why it was sufficient or insufficient.
And I think that we should take that template so that we can also track it.
In particular, this charter, since it's authorized by us, so we should have that level of information.
But I don't
Know that I want to put the blame on the petitioner for something that we might not have asked him to have Prepared and and so that's where I'm conflicted I don't want to hold them accountable for not giving us a full picture when in fact it was probably our responsibility to have that full picture
Just a quick comment here in the conversation.
I mean, I do.
I, too, am seeing inconsistencies as these are coming to us.
And I would just really encourage CDE staff maybe to work with liaisons on some consistency in the processes or clarity in processes so that we're clear when we're moving forward.
We have the information that we need to be able to do the full analysis.
I agree that, you know, I don't with
Member Feliz Ortiz Lacone.
I don't think it's we should be punishing the petitioners For a process that I think we need to probably update a little bit more Okay, so we're ready to vote I think we ought to call the rolls Okay super Jaden gray my cursed hi
Lisa Ortiz-Lacon?
Aye.
Patricia Rucker?
No.
Nikki Sandoval?
Eileen Strauss?
No.
Ting Sung?
Aye.
Karen Valdez?
No.
Trish Williams?
Aye.
The motion passes.
Okay, the motion passes.
So the charters are approved.
So now I'm going to read it.
We are continuing today's meeting
until 8.30 a.m.
tomorrow morning.
Tomorrow morning, the board will first start with closed session.
So this is read because we don't want to bring in the audience and have them have to leave, you know, we have closed session.
So we are continuing today's meeting and we will continue at 8.30 on Thursday.